THANK EVERYONE FOR ATTENDING
THIS CRITICAL HEARING FOCUS ON
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS DURING THE PANDEMIC AT
TODAY'S HEARING BRINGS TOGETHER
FIVE SENATE COMMITTEES TO FOCUS
ON THE CRISIS THAT EXISTS.
EVERY NIGHT ON THE STREETS OF
CALIFORNIA IN BIG CITIES AND
SMALL WE WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE TO
THE PARTNERSHIP OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS THEIR STAFF
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE IN THE PARTNERSHIP
AND CHAIR SCOTT WIENER IS WITH
US TODAY WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SENATE BUDGET BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE- SENATOR EGGMAN
IS WITH US TODAY GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO SENATE.
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR AND
SENATOR CABALLERO WHO WILL BE
WITH US TODAY AND OF COURSE TO
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY SENATOR
HER TITLE WE WELCOME ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
TO THIS MULTI COMMITTEE HEARING
IN OF COURSE TO THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WE WELCOME YOU. BUT FEAR BEFORE
WE TURN IT OVER TO OUR CHAIRS
FOR OPENING REMARKS AND WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO COVER SOME
HOUSEKEEPING MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
CRITICAL HEARING. IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN OR
MERGING SEA AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE'RE GONNA NEED A
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERING
SITTING HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES TODAY. IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
BE ABLE. TO ADVANCE NORMAL
PRACTICES AIMED AT THAT WILL
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. TODAY WE EXPECT TO
HAVE TO MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WILL SAY GOOD MORNING
TO SENATOR SKINNER AND SENATOR-
BURKE IN A FEW. MOMENTS IN THE
SENATE CHAMBER HE- TODAY WE ARE
HAVE SO ROB. HERTZBERG SENATOR
NEEDS. TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
ALWAYS CENTER DEBATE INCOMING
CURTAIL RITUAL ABOUT SENATOR
MIKE. HER TIE JONES PAN EGGMAN
IN SENATOR MELINDA IS OUR
PARTICIPATING HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. WE ALSO VARIOUS
EXPERTS JOINING US WERE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
FOR OUR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
WE'RE GOING TO ASK RESPECTFULLY
TO PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS WE ASK THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED
THAT YOU USE THAT RAISE THE
HAND FEATURE N THE PROGRAM
ONCE RECOGNIZE WE'RE GONNA ASK
YOU TO PLEASE SPEAK. PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN AT ALL TIMES BEEN
STATE YOUR NAME THEN YOU'RE
GONNA BE READY TO GO TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEES TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE DID NEEDED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC D. TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ARE ALLOWED. IN
MOBILE- USING A TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. VIA THE PHONE
LINE TODAY WE WELCOME YOU THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
ACTIVISTS TO GIVE THAT PHONE
NUMBER OUT NOW AND WILL ALSO
APPEAR ON YOUR SCREEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE TODAY
TODAY'S NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR THAT ACCESS CODE IS.
TWO NINE SIX ONE EIGHT FOUR TWO
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES AND
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE IN ORDER TO OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. ALL THE TO
DO'S ARE RIGHT THERE. FOR
TODAY'S ROSE GOING TO BE HERE
ALL THE PANELS OF WITNESSES. ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. RIGHT NOW WE
DON'T EXPECT ANY CHALLENGES BUT
I'D LIKE TO JUST THROUGHOUT
THIS NOTE. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAD THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO BETTER
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY VIA THE
TELEPHONE TODAY THE PHONE
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
WITH THE ACCESS CODE TWO NINE
SIX. ONE EIGHT FOUR TWO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MEDIALLY FOLLOWING IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING EACH OF OUR PANELS.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE A
TRANSITION TO OPENING
STATEMENTS IN QUICKLY. IN BIG
CITIES AND SMALL HOMELESS
RESIDENTS SLEEP ON THE STREETS
EVERY NINE. HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND RESIDENTS. LIVE ON THE
STREETS EACH DAY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. MORE THAN ANY
STATE IN THE NATION. AND AS I
SAID BEFORE AND I THINK THAT
ALL OF YOU AGREE IT'S SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE. IT'S DISGRACEFUL
AND IS THE FAILURE OF
GOVERNMENT AT ALL LEVELS. THE
COBY NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE
THE SITUATION ON OUR STREETS
EVEN WORSE. AS RESIDENTS OFTEN
HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES AND SUPPLIES THEY NEED
TO STAY HEALTHY. IN ADDITION A
RECENT REPORT BY THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE HAS
HIGHLIGHTED SERIOUS CONCERNS
SERIOUS CONCERNS AT ALL LEVELS
OF CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT ABOUT
IT JUST JOINTED APPROACH
TACKLING THIS CRISIS. EVEN
THOUGH THERE HAS BEEN RECORD
RESOURCES INVESTED IT'S BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED THAT THE STATE AND
LOCAL RESPONSE IS BEING
HAMPERED BECAUSE AND I QUOTE
THERE IS NO SINGLE ENTITY. IN
CALIFORNIA OVERSEEN EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND THERE
ISN'T A SINGLE STATEWIDE
STRATEGIC PLAN. FURTHER THE
AUDITORS REPORT STATES THAT
LOCAL AGENCIES SERVING HOMELESS
DO NOT KEEP TRACK OF WHERE THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
BEING INVESTED. ARE INVESTED
IN. THE FAILED TO FOLLOW
FEDERAL GUIDELINES IN DON'T
TRACK OUTCOMES. NINE BILLION
SEES CONCERNS THIS MORNING NOT
AS IN A GOTCHA BUT BECAUSE THE
STAKES ARE SO HIGH. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HUMAN LIVES. ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT ARE MOVING
FAST TO TACKLE THIS CRISIS. IN
THE AUDIT DOES ADVANCE POINTS
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT. END I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT ALL INVOLVED
IN THIS FIGHT ARE DOING THIS
BECAUSE THEY WANT BETTER
OUTCOMES. THE ONE INEFFECTIVE
STRATEGY TO TACKLE THE CRISIS
WE WANT A CONSISTENT APPROACH
FROM TOP TO BOTTOM. AND THEY
WANT TAXPAYER MONEY TO BE
INVESTED SMARTLY. THROUGH THIS
HEARING INTO THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS IN THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO DIG DEEPLY THIS MORNING.
INTO RECENT STATE AND LOCAL
EFFORTS HAD TO BE TO COMBAT THE
CRISIS THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS IN FOCUS ON THE
PARTICULAR CHALLENGES. FISHING
AT FACING TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
THE COMMITTEES WILL FIRST
RECEIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AND THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGH AT THREE
TWO. PROJECTS PROJECT ROOM KEY
AND HOME KEY SECOND THE
COMMITTEES WILL HEAR FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE ADOPTED
STRATEGIES TO CONFRONT
HOMELESSNESS IN ADDRESS THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES WITHIN
THEIR JURISDICTION. DURING THIS
PANDEMIC FINALLY THE COMMITTEES
WILL HEAR FROM DIRECT SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND INDIVIDUALS WITH-
TRUE EXPERIENCE AND WHAT IS AND
IS NOT WORKING WHEN IT COMES TO
THE SPECIFIC CHALLENGES.
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH FACE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
EACH OF OUR PANELISTS NOW AND
TURN IT OVER TO EACH OTHER
COMMITTEE CHAIRS. THE START US
OUT WITH OPENING COMMENTS WE'RE
NOW GOING TO YIELD THE FLOOR
OVER TO SENATOR WIENER CHAIR OF
THE SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIR. GOOD MORNING THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. BY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS CHAIRMAN AND YOU
FOR ALL US WORKING TOGETHER. ON
AND FOR- YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS AND OF COURSE COVE
IT HAS SHOWN A HUGE LIGHT. ON
SO MANY PRE EXISTING PROBLEMS
ARE LARGELY NOT NEW PROBLEMS
ARE PROBLEMS OF ALWAYS BEEN
WITH US- AND NOW THEY'RE EITHER
JUST GETTING WORSE OR THERE ARE
MORE VISIBLE- AND THE QUESTION
FOR US IS- AS WE MOVE PASSAGE
PANDEMIC WHICH WE WILL. ARE
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE OLD BAD
NORMAL OR WE'RE GOING TO DO
WHAT IT TAKES- TO SOLVE. THESE
PROBLEMS THAT AGAIN HAVE BEEN
FESTERING FOR MANY MANY MANY
MANY YEARS- AND ARE NOW BEING
SHOWN FOR WHAT THEY ARE AND THE
HARM THAT THEY'RE CAUSING INTO
CALIFORNIANS. EVERY DAY AND
AMONG THOSE- IS HOUSING AND WE
SEE THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE
WITH. PEOPLE STILL CAN'T AFFORD
HOUSING HOUSING IS STILL
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE IN SOME
WAYS MORE EXPENSIVE. PEOPLE ARE
STILL GETTING AFFECTED AND
BECOMING HOMELESS- AND ARE
HOMELESS- NEIGHBORS ARE ARE
BECOMING SADLY MORE NUMEROUS-
THAN THEY WERE. BEFORE AND I
KNOW THAT A BIG FOCUS IS THAT
HEARING- AND I SUPPORT THIS IS
THE TRIAGE. OF HELPING PEOPLE
WHO ARE HOMELESS WHETHER
THEY'RE ON OUR STREETS LIVING
IN CARS- COUCHSURFING- OR
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE WITH
THE TRIAGE. OF HELPING GETTING
THEM STABILIZE AND THE HOUSING.
THAT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
BUT WE ALSO AS WE DO THAT WE
CAN NEVER LOSE SIGHT OF WHY IT
IS A CALIFORNIA HAS SO MANY
HOMELESS PEOPLE. CALIFORNIA HAS
13% OF. THE POPULATION OF THIS
COUNTRY THIRTEEN PERCENT. BY
25% OF THE NATION'S HOMELESS
POPULATION AND A MAJORITY OF
THE NATION'S UNSHELTERED
HOMELESS POPULATION. 13% OF THE
POPULATION IS COUNTRY BUT
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF THE
NATION'S HOMELESS POPULATION
AND A MAJORITY. OF THE
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS POPULATION
I SAID THAT TWICE BECAUSE IT IS
SHOCKING AND APPALLING. AND
IT'S NOT JUST RANDOM. THAT WE
HAVE SUCH A DISPROPORTIONATE
HOMELESS POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA COMPARED THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY THAT IS RANDOMLY
HAPPENED. IT WAS AN ACT OF GOD
IT WASN'T JUST RANDOM IT WAS
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA. IT HAS A
PROFOUND HOUSING SHORTAGE
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS HAD
ADOPTED AN AWFUL HOUSING POLICY
OVER THE LAST FIFTY YEARS. WE
DECIDED THAT IT'S NOT A
PRIORITY TO HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE WHO NEED IT AND NOT
JUST PUSHES EVERYONE DOWN IT
MEANS THAT FAMILIES THAT USED
TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO BUY A
HOME CAN'T AFFORD TO BUY A HOME
ANYMORE MEANS OF FAMILIES AND
MAY HAVE HAD A LARGE ENOUGH
APARTMENT FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR
FIVE. NOW HAVE A VERY SMALL
APARTMENT OR HAVE TO DOUBLE UP
WITH OTHER FAMILIES. SENATE
MEANS THAT PEOPLE WHO IN THE
PAST WILL BE ABLE TO AT LEAST
AFFORD SOME SORT OF APARTMENT
WHETHER IT'S A SINGLE ROOM OR A
SMALL APARTMENT- OR WITH A
ROOMMATE. ARE NOW LIVING IN
CARS OR COUCH SURFING OR ON THE
STREETS OR IN A HOMELESS
SHELTER IT PUSHES EVERYONE
DOWN- AND SO AS WE WORK ON THIS
TRIAGE. TO HELP GET PEOPLE OFF
THE STREETS. LET'S KEEP IN MIND
ALWAYS AT THE BROADER WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING IN THE SENATE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE ON HOUSING-
ONE ON TRYING TO SPUR THE
PRODUCTION OF MORE HOUSING.
WHEN TRYING TO REMOVE THE
OBSTACLES TO HAVING ENOUGH
HOUSING. THAT THAT TIES
DIRECTLY. INTO PREVENTING
HOMELESSNESS FROM HAPPENING IN
THE FIRST PLACE IT IS MUCH
BETTER TO PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING. THEN THEY HAVE TO
TRIAGE. ONCE IT'S HAPPENED SO
IT'S ALWAYS REMEMBER THAN A
CONNECTION THAT'S WHAT'S SO
GREAT ABOUT THIS HEARING NUMBER
INTER CONNECTING EVERYTHING.
AND FINALLY I JUST WANT TO NOTE%
THAT I'M REALLY THRILLED THAT
WE ARE LOOKING SPECIFICALLY.
AROUND HOMELESSNESS AND AMONG
OUR MOST AT RISK YOUTH. ARE
HOMELESS. YOUTH YOUTH EXITING
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM YOUTH
EXITING THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM- WE KNOW THAT MOST
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES DO NOT EVEN
HAVE YOU SPECIFIC HOMELESS
PROGRAMS. WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
GET MORE RESOURCES OVER THE
YEARS FROM THE STATE I'M GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK.
WE'RE TAKING ANOTHER RUN AT IT
THIS YEAR. WITH A SPECIFIC
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT HOUSING
FOR MOST AT RISK YOUTH- FOR TO
DISCUSSIONS TODAY TO THE WORK I
HAD THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER SENATOR IN FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE. AND CENTER
WIENER BROUGHT UP A GREAT POINT
WE HAVE EVERY COMMITTEE WHETHER
IT'S THE FISCAL. END OR THE
POLICY HERE IN ONE ROOM FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN SPEAKING THAT WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR ACHING. SHE IS THE
CHAIRWOMAN FOR SENATE BUDGET
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THREE
FOCUS ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES BETTER CHAIR IT IS AN
HONOR TO PARTNER WITH YOU. ON
THIS CRITICAL HEARING THANK.
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK TO FLOOR
IS YOURS MA'AM. THANK YOU MUCH.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR LEADING
THIS TODAY I THANK ALL OF MY
SENATORS FOR BEING HERE. AND
EVERYBODY WHO WILL BE MAKING A
PRESENTATION- SO I GIVE BLOOD
MY PROFESSION HAS BEEN AS A
SOCIAL WORKER ANDIN TEACHING
ABOUT SOCIAL WORK WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT THE RIVER RIGHT AND
I THINK AT THIS POINT RIGHT
NOW. WE FIND OURSELVES IN THE
POINT WHERE WE ARE JUST TRYING
TO PULL AS MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
DROWNING OUT OF THE RIVER AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN IT IS EXHAUSTING.
OUR SYSTEM WAS NOT DESIGNED IF
YOU THINK ABOUT IT WHEN WE WENT
TO HOLD LIKE LET'S LET'S LET'S
CREATE A WHOLE SHELTER SYSTEM.
THAT WAS ANOTHER BANDAID TO A
LARGER ISSUE RIGHT I MEAN
DEVELOPING MORE SHELTERS.
SHOULD NOT BE OUR GOAL OF
FINDING PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO
LIVE IN A IN A MORE PERMANENT
FAMILY COMMUNITY STRUCTURE.
SHOULD BE OUR GOAL AND AS LONG
AS WE KEEP JUST PULLING PEOPLE
OUT OF THE RIVER VERSUS GOING
UPSTREAM. AND IDENTIFYING WHY
SO MANY ARE FALLING IN. IT WILL
WE'LL NEVER BE ABLE TO TRULY
MAKE. GAINS ON THIS ISSUE- I
COME AT THIS FROM BOTH A- WE
NEED TO DEVELOP MORE HOUSING
AND IF YOU JUST THINK ABOUT.
THE ANALOGYOF A BUYING IN BUK
RATE AND PEOPLE GO TO. TO
BIGGER BOX STORES BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HAVE LOWER
PRICES BECAUSE THERE'S MORE OF
THEM. VERSUS IF YOU GO TO A
SMALL LITTLE BOUTIQUE YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA BE PAYING MORE
BECAUSE IT HAS MORE VALUE
BECAUSE THERE ARE FEWER OF
THEM. WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THAT WITH HOUSING WITH THE MORE
WE HAVE THE PRICES WILL COME
DOWN. ON PEOPLE COULD STILL
HAVE THE BIG MASS OF A SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES NO ONE SAYING THAT
YOU CAN'T. BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE
MOE SUPPLY. WE HAVE OUR MORE
YOUTH ON THE STREET BECAUSE
FAMILIES ARE MORE UNSTABLE THE
MORE UNSTABLE FAMILIES ARE THE
MORE YOU THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE ON. ON THE STREET SO FROM
A MENTAL HEALTH PERSPECTIVE. WE
HAVE TO START ADDRESSING AT
THIS FROM THE FAMILY LEVEL. IN
OUR SCHOOLS. AND THEN ALL THE
WAY THROUGH THE SYSTEM. IT IS-
IT IS. IT IS IT IS SOMEONE WHO
COMES FROM A FAITH TRADITION IT
FEELS LIKE A SIN EVERY TIME I
DRIVE DOWN THIS THREE. AND SEE
SOME PEOPLE. ON THE STREETS A
CLEARLY MENTALLY ILL CHILDREN
ARE SENIORS- WE ARE CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
STRONG. SO WE HAVE WE HAVE WE
HAVE OF. A LARGER BIG BOX OF
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE TO SOLVE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS I THINK WE
HAVE EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO
CAN ACTUALLY ONE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION I
LOOK FORWARD TO US COMING UP
WITH REAL SOLUTIONS. NOT
CONTINUE TO JUST PUT BANDAIDS-AND PULL PEOPLE FROM THE RIVER.
THAT WILL EXHAUST ALL OF US-
AND EVERYBODY COMING OUT OF THE
RIVER IT DOESN'T COME OUT THE
WAY THEY FELL IN. WE HAVE TO GO
UPSTREAM WE HAVE TO BECAUSE IT.
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES.
THAT THAT EXIST IN OUR SOCIETY
IN ORDER TO REALLY MAKE GAINS
ON THIS. AND UNTIL WE MAKE
GAMES ON THIS. CALIFORNIA IT
WILL NEVER GET IT WHAT THE NONE
OF US WILL EVER. BE ABLE TO
BEAT ARE FULL AND SELVES AND IF
WE CAN'T BE OUR FULL SELVES
THAN OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
SOCIETY CAN NEVER BE OUR FULL
SELVES. SO I AM A- I AM.
THANKFUL FOR THIS HEARING
TODAY. I AM. GRATIFIED FOR MY
COLLEAGUES TO BE HERE AND WE
CAN ALL JOIN ARMS. ACROSS THE
AISLE ACROSS POLICIES ACROSS
BUDGET. TO FINALLY REALLY MAKE
PROGRESS ON THIS ISSUE FACING
CALIFORNIA TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR
ARE SO LUCKY TO HAVE YOU IN THE
SENATE T WITH YOUR BACKGROUND
YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR THOSE VERY ELOQUENT
OPENING WORDS. AS WE STATED WE
HAVE THE TO FISCAL. COMMITTEES
HERE WITH US TODAY- AS WELL AS
THEIR CHAIRMAN- TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER THEIR PERSPECTIVE WE WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO CHAIRWOMAN
SENATOR ANA CABALLERO. SHE IS
THE CHAIR OF SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER FOUR THAT
FOCUSES ON STATE
ADMINISTRATION. AND I GENERAL
GOVERNMENT WE'RE GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO MADAM CHAIR FOR ANY
OPENING REMARKS MADAM CHAIR
IT'S GOOD YOU SEEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CARE I'M I AM HAPPY TO BE HERE-
NOT HAPPY TO BE TALKING ABOUT
THIS ISSUE THAT. WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT FOR SO LONG LET
ME JUST SAY THAT- BAD. THE R.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE.
OUR BUDGET IS IN REALLY GOOD
SHAPE BUT IT'S NOT JUST AN
ISSUE OF THROWING MONEY AT AT
THE PROBLEM IT'S AN ISSUE OF
HAVING REAL METRICS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE WHAT THE
BEST PRACTICES ARE SO THAT. WE
CAN MAKE SOME CHANGES IN HOW WE
WE'VE WE'VE SPENT CLOSE TO
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
PAST NUMBER OF YEARS AND STE
AND I LOOK AROUND AND I DON'T
SEE ANY CHANGE QUITE FRANKLY IT
SEEMS TO BE GETTING WORSE I'M
AND THEN THE PANDEMIC HAD A LOT
TO DO WITH IT BUT QUITE FRANKLY
I THINK ARE OUR SYSTEM HAS NOT
WORKED I'M ANXIOUS TO HEAR THE
WHAT WITNESSES TODAY AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND BRING IN THIS COMMITTEE
TOGETHER. I'M SURE THANK YOU-
THIS WOULD NOT BE HAPPENING
WITHOUT YOU AND THE OTHER
CHAIRS IN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND WE SO APPRECIATE BEING WITH
YOU TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
COMMITTEES WE WILL BE HEARING
FROM MATURE WOMAN HER TITLE
HERE IN A FEW MOMENTS SHE HAS.
ANOTHER MEETING AND WE KNEW
THAT SHE WAS GOING TO BE A BIT
LATE I UNDERSTANDTHAT IS A
BUSY TIME OF YEAR. SO
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WOULD NOW
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE INTO
OUR FIRST PANEL. AT SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ON THE PANEL EACH
PANELIST WILL BE GIVING REMARKS
FOR THREE TO FIVE MINUTES. WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO DO
BECAUSE- EACH OF THESE NEXT
PANELISTS. ARE GONNA HAVE OTHER
MEETINGS TODAY WHAT WITH
ACTIVATED DO IS HEAR FROM EACH
OF THE PANELISTS. THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO EACH
OF THE SENATORS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. AND TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
WELL FIRST HERE FROM ALLEY
SUDDEN SHE'S A DEPUTY SECRETARY
OF HOMELESSNESS- THE CALIFORNIA
HOMELESS COORDINATING FINANCE
COUNCIL- THEN WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM KIM JOHNSON SHE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM GUSTAVO
VELASQUEZ HE'S A DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. ALL ARE
WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD TO BE
ABLE TO TACKLE THIS CRISIS. THE
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN THE
COMMITTEES WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO TURN THE HEARING
OVER TO ALLEE SUTTON. THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
HOMELESSNESS CALVET- OF
CALIFORNIA HOMELESS CORNING IF
ANYTHING COUNCIL. BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY I MISS SUTTON IS ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR THAT LONG TITLE HE SAID.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE UP
TO. FIVE MINUTES AND WE'LL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT AS
YOU GET CLOSE TO THAT FIVE
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING. MORNING
ARE YOU. HEARING HELLO. WE ARE
NOT HEARING IN A IN THE
COMMITTEE TODAY OKAY WILL. I
HAVE I'M. I ET THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT I'M THAT. AS I SAID I AM.
VERY. IT IS A SERVICE THAT MANY.
WELL WHY. HE HAD ALL HER. ME
INCREASE MY ARMY RATIONS. IT
MIGHT ALL RIGHT YEAH. THE
LEGISLATURE. AND ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE- HELLO QUITE
RENDON YOU. MARCH TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TO SIXTY AFTER AUTHOR.
H. YEAH OR IN MY MILLION
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
NINETEEN REGENCY FINDING EACH
OF THE STATE M. A. R. AND
THIRTEEN MY CITY. EIGHT HOMER
EMERGENCE AID PROGRAM HE ADDED
A HOMER. HE. ALLOCATED SPACE
AND NEEDS TO ADDRESS OF THE
DRAFT TODAY HE HAS TURNED OVER
FIVE THOUSAND SMALL INCLUDING A
SIX AND I WHEN EAST. WE LIVE
HERE DURING THAT. YEAH WEEK OR
CLOSELY WITH HE REITERATED. AND
THERE IS A IN UTILIZED.
INCREASE OUR IMPACT I AM
HELPING YOU SERVICE IF YOU
EXPERIENCE ON CHILD HOMELESS. I
AM NOT. SURGERY USED TRANSMIT
ON COME NINETEEN. AND OR
ANYBODY. IT WILL BE SHELTERED
PROJECT HE. I NEED HE SAYS THAT
HE'S- I HAVE ST YOU DURING THE-
CITY BY WALKING OUT OF PROBABLY
HE ENTERED HER HOUSE AND CLOSE
REYES AND I CORPORATION FOR
LOCAL. I DON'T AND RIDERS EACH
OF THESE. NON ONE HEARING HOW.
AND PEOPLE IN BY. YOU ARE.
BLACK INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND ALL OF. I HEARD
THIRTY BUCKS. AS MUST BE.
STREETEASY WELL THAT IS GOING
WORKS GRANTED. AND HOW PEOPLE
ARE HOMELESSNESS RESPONSE AND
STUFF. IT IS. A STATE WHERE I
AM AT FACT. THE ACTUAL PLAN I
AM MAJOR. BUT SOME
STRENGTHENING INTERVENTIONS
SHELTERING PROGRAM HOUSING
RIGHT UNDERNEATH OR WE CAN
DRIVE OVER A YES. AT THE HEART
COMMA SHE CLEAR TIME APARTMENTS
MY CHANGE WE WILL SOMETHING.
AND WORKING YOUNG AGE YEAR. ONE
MINUTE HIGHLIGHTS. OTHER NON
NATIONAL. IT DIDN'T WHEN IT IS
ACT ECS ABOUT ANY OTHER
PARTNERS OF OUR STATE MORE
HOMELESS DAY INTEGRATION SYSTEM
OR A GI. A LOT ONLY JACK BROWN
EIGHT MOST IMPORTANTLY ON WHO
ARE RELEASED AND PAR POLICY IT
IS STILL THE GREAT AND OUR
STATE CRISIS. FOR EXAMPLE WILL
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY. HIS USAGE
ACROSS FOR. AND ACROSS. THE
NATION AND WILL BE FOR HER IRAQ
YEAH EDITORIAL JOSH IN OTHER
AND I. AMONG PEOPLE RAISING
HOMELESSNESS THIRTY SO. H. HERE
OFFICE IN OUR WORK WITH PCA AT
AGE YEAH RIGHT ONLINE TOOL
ASKING THE YEAH. COMING OUT OF
THE OFF DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WORKING IN REGIONAL MCCARTY IT
IS FURTHER ALLEGED. AND LONG
TERM THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR YEAH REAL PROGRESS.
RIGHT AGAIN EVERY AND THE
INEVITABLE FOR. TO DRIVE HOME
OR DURING THE- THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR RENDON NAY AND I'LL NOW
TURN MY COLLEAGUES AND THE GOT
HER FRANK HE AT HOME CALIFORNIA
HEARING AID. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAM DEPUTY SECTOR IT'S GREAT
TO HAVE YOU WITH US WE ARE NOW
GONNA BE HERE FROM THE TO OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL. AS
DEPUTY SECRETARY GIVE A THIRTY
THOUSAND FOR VIEW IN NOW WE'RE
GOING TO BE I IT REALLY FOCUS
ON THE EMPLOYMENT WE THE TO
RECEIVE AGE. LET'S TURN OVER TO
DRAW CAME FROM THE OF SOCIAL
THAT YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
MANAGER IN WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
YOU'RE WITH US TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH READING. TO BE HERE AND
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIRS
AND MEMBERS. KEN JOHNSON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
MANAGER TO HOUSING- AND
TRANSISTOR. THE SOCIAL SERVICE
DIRECTOR FROM DEVELOPMENT
OVERSIGHT SIX HOW HOME
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS DIRECTIVES
CANNOT. INDIVIDUALS IN HOMELESS
ARE HOW AND- INCLUDING
PARTICIPANTS OF WORK CHILD
WELFARE COUNTY GENERAL SYSTEM
IN GENERAL RELIEF. NOT ADDRESS
YOU'RE LOOKING TO HEAR. OF THE
PROJECT SERVICE. THE NEWEST
INITIATIVE PROJECT RANKING
DEVELOPED AND IMPLEMENTED LAST.
THIS EFFORT WITH DESIGN TO SIT.
OUR ACTON MADAM WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS- ARE I. T. IS GOING
TO CONTACT YOU NUMBERS IF WE
CAN JUST HAVE YOU TIMES REAL
QUICK- MISS JOHNSON I'M SO
SORRY WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
START OVER WE DIDN'T HAVE YOUR
VIDEO ON. THE AND WE DO SEE TO
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE VIDEO
AND I APOLOGIZE ABOUT
INTERRUPTING THEM DIRECTOR SO
IF WE CAN RESTART THE FIVE
MINUTES WE'RE GONNA START A
NEW- IN MADAME TRACTOR AGAIN WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE. UP ON.
CHAIRS AND YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY.
AND THEN WE CAN HEAR YOU BUT
YOU'RE IS NOW OFTEN. ALL RIGHT
BETTER DIRECTOR OF I'M GONNA
STAGGERING HAVE YOU SAY YOUR
FIRST SENTENCE IN THE TO SEE IF
THAT OKAY. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION. CAN YOU
HEAR ME UP HER MANAGER AFTER WE
SEE YOU WE HEAR YOU YOU ARE
GOOD. AGAIN I TAKE IT AWAY
MA'AM. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AGAIN. THE TENSION I COULD
MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS JIM JOHNSON PART OF
SOCIAL SERVICES. HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS BRANCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES CURRENTLY ADMINISTERS
AND PROVIDES OVERSIGHT FOR SIX
STATEWIDE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS. THESE PROGRAMS OF
THOSE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR HOUSING
INSTABILITY INCLUDING
PARTICIPANTS ACCOUNT WORKS
CHILD WELFARE. COUNTY GENERAL
ASSISTANCE IN GENERAL RELIEF
PROGRAMS DISABILITY BENEFIT
PROGRAMS AND ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES THE NEW CYNOSURE
PROJECT ROOM HE WAS DEVELOPED
AND IMPLEMENTED LAST YEAR THIS
EFFORT WAS DESIGNED TO SAVE
LIVES REDUCE TRANSMISSION OF
CODE NINETEEN RELEASE PRESSURE
ON THE HOSPITAL'S DESPERATE.
THIS HOSPITAL SYSTEM BY
PROVIDING SHELTER FOR THOSE WHO
ARE COPING POSITIVES HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED OR WHO ARE AT HIGH RISK
FOR MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS IF
THEY ARE OUT WERE TO CONTRACT
THE VIRUS. THIS INCLUDES
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS
HAVE BEEN HOUSED IN LARGE
NUMBERS TO THIS EFFORT AND
THAT'S WHERE I WILL FOCUS MY
REMARKS. EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC
THE GOVERNOR ESTABLISHED A
ROADMAP TO RECOVERY THAT NOT
ONLY ADDRESS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACT OF THE VIRUS AND
CALIFORNIANS BUT ALSO THE
HISTORIC DESTRUCTION IN THE
ECONOMY THAT HAS A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON LOW
WAGE WORKERS IN AND THERE'S
EXPERIENCING POVERTY. THE
GOVERNOR DEVELOP A SPECIFIC AN
INDICATOR AIMED AT ENSURING
RESOURCES INTERPRET
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE DEPLOYED
WHAT SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE
POPULATIONS AT GREATEST RISK.
ABOUT A MONTH PRIOR TO THE
OUTBREAK IN A LITTLE OVER A
YEAR AGO TODAY THE GOVERNOR
PRESENTED HIS STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS DEDICATED
EXCLUSIVELY TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE KNEW AT THE TIME. AS YOU
MENTIONED CHAIR OVER ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND AND-
OR EXPERIENCE HOMELESS. THOSE
THE AGE FIFTY WITH A FAT
GROWING POPULATION FIRST TIME
HOMELESS AND WE ALSO KNEW THAT
I JUST. SHARE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE BLACK NATIVE
AMERICAN AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THESE WOULD BE THE SAME
POPULATIONS THAT WOULD BE AT
HIGHEST RISK FOR MEDICAL
COMPLICATIONS IF THEY WERE TO
CONTRACT THE VIRUS. OUT OF
THESE PREVIOUS AND NEW
PRIORITIES PROJECT ROOM HE WAS
BORN. AS THE AGENDA STATES THIS
INITIATIVE WAS ANNOUNCED IN MID
MARCH WITH AN APPROVAL FROM
THIS BODY IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR INITIAL
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT. A HUNDRED
MILLION OF WHICH I WAS DIRECTED
BY B. C. S. H. TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CONTINUUM OF
CARE FOR BOTH PROJECT ROOM HERE
OTHER CODE RELATED EFFORTS. FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES I WAS
ADMINISTERING FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE SPEND SPECIFIC
TO PROJECT ROOM KEY FOR
COUNTIES AND TRIBES. AND TO
PURCHASE TRAILER TRAILERS.
UTILIZING THE EXPIRY THAT I.
RESEARCHERS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM FEDERAL
AGENCIES WHAT AT AGENCIES LIKE
THE HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT AND THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY
FEMA. AND COORDINATION FROM A
NUMBER OF STATE AGENCIES MOST
NOTABLY B. C. S. H. H. C. D.
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AT
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND SOCIAL
SERVICES WE WERE ABLE TO
QUICKLY DEPLOY THESE RESOURCES
INTO COMMUNITIES. AMANDUS
EFFORTS AND PARTNERSHIPS AB
FIFTY FIVE COUNTIES AND THREE
TRIBES. WE SECURED OVER SIXTEEN
THOUSAND ROOMS AT THE HIGHEST
PEAKS ARE PASSING OUR INITIAL
TARGETS AND HAVE SHELTERED AND
SUPPORTED WELL OVER TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS TO
DATE. THE PROGRAM WAS THE FIRST
IN THE NATION APPROVED FOR FEMA
REIMBURSEMENT WHICH MEANT THAT
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COULD FURTHER LEVERAGE SPENDING
AND RECEIVE A 75% COST SHARE
FOR HOTEL AND MOTEL ROOMS.
INCLUDING WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS.
AND THE NEWEST FEDERAL
MINISTRATION HAS RECENTLY
INCREASED ITS REIMBURSEMENT AT
21100% FOR ELIGIBLE ACTIVITIES
THROUGH SEPTEMBER OF THIS YEAR.
PROJECT REACH YOU SITES PROVIDE
BOTH EMERGENCY SHELTERS
CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTIVES WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
WRAP AROUND SERVICES LIKE MEALS
AND CONNECTIONS TO OTHER
SUPPORT SERVICES. THESE SITES
PROVIDE STREAMLINED ACCESS TO
CRITICAL SAFETY NET BENEFITS AS
WELL AS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES MEDICAL SERVICES CASE
MANAGEMENT AND HOUSING. FOR
EXAMPLE KERN COUNTY HAS USED
TRAILER SECURED YOUR PROJECT
ROOM HE AS A DIRECT ACCESS.
FROM HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE A
SAFE SPACE FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO
ISOLATE RECOVER FROM KOBE
NINETEEN CONTRA COSTA HAS
SHARED THEIR SUCCESS PROVIDING
MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
BENEFIT ACCESS SUPPORT TO
CLIENTS WHO WOULD NOT RECEIVE
THE SERVICES. IN A DECADE OR
MORE WITHOUT PROJECT ROOM KEY
THEIR PROVIDERS LAST YEAR BUT
MANY OF THE PARTICIPANTS WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN CONNECTED. TO BE
SERVICES OR BENEFITS. ICAL
ELEMENT OF PRIDE ROOM TO EFFORT
IS THE ARE GOING RE HOW. AND
SHOULD GO X. PRESS ROOM ARE
COULD. TO HOUSE AND SERVICES
NAY. TO MEET THEIR HOUSE GOALS.
TO SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS AND OF
THEM OF LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
APPROVED THE USE OF AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND ONE TIME STATE
GENERAL FUND FROM THE STATE'S
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS COUNT OR GLS. TO
ALLOW CONTINUED PROJECT FRANKIE
OPERATIONS BUT ALSO SUPPORTING
RE HOUSING FOR CLIENTS. CDSS
ALLOCATED THESE FUNDS TO FIFTY
COUNTIES IN TWO TRIBES ON
NOVEMBER EIGHTEENTH THE SUPPORT
THIS WE HOUSING EFFORTS ONE
MINUTE IN IN ADDITION TO THIS
WE HOUSING EFFORT YOU WILL HEAR
MORE FROM MY COLLEAGUE HOUSING.
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR OF THE
SOUTH OF THE LAST GUESS ABOUT
WHO HE WHICH BUILT ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE PROJECT ROOM KEY
TO CREATE PERMANENT HOUSING
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN CLOSING
TODAY THERE ARE OVER NINE
THOUSAND HOTEL AND MOTEL ROOMS
THAT ARE CONTINUING TO PROVIDE
SAFE SHELTER TO ROUGHLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS MOST OF WHOM ARE
SENIORS OR ELDERS AND PEOPLE
WITH UNDERLYING HEALTH
CONDITIONS. DUE TO THE ELECTED
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC THE NEED FOR HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES. WE WILL CONTINUE
THESE EFFORTS AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THE
GROUND WE ALSO HAVE THE
DEFINITION JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH IS INCLUDING ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN INVESTING IN THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO ACQUIRING
IN REHAB REHABBING HOUSING FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WITHIN THAT
PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND OVER THREE YEARS
THIS PROPOSED FOR THIS
DEPARTMENT TO ADMINISTER THE
COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION.
PROGRAM WHICH WILL PROVIDE FOR
THE ACQUISITION OR
REHABILITATION EVAN JONES
SENIOR CARE PROGRAMS WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE PARTNERSHIP OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO OUR STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERS THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS ON THE GROUND IN
THOSE THAT HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
PROJECT RICKY WHO CONTINUE TO
SHAKE THESE EFFORTS. AND HELP
REACH OUR GOALS THANK YOU.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH NOT
AT ALL TRYING TO BE PUSHY BUT
KNOW THAT EVERYONE IS BUSY AND
THANK YOU FOR STICKING WITH US-
AFTER AT THE START WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL. NICE JOB. ALL RIGHT
WE HER ABOUT PRIME ROOM KEY. AT
THAT PROVIDED THOSE TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND- FOR THOSE FOR
HOMELESS OR CLOSE TO HOMELESS
NOW WE'VE GOT TO DO DO DIVE
PRIME. HOME KEEP WHICH IS AT
PERMANENT THE OF HOW. FOR THAT
WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM GOOSE
VELASQUEZ HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT MISTER
DIRECTOR IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE SIR THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES WE'LL GIVE
YOU A ONE MINUTE AND THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT AS YOU GET CLOSE
TO THOSE FIVE. IT'S A DIRECTOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. BUT
MORNING- GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU- CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES. FOR INVITING ME
TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT THE-
STATE'S INCREASE EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT.
ORDINATED SOLUTIONS TO PREVENT.
AND END HOMELESSNESS. MY NAME
IS GUSTAVO VELASQUEZ AND I
SERVED AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING. AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. I ALSO
SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE
HOMELESS. COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL. AS WE ALL
KNOW THE PANDEMIC EXACERBATED
WHAT ALREADY WAS AN URGENT
CRISIS FOR STATE AND
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. ON HOUSE PEOPLE
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
BY HEALTH CONDITIONS CAUSED BY
LACK OF SHELTER RESULTING IN
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON MATH UNTIL
IN PHYSICAL WELL BEING. LAKE
CITY HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
AMELIORATE THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS WORKING IN TANDEM WITH
OTHER PARTNERS IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. INCLUDING THE
ENTITIES I SURE THIS PANEL WITH
AND OF COURSE ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THE WORK THREE CD IS
INEXTRICABLY LINKED TO THE WORK
OF THE COUNCIL. THAT GUIDES THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM THAT SETS
PRIORITIES FOR HOW THE STATE
ADDRESSES HOMELESSNESS. HC NEED
THEM AT MANY STORES ARE BROAD
CONTINUUM OF PROGRAMMING. FOR
EXAMPLE THE EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
GRANT AND THE PERMANENT LOCAL
HOUSING ALLOCATION ISSUE
PROGRAM CAN HELP COMMUNITIES
MITIGATE HOMELESSNESS BY
FUNDING ACTIVITIES LIKE INTERN
SHELTER RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
SERVICES. OTHER PROGRAMS ALSO
ADMINISTERED BY EIGHT CITIES
SUCH AS NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
HOUSING FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA THE VETERANS HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION PROGRAM
AND OF COURSE HOME KEY
INCREASES THE SUPPLY OF
PERMANENT SOLUTIONS BY FUNDING
THE ACQUISITION OR CONSTRUCTION
OF PERMANENT HOUSING FOR THOSE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
DAHLE THIS PROGRAM SUPPORT
EFFORTS ACROSS THE CONTINUUM
THEY OFTEN WORK IN A
COMPLIMENTARY FASHION WITHIN
HCV AND WITH THE REST OF. THE
STATE HOMELESSNESS PROGRAM. LET
ME NOW BRIEFLY AND SPECIFIC. HI
LARRY. WHICH I. EGGS THE GUNS
AT RISK. OF STATE AND THEN. IN
JULY GOVERNOR NEW I'M NOT WAS
ABLE OF SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR HONKING
WITH ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS I LOCATED IN
OCTOBER. ALONG WITH FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN
PHILANTHROPIC FUNDING SUPPORT
FOR A TOTAL OF EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
IN A MATTER OF MONTHS. DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE DID WHAT MANY
SAID WAS IMPOSSIBLE WE CREATED
OVER SIX THOUSAND NEW UNITS ON
TIME AND UNDER BUDGET HELPING
THOUSANDS OF HOMELESS
CALIFORNIA'S BOTTLE CARSON TENS
AND DEPARTMENT HOUSE. HOME ON
CUE WILL BE CALM WHEN ALL OF
THIS PROCESS IS GONE CLOSE TO
WILL WELCOME CLOSE TO TEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
EXPERIENCED OR WHERE OTHER RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS. AND LOCAL
INTEREST HAS BEEN STRONG FROM
THE DAY THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED
HUNKY AC THE RECEIVER STATEWIDE
APPLICATIONS FROM SIXTY SEVEN
JURISDICTIONS BY THE PRIORITY
APPLICATION DEADLINE WHICH WAS
ONLY A MONTH AFTER. THE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED ON KEEP IN A
TOTAL OF MORE THAN A BILLION.
DOLLARS IN FUNDING WAS REQUEST.
I OF THE LAST DAY OR THE YEAR
GOOD WE NEED TO SPEND. THIS
MONEY OPPER FEDERAL GUIDELINES
ALL FIFTY ONE LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT RECEIVED AWARDS HOW TO
OBTAIN THE FUNDING AND
PURCHASED AND CLOSED ESCROW ON
ALL NINETY FOUR PROJECTS. IN
ADDITION TO FUNDING TO ACQUIRE
UNITS EVERY JURISDICTION IN
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
RECEIVED OPERATING SUPPORT
GRANT FROM PHILANTHROPIC
SOURCES INDUSTRY GENERAL FUND
TO HELP GUARANTEED THE LONG
TERM BUT ABILITY OF EACH
APPLICANT TWENTY PORT FOR. HOME
GAMES PROVIDING PERMANENT
HOUSING IN EVERY SINGLE REGION
OF THE STATE. EMPOWER WITH
SUCCESS HAS BEEN ITS FOCUS ON
EQUITY WITH AN INTENTION TO
GIVE LOCAL JURISDICTION HAS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO TAILOR THIS
PROGRAM IS DIRECTLY TO THE
NEEDS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES ONE
MINUTES HAS RESULTED IN HONKY
HAVING DIRECT TOUCH POINTS WITH
MANY COMMUNITIES DIRECTLY
AFFECTED. BY RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES IT HAS MEN
WERE SERVING CURRENTAND FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH RESIDENTS IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES LGBTQ PLUS
INDIVIDUALS PEOPLE LIVING WITH
HIV FARMWORKERS SENIORS
VETERANS EVEN FAMILIES AND
WOMEN. ESCAPING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THIS PROBLEM WAS ONLY
A TO SUCCEED THE SUPPORT. FROM
ALL YOU MEMBERS OF THE LATE IN
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS WORK IN
TANDEM TO DELIVER THIS CRITICAL
PROJECTS. WE KNOW OUR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF THE BOLD
INNOVATIVE IDEAS INFUSED WITH
ACTION AND FUNDING CAN LEAD TO
SUCCESS I'VE SEEN WITH CLUNKY
AND WE'RE EAGER. TO CONTINUE
THE WAR WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUE THEIR WORK
THE EASIER BUILDING WITH YOUR
SUPPORT ALL SUCCESSES AND
LESSONS LEARNT THIRTY SIX. MUCH
MORE THAN NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
DEVELOP A STRONG HOMELESSNESS
FIFTEEN BUT I DO BELIEVE
SINCERELY BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
MAKING. MEANINGFUL PROGRESS IN
THIS CASE AND I LOOK FORWARD.
TO THE CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
WITH ALL OF YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
ATTENTION. MISTER DIRECTOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WORDS TO ADD TO YOUR ENTIRE
TEAM'S WORK AS THEY HAVE BEEN
MAKING THEMSELVES AVAILABLE
OVER THESE PAST MANY MANY
MONTHS WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM. EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
RESPECTIVE SENATORS WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THAT EACH OF OUR
PANELISTS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
CERTAIN DIRECTOR JOHNSON
DIRECTOR VELASQUEZ IF YOU COULD
PLEASE KEEP YOUR CAMERAS ON AT
THIS POINT. AS WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING TO QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE
GONNA START OUT WITH A MYSTERY
CASSIE IN BERGEN GOING TO CHEER
CABALLERO THAT'S RIGHT CASTING
THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M DELIGHTED TO
SEE HERE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THAT THE FEMA
PROGRAM IS GOING TO PAY A 100%
REIMBURSEMENT. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S RETROACTIVE TO HAVE
SOME IDEA OF WHAT THAT NUMBER
IS RETROACTIVELY AND WHAT'S THE
GAME PLAN WITH THIS. AS SOME
HAS DETERMINED. UNCLEAR
FRAGMENTED HOMELESS RESPONSE
WILL HAVE HAPPENED THEN AND
THEN THE OTHER SECOND QUESTION
THE ANSWER BOTH OF THEM IS OF
THE ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION- I DIDN'T SEE. A ARE AN
ELEMENT IN THERE FOR A
CONSTRUCTION OF EIGHTY USE I
KNOW THAT WE TALK ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIVERSALITY
BUT HE WANTS TO BUILD IT FOR
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS AND WE
KNOW THAT. ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS A GARAGE CONVERSION CAN
BE AS LOW AS EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A REGULAR STANDALONE
HUNDRED SIXTY SO. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE GAME PLAN IS
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE'RE GOING
TO BUY PROPERTIES IN REHAB THEM
IF THAT'S IF TO ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY USES. INCLUDED THAT MR
CARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH BY
CASKEY AT LET'S HERE WHY DON'T
WE TO. A DEPUTIES. AT TO BE
ABLE TO START OUT IN IN MADAM
DEPUTY SECRETARY IF YOU WANT TO
PASS ON THAT ANY SPECIFICS TO
EITHER DIRECTORS DEPUTY
SECRETARY ON CENTER BY CATHY'S
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY I ADD WILL SORT OF
THE INTERNET QUESTION I THINK
YOU WERE ASKING AROUND. AND
SOME OF THAT DESTROYED SYSTEM
BEING IT BEING DISCUSSED IN THE
AUDIT- WE DEFINITELY BELIEVE WE
HAVE MORE WORK TO BE. DOING IN
THIS AREA- BUT WE DO FEEL LIKE
SOME OF THE GUYS WE PUT OUT
THIS YEAR PARTICULARLY THAT.
THE STATEWIDE- STRATEGIC
SPENDING GUIDE FOR STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING WAS INTENDED TO
HELP LOCAL COMMUNITIES THINK
ABOUT HOW TO BREAK THOSE
RESOURCES TOGETHER AT THE
GROUND LEVEL. I THINK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT WAYS TO USE THAT
FUNDING SO WE'VE BEEN DOING
SOME WORK LIKE THAT. ON THE
ACTUAL PLAN I MENTIONED ALSO
HAS A EXPLICIT WORKING GROUP
THAT WILL BE WORKING ON HOW TO
MAXIMIZE AND COURTNEY STATE
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE GETTING
OUT. AS SOON AS THAT THAT
ACTUALLY MANAGED APPROVED
IDEALLY NEXT MONTH- SO WE DON'T
KNOW THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE THERE BUT WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT WERE REMOVING AS
AS- DIRECTOR DIES BECAUSE THAT
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION- IN
REGARDS TO THE FEMALE QUESTION
PARTICULAR. I WILL- SAY THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING A LOT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN THAT
AREA BUT I THINK IT MIGHT BE
BEST FOR DIRECTOR JOHNSON TO
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ON THAT- IN
SOME OF THE WORK THEY'VE BEEN
DOING IN THAT SPACE AND THEN-
IF IT'S OKAY FOR EIGHTY A
QUESTION RIGHT. HAND THAT OVER
TO JOHN DIRECTOR OF. AFTER.
SURE RELATED TO THIS. A
QUESTION AG JUST. THE LADY AT
THIS INCREASE IN THE HUNDRED.
BECAUSE SHARE OP. WOULD AGAIN
WILL LEVERAGE. A NUMBER OF
RESEARCH. TO SECURE. IN A- IS
NECESSARILY A NUMBER. AT THAT
WE CAN GET YOU INTO. ABS OF
WHAT WILL BE DRAWN DE. AS THAT
SO. BUT A CERTAIN X. AND HE-
OUR- TO FOR. AT THE SERVICE FOR
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME GOING TO
BE EACH BASED ON L. COSTS- IN
AND HOW THAT WORKS WHOSE
FORWARD. I WE ARE. US IN.
AMOUNT OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THIS FRONT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
IN IN ALSO JUST REALLY WONDER
PRE SHAPE THE PARTNERS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS TO HAVE ALSO
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE IN
HELPING. LOCAL COMMUNITIES
NAVIGATE AT THEIR ABILITY TO.
COMPLETE THE PROJECT WORKSHEETS
AND DO THE ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPONENTS TO ALLOW FOR THAT AT
RESOURCE. TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
THEM. THANK YOU SO MUCH LIKE TO
GO BACK TO CENTER MY CAST
CINEMA CASKEY- QUESTIONS- OR
ANY FOLLOW UP ON- THE DIRECTOR
OR THE DEPUTY SECRETARY. HI I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE TWO CHAIRS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE CENTER HERE
IN THIS AREA BUT I'M SURE THEY
WILL BE. EAGER TO KNOW WHAT
THAT EXPECTATION OF THE NUMBER
IS AND HOW THE WORK PLAN IS IF
IT IS. IF IT'S GOING TO BE
DIRECTED AT. CORRECTIONS THAT
WE KNOW OR- IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES WHETHER
IT'S HOME KEY ROOM KEY SOCIAL
SERVICES. EIGHTY USE WHATEVER
WHATEVER THAT THERE THERE IS A
NUMBER OUT THERE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS SENATOR WE'LL DO IS
WE'LL ASK FOR THE DIRECTOR TO
BE TO RESPOND TO THAT- AFTER I
CHAIRWOMAN CABALLERO SPEAKS-
CHAIRWOMAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- LET ME SEE IF I CAN DO
IT MY GOOD COLLEAGUE- FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY DID. IT WHICH IS
TO KIND OF GET IT ALL OUT AND
SEE WHO IT IS THAT CAN ANSWER
THE QUESTION- YEAH. THAT
WOULDN'T THE FIRST QUESTION I
HAVE IS WHAT WHAT EFFORTS HAVE
BEEN MADE- THROUGH THE- EITHER
THE- PROJECT ROOM CARE HOME
KEY. TO MAKE SURE THAT SMALL
RURAL COMMUNITIES CAN ACCESS
THE RESOURCES. ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES GENERALLY SPEAKING
ARE LESS NIMBLE. AND HAVE LESS
STAFF. THAT DEALS SPECIFICALLY
WITH- THE HOMELESS ISSUES. AND
SO AND I'M CONCERNED BECAUSE I
TOOK A LOOK AT THE LIST OF. OF
THE GRANT AND- A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THE GRANTS WENT
TO THE BIG WELL ACTUALLY. AT
LARGE A LARGE PERCENT.
PERCENTAGE WENT TO THE BIG
CITIES. AND A HUGE PERCENTAGE-
I HAD A NUMBER BUT CAN'T FIND
IT WENT TO LOS ANGELES WE KNOW
THAT ALI HAD. A TERRIBLE. ISSUE
BUT WE ALL DO AND SO THE
QUESTION BECOMES. HOW CAN WE
MAKE SURE THAT RURAL CALIFORNIA
KING CAN ACCESS THESE FUNDS AS
WELL- WHY THE HIGH VCANCY
RATE- I IT SOMEWHERE I READ
THAT 65% OF THE UNITS ARE
OCCUPIED SEEMS TO ME. THAT
MOTEL ROOMS ARE MOVABLE HE CAN
MOVE IN AND YES YOU'D PROBABLY
WANT TO. READ TO THEM A LITTLE
BIT- BUT BUT WHY DO IT NOW IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC WHY
NOT. GET JUST GET PEOPLE IN A
BAD. IN THEN I WANT THIS IS NOT
THE SUBJECT OF A OF. THE
HEARING TODAY BUT IT IS
PROBABLY JUST AS IMPORTANT
WHICH IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
FUNNELING A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
THE RESOURCES THAT THE STATE
GRANTS THROUGH OUR BUDGET. TO
THE COMMUNITIES OF CARE CECILIA
SIS AND ON AND- THERE THERE ARE
THIS YEAR SHE WAS SET UP. BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND IN
MY MIND LEAVE SOME REAL ISSUES.
UNRESOLVED BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
PUBLIC BODY NECESSARILY THEY
DON'T HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
BROWN ACT OR ANY OF THOSE KINDS
OF REQUIREMENTS. AND THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRED THAT IF
YOU WANT TO GET A GRANT YOU
CAN'T SERVE ON THE BOARD TO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU CAN SERVE ON THE
BOARD AND SAY HEY WE ARE AGENCY
NEEDS MONEY AND- IT CAN BE
GRANTED AND THAT. OBVIOUSLY IS
A SITUATION THAT CREATES.
CHALLENGES AND THEN WE DON'T
REQUIRE THEM TO REPORT
INFORMATION TO US IN A WAY THAT
GIVES THE SENATE THE ABILITY TO
SEE WHETHER THEY'RE- ACTUALLY
TAKING PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
WHETHER THEY'RE SATISFYING- AND
WITH THAT REQUIREMENTS SAID
THAT OF THE GRANT IS AND IT SO
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE'S A WHOLE LOT OF. OF
INFORMATION THAT WE SHOULD
REQUIRE AS PART OF THIS GRANT
SO THAT WE CAN LOOK AND
DETERMINE WHETHER SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE DOING A BETER
JOB IN THE COMMUNITY SO. THAT
THAT- I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT WE
AS WE DEVELOP OUR PACKAGE THAT
IT MAKES SENSE THAT WERE USING
OUR MONEY WISELY AND THAT WERE
ACTUALLY GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET. MORE IMPORTANTLY
GETTING THEM OFF THE STREET
PERMANENTLYTHANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR THANK YOU SO MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR THERE ARE THREE ISSUES IF
WE COULD ADDRESS THAT- SMALL
RURAL COMMUNITIES ACCESS TO
FUNDS. TO ON THAT VACANCY RATES
THREE ON TRACKING METRICS IN
REGARDS TO THE. CONTINUED CARE
SCRIPTED MANAGER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH IF WE CAN START WITH
ACCESS FOR SMALL RURAL
COMMUNITIES- WHO WOULD LIKE TO
BE BECAUSE AFTER. POLICE MISTER
I CAN I CAN. I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION SO LET ME JUST-
SENATE HOW GYRO I THINK- PLEASE
KNOW THAT AB EIGHT AT REGIONAL
IN A IN IN MANY OTHER- FORMS
LIST WAS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AS WE WERE DESIGNING AND
IMPLEMENTING PUMPKIN I'M I'M
BUT- NOT TOUCH. KEY BECAUSE- WE
DESIGNED A PRIORITY UPTICK. TO
CREATE A I CAN GEOGRAPHIC
EQUITY THROUGHOUT STICK
CREATING EIGHT GEOGRAPHIC
REGIONS AND SETTING ASIDE A
PROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF FUNDS
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. AND THOSE AT RISK
OF HOMELESSNESS BASED ON
AFFORDABILITY FACTORS AND RATES
AT THAT TIME OF COMING IN A
COMMON INFECTION AND ALL EIGHT
REGIONS WERE. FULLY SUBSCRIBED
I MEAN WE RECEIVED A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF INTEREST FROM ALL THE
REASONS BUT JUST TO PUT IN
CONTEXT- D. MENTIONED YOU KNOW
IT. AS A WHEN YOU AT THE KEY A.
B. BALA ALL IT'S GOING TO
HOMELESS BASED ON THE TWENTY
TIME COUNT IS THE I. THE WAY
THEY GENERALLY- THE COUNTRY IN
THE STATE MAY. AT HOME IS IN
THE- YOU KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT
A WITH CLOSED PER OF THE-
POPULATION OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN THE STATE- HONKY.
THE NEW ON THE FOR THAT WAS
ROUGHLY 2% WHEN YOU LOOK AT SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY WHICH- ROUGHLY A
POPULATION OF THESE AT. THE END
IN THESE POPULATION HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS ROUGHLY SIX
PERCENT. 80% D. THE AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS AND SUPPORT AT HOME
KEY- I GAVE TO THE TO THE
BALLOT SO IT CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE- NOTHING IS
PERFECT IN THE DISTRIBUTION BUT
WE INTENTIONALLY. WE REALLY
INTENTIONALLY ENSURE THAT
REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION EQUITY IN
THAT REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION WAS-
WAS TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
AND WE WORK WITH WITH EVERY
COMMUNITY WE UNDERSTAND THE
SMALLER COMMUNITIES HAD LESS
CAPACITY. IT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED EVEN
THOUGH. WE WERE DEALING WITH
SUCH A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WAS
TREMENDOUS WITH EACH
JURISDICTION. EACH AND EVERYONE
OF THE NINETY FOUR PROJECTS
THAT RECEIVED AWARDS ACT END
OBVIOUSLY LOOK FORWARD AS AS
POTENTIALLY THIS PROJECT CAN
CONTINUE THIS YEAR. WITH MORE
TIME NOW THAT WE WILL AT
POTENTIALLY HAVING. OUR HANDS
NOT JUST FIVE MONTHS. TO DO. AT
AT STAKE IS FOCUSED ON THE EAST
OF REGIONAL DISTRIBUTION AND A
IN GENERAL THE THAT'S WHERE
IMPORTANT. FOR US AND I THE
VACANCY RATE IS SOMETHING WITH
ROOM TO- WILL HAVE- DIRECTOR
JOHNSON. THANK YOU. GLAD TO SO
A COUPLE THINGS TO THAT ARE
RATE AT THE HOTEL SO THAT HOTEL
AND MOTEL COUNT YOUR EVERY SIX
THIS NOT NEXT. MEAN THAT WERE
FOR EACH OF ROOM RIGHT SOME OF
THE AGREE FROM INTENTIONAL
SAYING WE LIKE EIGHT OF COURSE
I ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
REALLY HELP FACILITATE THE
IDENTIFICATION OF WILLING HOTEL
AND MOTEL OWNERS TO SUPPORT
THIS EFFORT- IN IDENTIFYING IN
EACH SCREEN THAT WE COULD THEN
SHARED WITH THE- LOCAL COUNTY
ADMINISTRATORS AND IN TERMS OF
WHO. THAT WAS RUNNING THE
PROGRAMS BACK AGAIN SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE MAXIMUM CAPACITY OF
ROOM SECURED AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS AND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING- AND THEN-
OCCUPANCY- IS WHAT ARE BEING
UTILIZED SO OF COURSE AS THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS- OVER
THE COURSE OF THESE LAST AT AT
YEAR. TWELVE MONTHS YEAR I'M
HAS CHANGED CERTAINLY THAT'S
BEEN DIFFERENT ACROSS
COMMUNITIES IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY ARE ACCESSING BUT I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THAT DIRECT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE THAT THIS
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY. TO
SUPPORT ME AGAIN AS AS WE HAVE
SAID THIS REALLY GOOD IS IT
REALLY IS A BY STATING THAT
MEASURE WAS ABLE THAT.
PARTICIPATE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AT TASK FORCE THAT WAS DEPLOYED
BY THE GOVERNOR A LAST YEAR'S
WELL AND WE'RE HEARING DIRECTLY
FROM THE HOSPITAL DIRECTORS AND
OTHERS ABOUT JESS- THAT THAT
THE DIFFERENCES MADE IN TERMS
OF I INDIVIDUALS THEY KNOW
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE SHOWN UP I
IN THE E. ARE. AND HAVE THIS
AFTER HAS SUPPORTED THEM SO
AGAIN WE REALLY ENCOURAGE
ASKING THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EFFORTS TO HAVE THESE AT ROOMS
UTILIZED ATWITHIN THE EXISTING
PARAMETERS TO SUPPORT I
INDIVIDUALS I ALSO JUST A LAST-
FOR IN TERMS OF RURAL
COMMUNITIES FOR PROJECT ROOM HE
AGAIN IT WAS THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN SUPPORT BUT ALSO
THAT. DEPLOYMENT OF TREATMENTS
THAT WAS. OUT TIONS FOR I CAN.
THAT WAS MORE SO. IN SOME CAN.
AS SOME OF THE COMMUNITY SO. I
AND THEN FINALLY JUST WANT TO.
AS CENTER BY POUNCEY IN THE
AGAIN IT IS THE- SO WILL BE-
APPLYING FOR IT JUST. THE SB
MARIA. SO IT'S THE IT'S THE
LOCALS BE DRYING DOWN THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAME DIRECT OF WHAT WE'D LIKE
TO BE DO TO GET THE FINAL WORD
TO. COPY CENTER I KNOW YOU WANT
TO HAVE A FOLLOW UP. I THINK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I GUESS THAT. WERE WHAT'S
BECOME. TO ME. THROUGH THE
ANSWER IS THAT THESE. ARE YOU
KNOW IT WAS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT WE WERE PURCHASING THROUGH
ONE OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE
PURCHASING HOTELS. AND USING
THEM AS- A CONVERSION TO
PERMANENT HOUSING. OR OR USING
THEM AS AT. AN INTERIM HOUSING
AND TELL. INDIVIDUALS COULD BE
PLACED IN PERMANENT HOUSING.
NOW IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS RUNNING ROOMS.
AND AND SO IT'S NOT A PERMANENT
SOLUTION OR IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT GIVES US NEW. HOUSING
UNITS. AND THAT'S- THAT'S
REALLY CRITICAL TO UNDERSTAND.
SO IF I AM RIGHT MY CONCERN IS
THAT WE REALLY. WE'VE WE'VE
SOLVED THE TEMPORARY PROBLEM.
WHICH IS A HEALTH CARE ISSUE.
RELATED TO KOBE BUT WE HAVEN'T
PERMANENTLY. SET UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO USE THOSE. HOUSING
UNITS AS PEOPLE MOVE INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND THAT HAS
ME GREATLY CONCERNED. BECAUSE
ESSENTIALLY WE'RE RENTING ROOMS
AND THAT'S EXPENSIVE- IT IS THE
HUMANE AND JUSTTHING TO DO AT
THIS PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME
BUT- BUT THAT MEANS WEEK WE'VE
REALLY GOT TO. UP OUR GAME AND
IT REALLY GETS BACK TO THE
ISSUES THAT MY- MY GOOD FRIEND
CENTER RIGHT BECAUSE HE BROUGHT
UP WHICH IS THAT. YOU KNOW WE
OUGHT TO BE LOOKING FOR THAT
THE CHEAPEST ALTERNATIVE. TO
GET US HOUSING UNITS
IMMEDIATELY. AND WE OUGHT TO BE
LOOKING AT THE BUDGET AND THAT
WAY AS WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS CENTER COVER ON AND TURN IT
BACK OVER TO DIRECTOR VELASQUEZ
BECAUSE I THINK THAT. IT
DEPENDING ON THE JURISDICTION
WHAT WE'VE BEEN SEEN FROM A LOT
OF JURISDICTIONS AND PLEASE
PUSH BACK ON THE MISTER
DIRECTOR. IS THAT THERE'S A TWO
STEP PROCESS NUMBER ONE- IT'LL
GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE THAT WE SEEN
IN CINEMA COUNTY OR MENDOCINO
COUNTY. COUNTIES WILL AT PLACE
INDIVIDUALS. OFF THE STREETS.
INTO THE ROOMS. AT THEN
THERE'LL BE A REFURBISHMENT
ADVANCED. I TO BE ABLE TO PUT
IN FOR EXAMPLE KITCHENETTES SO
THAT THEY CAN BECOME. MORE
PERMANENT PLACE. TO LIVE BUT
THERE'S REALLY A TWO STEP
PROCESS OF GETTING FOLKS OFF
THE STREETS. IN IN GETTING THEM
PERMANENTLY HOW'S THE MISTER
DIRECTOR I DON'T WANNA. PUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH AND CENTER
CABALLERO AYE BRINGS UP SOME
VALID CONCERNS SO MISTER
CHARACTER IF YOU COULD PLEASE
COMMENT ON THAT. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLARIFY- THIS. OP I'M GONNA
USE- NUMBERS A LITTLE BIT JUST
TO- REALLY PUT A FINE POINT ON
THIS ISSUE ALL OF. ASSIST
BERMAN AND HOUSING- HONKY WAS
MAN- I DO I CHOIR THESE. AND
HAVE THEM FOR OCCUPANCY WITHIN
NINETY DAYS AFTER THE
ACQUISITION IN FACT AS OF NOW
SOME OF THE PROJECTS THAT
CLOSED- AT THE VERY LAST AT
POINT OF THE MONTH OF DECEMBER
THAT THERE IS STILL YOU KNOW
BECOME WE ARE STILL HAS NOT AT
THE NINETY DAY. AB PLAN HAS NOT
EXPIRED YET NOW I'M WITH THE
AFTER THISOCCUPANCY IT HAPPENS
THEY ARE THERE'S A SMALL
PORTION OF THE. SIX THOUSAND
AGAIN THIS IS SIX THOUSAND. THE
NEW DOORS HOUSING THAT WILL BE
AVE- IT ONLY A SMALL PORTION
DOES A THOUSAND OF THEM. WILL
BE FOR INJURING HOUSING
PURPOSES AND THE VAST MAJORITY
WILL BE- THURMAN IN HOUSING SO
THESE UNITS WILL BE PERMANENTLY
FOR THESE POPULATION FOR UP TO
FIFTY FIVE YEARS IN THE IN THE
IN THE FUTURE HORIZON SO. WE
ARE AT CENTER TOMA EUROPE
CREATING VAST MAJORITY OF THESE
FOR PERMANENT HOUSING IN THESE
UNDER THE MODEL PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WE HAVE AN
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT THERE
ARE GOING TO BE SERVICES ON
SITE THAT WILL THESE PROPERTIES
HI EIGHT A WAY TO- ASSISTING
ABILITY IN THE LONG TERM-
THROUGH ALL OPERATING- A
CAPITOL IN CONCERT WE- IT IS IT
IS IMPORTANT TO. CLARIFY THAT
DOES THIS IS A PROJECT AIMED AT
PERMANENT HOUSING PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR THE
FUTURE A THERE WILL BE SOME
ENGINE HOUSING AT THE BEGINNING
THERE WILL BE SOME ENGINE
HOUSING FOR ACTS MORE MAJORITY
OF THESE SIX THOUSAND WAS UNITS
BUT THE MAJORITY IS PERMITTED
WILL BE PERMANENT UNITS FOR THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION OF
PEOPLE A RISK. AT RISK OF HOMES
THANK YOU AND AT THIRTY SECONDS
MISTER DIRECTOR THEN I'M GONNA
GO TO ENSURE EGGMAN THE OTHER
COMPONENT THIS IS AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PASTOR THOSE UNITS.
FOR SERVICES AS WELL. YOU WANT
TO COME ON THAT THIRTY SECONDS
PLEASE SIR. YES SHORT ANSWER
YES HI DAN ALL RIGHT THAT SAID
LET'S THAN FIVE. YOU MISTER AT
LET'S GO TO ENSURE WE EGGMAN
MADAM THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THEN GOING
FROM- THE VERY FINE BUT MIKE
POLICY QUESTIONS BACK. BACK TO
A MACRO VIEW FOR A MOMENT-
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE ALL
STRUCK AS I AS I LOOK AROUND
THIS ROOM AND I AND I LOOK AT
EVERYBODY. WE ALL. WE ALL GOT
DRESSED THIS MORNING WELL LOOK
IN THE MIRROR WE ALL THOUGHT
YEAH I THINK I'M YOU KNOW. I
THINK I'M READY TO. TO GO OUT
INTO THE WORLD. AND AS I DROVE
FROM MY HOUSE AND STOCK AND I
PASSED AND AT LEAST ONE MAN I
HAD THIS I HAD TO SLOW DOWN HE
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ROAD.
CLEARLY HOMELESS CLEARLY.
HAVING SOME. MAJOR ISSUES GOING
ON I HAD TO WAIT FOR. FOR HIM
TO MOVE. IN ALL. FORTY YEARS
AGO I WOULD'VE STOPPED AND
HELPED. BUT NOW BUT NOW YOU
UNDERSTAND. IT YOU KNOW. IF I.
IF I STOP THERE'S NOT. REALLY
PRACTICAL HELP I CAN DELIVER
RIGHT NOW. AS I DROVE UP I FIVE
I SAW. AT LEAST. AT LEAST THREE.
I CAN'T MEANT SEVEN CAMINO FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN CARS AND A
COUPLE MOTOR HOMES. ON THE SIDE
I FIVE. AND THEN AS I DROVE IN
SACRAMENTO I. YOU KNOW I LOOK
TO STOP AT A STOP LIGHT AND
THERE'S A MAN LYING ON THE
STREET. WITHIN TOUCHING
DIFFERENT DISTANCE OF ME WHO
DIDN'T HAVE A SHIRT ON. THIS
HAND DOWN HIS PANTS. ANOTHER
MAN SITTING NEXT TO HIM.
CLEARLY THAT'S WHERE THEY LIVE
RIGHT THERE ON THE SIDE OF THE
STREET IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO.
IN I SIDE OF THE CAPITOL. AND I
THINK THEY WOULD HAVE LIKE TO
GOT UP IN THIS MORNING TO AND
LOOKED IN THE MIRROR AND-
THOUGHT IF THEY LOOKED OKAY TO
GO OUT IN THE WORLD BUT- THAT
WAS THAT'S NOT THE REALITY.
THEY AND WHEN I SEE THEM I SEE
CALIFORNIANS. WHEN I SEE YES I
SEE CALIFORNIANS. RIGHT WE ARE
ALL DESERVING OF THEIR THE
RICHES OF THIS OF THIS GOLDEN
STATE OR AT LEAST A PLACE TO
LAY YOUR HEAD THAT IS NOT. ON
THE STREET OR ON THE SIDE OF
THE ROAD. SO MY QUESTION GOING
BACK TO THAT KIND OF MACRO
ISSUE. SO LET'S SAY. WE ALL
WOKE UP TOMORROW AND WE WENT
OUTSIDE. AND THERE WERE PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE STREET. THERE
WERE PEOPLE CAMPING ALONG THE
WAYS THERE WEREN'T. PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISES GOING ON. IN
PLAIN SIGHT. MY QUESTION TO ALL
OF YOU BECAUSE WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT MILLIONS AND BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE USED TO ADDRESS
THIS. I GUESS FOR INTERVIEW
WHAT THING IF WE WOKE UP TO
THAT WORLD WHERE THERE WAS
NOBODY LIVING ON THE STREETS IN
CALIFORNIA ANYMORE WHAT WOULD
HAVE CHANGED WHAT POLICY WHAT
WOULD HAVE CHANGED IN ORDER FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN. THREE THINGS
WHAT THREE THINGS WOULD HAVE
CHANGED IN ORDER FOR THAT TO
OCCUR SO MANY GUESS I'M ASK
EACH OF YOU FROM WORK YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE GOOD FOR MULTI
PEOPLE HERE TODAY. I'M ASK EACH
OF YOU TO WHAT ONE THING FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE WOULD HAVE
CHANGED IN ORDER FOR US TO WAKE
UP. TOMORROW MORNING WITHOUT
ALL THE PEOPLE ON THE STREET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER GREAT
QUESTION- WHY DON'T WE START
WITH DIRECTOR JOHNSON. DIRECTOR
JOHNSON- WHAT. ONE POLICY I
DON'T BUDGET ON YOU NAME IT
WHATEVER IT NEEDS TO BE I'M
SORRY THREE OR ONE MANAGER ONE
THANK YOU. TO WHAT ONE ITEM.
WOULD YOU. NEED TO CHANGE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SOLVE THAT
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS- MAN
DIRECTOR. YEAH VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND
THEY HAD THAT EXPERIENCE AND
REALLY RECOGNIZING ARE INSULTED
NEIGHBORS IN CALIFORNIA AND ITS
HISTORY THIS PANDEMIC HAS NOT.
ESTABLISHED THAT RIGHT HOW WE
ARE ALL CONNECTED TOGETHER I'M
SO YOU KNOW WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
THAT IT IS IT IS A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH IS EVERYTHING
THAT YOU ALL AS OUTLINED IN IN
THIS CONVERSATION. BOTH THE
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING BUT
ALSO THEN HOW WE ARE CONNECTING
INTENTIONALLY- INDIVIDUALS TO
THE COMPREHENSIVE ARRAY THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BUILT OVER TIME
SO IT'S MAKING SURE THAT EACH
INDIVIDUAL. AND THOSE IN THE
NEEDS OF THAT INDIVIDUAL ARE
MET IN SUPPORTING THE CONCEPTS
THAT WE ALL TOGETHER HAVE BEEN
FORWARDED IN THE HOUSE AND
FORCE FIRST CONCEPTS SO I WILL.
I WILL BECAUSE THEY ARE IN IN
IN DEFERRED MY COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU SO MUCH LET'S GO TO- MISTER
DIRECTOR AND WILL GO TO MADAME
DEBBIE. CENTER MISTER DIRECTOR.
SURE- THANK YOU I'LL- A COUPLE.
ONE WHICH IS. SORT OF RUN OVER.
IN RIGHT IN BED. DOT IN A WAY
THAT HE'S- WHAT HOW. AND
HAPPENING A COORDINATED FASHION
THE STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WORKING TOGETHER TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS- I CREW. IN IN THE
IN THE- CATEGORIES OF. AT
BRICKS AND MORTAR AS WELL AS
SERVICES. THE SECOND. WHICH IS
POLICIES THAT CAN EXPECT I. X.
KNEW HOW. FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. THE
LEGISLATURE SAUDI URGENCY OF
THE MOMENT WITH ONE KEY AND WE
AB EIGHTY THREE PASS KEY POLICY
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW US TO
MOVE QUICKLY THAN THE
TRADITIONAL DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
ALLOW SO CONTINUING THIS
PROGRAM AND ALL THEIR SIMILAR
TO THESE WILL ALLOW FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT WE NEED THE
ASSISTANCE AND AGAIN LOOK NO
FARTHER THAN EIGHTY EIGHTY
THREE TO KNOW WHY THIS PROGRAM
HUNKY HUBBY SUCCESS THAT INDEED
AND IS JUST TRYING TO REPLICATE
THINGS LIKE THAT. THANK YOU
MISTER DIRECTOR MAY DE
SECRETARY THEY WERE GONNA GO TO
CHAIRWOMAN EGGMAN FOR FINAL
COMMENT TO APLEY MADAM DEPUTY.
YEAH VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
RUSSIAN AS WELL AND WITH
REITERATE ALL THE DIRECTORS
INSTEAD YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA IS
PROBABLY A HOUSING FIRST STATE
AND WITH THAT MEANS THAT WE
NEED TO BRING NEW HOUSING
ONLINE AS WELL AS SORT OF. I
THINK MY COUNTY RIGHT NEW UNITS
BUT ALSO IN MAKING ABOUT HOW TO
REPEAT THIS YEAR'S INTO ARE YOU
BECAUSE- THEY STARTED USING
RENTAL ASSISTANCE USING
LANDLORD INCENTIVES THINGS OF
THAT NATURE TO. TRY TO ACCESS
THE PRIVATE HOUSE MARKET BUT
ALSO QUITE TO THE FACT THAT
SENATOR MENTION AND YOU MENTION
IF YOU HERE AS WE HAVE THE
LARGEST UNSHELTERED HOMELESS
POPULATION. IT IS WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BALANCE CRISIS RESPONSE
WHICH ARE PERMANENT HOUSING
SOLUTIONS AND SO BEING ABLE TO
HOLD WEEK FOR BOTH OF THOSE AND
I WOULD POINT TO OUR ACTION
PLAN AND YOU'RE IN THE MIDST OF
DRAFTING. WITH SORT OF THE
PRINCIPLES AND PRACTICES THAT
NEED TO BE BELIEVE AS
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHT FOCUSING ON
RACIAL EQUITY AND JUSTICE
FOCUSING ON THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES VARIETY COME
HOMELESS I HAD A RANGE OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF
INTERVENTIONS AND SUPPORTS THEY
NEED TO FIND PERMANENT HOUSING.
SO THIS IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL IT IS MULTI PRONGED WE NEED
TO BE MINDFUL OF THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
REASONS FOR BEING WHERE THEY
ARE AND WHAT THEY NEED TO GET
OUT OF IT. AND WE NEED TO BE
DOING THAT WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING AND EXPERTISE AND
PEOPLE BATTLING SIX PERIODS I'M
SO IT NEEDS TO BE MORE
PROMINENT NEEDS TO BE VERY
REALISTIC AND NOT JUST A ONE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ALL WISH THERE
WAS- BUT UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS
NOT A ONE A ONE SO ONLY
SOLUTION FOR A PROBLEM. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY- WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN FOR THE FINAL
WORD. I WOULD JUST I THINK YOU
AND I AND I THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR WORK AND I AND I KNOW. IT
IS NOT EASY THEN. BUT I WOULD
JUST OFFER WHAT. WOULD YOU TOLD
ME AS WELL OF IS MORE OF THIS.
IS MORE THE SAME AND IT'S-
GREAT WE CAN ALL DRIVER AND SEE
IF. IT IS BEING OF. AND SO YOU
UNDER. PEOPLE ARE THE PEOPLE
SKEPTICAL- IN A- SO THANK YOU
AND I THINK ONE OF THE MY
COLLEAGUE OVER HERE FOR. SELENA
SAID THE BILL BILL BUILD WE
MORE HOUSING WE NEED MORE
HOUSING AND YES WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO. TO CARE FOR
UNSHELTERED BUT- HI I LOOK FOR
THIS CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK. JUST
MORE THE SAME IT IS GETTING US
OUT OF THIS. IT WOULD THEE WAS
A STORM BEFORE THE STORM IT'S
BEEN IT'S BEEN RAINING AND
HAILING FOR AWHILE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH READING CHAIR WANTED TO
QUIT TIME CHECKING ALL SORT
NINE FORTY THREE. WHAT WOULD I
DO WE HAVE TO DO IS GET TO OUR
NEXT PANEL. A LITTLE BEFORE
ELEVEN O'CLOCK AT THAT'S THE
NEXT PANEL IS GOING TO BE
FOCUSED ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SO
WE HAVE TO CURRENTLY IN THEIR
QUEUE CENTER CORTESE. CENTER
DORADO IN THE MAJORITY LEADER
HERTZBERG. SO WE'RE GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO CENTER CORTESE AT
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS. GOOD
MORNING SIR. THANK YOU- MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I'M GONNA JUST
CONFINE MY QUESTIONS TO SCALE-
AND SEGMENTING AND HOW WE'RE
GOING ABOUT THAT JUST TO. GET
SOME MORE CLARITY ON THAT FIRST
OF ALL THANK YOU FOR. THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS PROVIDED.
A PRIOR TO TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK THUS FAR WITH VERY
LIMITED RESOURCES IN IN MY
OPINION. IN I THINK WE SHOULD
LOSE SIGHT- THAT WHICH IS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO WHERE THERE
WEREN'T NOT LINE ITEMS ARE
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THIS KIND OF
WORK- AVAILABLE TO DO THE WORK
AND I DON'T WANT YOU TO KNOW I
UNDERSTAND THAT. BUT SECRETARY
SUTTON I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH-
YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT HAVING A
BALANCE- IN AS I HEARD THEM HOW
TO BALANCE INVESTMENT ABLE
PURPOSE PART OF HOUSING. AND
SHELTER TO DO IT ALL WE CAN
HELP PEOPLE WITH AN INCREASE IN
UNDERPASSES AND SO FORTH AS WE
IS DESCRIBED. BY MY COLLEAGUE
WAITING FOR PERMITS SPORT
HOUSING TO BE BUILT IT WE HAVE
TO BUILD IT. WITH THAT IN MIND-
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT WORK HAS
BEEN DONE IN TERMS OF. IN TERMS
OF EXTRAPOLATING FOR SCALING
THE BUDGETARY APPROPRIATIONS
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED- TO BUILD
THE NECESSARY PERMITS SUPPORT
HOUSING FOR THIS POPULATION
WHICH FOR TODAY'S SNAPSHOT IS A
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE THOUSAND. AND
SIMULTANEOUSLY HOW MUCH. OF A
OF AN APPROPRIATION WOULD BE
NEEDED. HI TO SHELTER THOSE WHO
WERE WAITING FOR THAT PURPOSE
PART OF HOUSING WHILE THEY'RE
WAITING. I KNOW IT'S A LOT MORE
MONEY THAN WHAT YOU HAVE ALL
YOU HAVE AVAILABLE TO YOU RIGHT
NOW WHAT THE LEGISLATURE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S- PAST EFFORTS HAVE
HAVE PROVIDED FOR. WHATEVER
REASONS GOOD REASONS RELATED TO
WHAT WORK HAS BEEN DONE TO
EXTRAPOLATE THAT IT LET ME JUST
SAY FOR CONTACTS IN SENECA
COUNTY WAS RECENTLY A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR WE PASSED THE NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
EXTREMELY LONG HOUSING BOND.
WHICH EXTRAPOLATED OUT WITH A
THREE TO ONE INVESTMENT MATCH
BETWEEN DEVELOPERS
MUNICIPALITIES AND SO FORTH- IS
ON SCHEDULE TO HOUSE ABOUT
FORTY HUNDRED FOLKS IN PURPOSE
PORT OF HOUSING. I WILL ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN THAT COUNTY
THERE'S REALLY NO SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING FOR SHELTERING- THE
EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL. IN KANSEN AND CREEKS
WAITING FOR THAT PURPOSE
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND THAT IS
THE CONTEXT FOR THAT QUESTION
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE CAN DO TO SCALE AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL. LASTLY LET ME
JUST ASK IN IT AND ALL SIT DOWN
STRUCTURE WHAT- HAS BEEN DONE
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF SEGMENTATION. IN
THAT SCARY FOR EXAMPLE THERE
ARE DIFFERENT TOOLS AVAILABLE
M. PARTNERS AVAILABLE A WITH
REGARD TO. ENDING VETERANS
HOMELESSNESS. I THAN THERE IS
FOUR X. FOUR OTHER DEMOGRAPHICS
FOR EXAMPLE. AM I INTRODUCED A
BILL. SB. SEVEN THIRTY NINE.
WHICH TALKS ABOUT BASIC INCOME.
A FOR FOSTER YOUTH TRANSITION
AGE FOSTER YOUTH THE POPULATION.
AT REPRESENTS ABOUT 40% OF THE
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS NOW. IN
ABOUT ONE IN FOUR TRANSITION
AGE FOSTER YOUTH ARE HOMELESS
TODAY- SO AGAIN CONTEXT I'M
JUST ASKING FOR CONTEXT ARE
PROVIDING CONTEXT IN TERMS OF
MY QUESTION HOW MUCH SHOULD WE
LOOK AT ATTACKING SEGMENTS
DEMOGRAPHIC SEGMENTS BASED ON
VARIOUS TOOLS WE HAVE AVAILABLE
THANK YOU THE STRUCTURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH SENATORS SO- WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IS THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY TO BE
ATTORNEY. TAKE THREE QUESTIONS
AND WE'RE GONNA DO A LITTLE BIT
OF A LIGHTNING ROUND JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER SENATORS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK SO IF
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT. HOW MUCH IS
NEEDED. TO SHELTER THOSE
HUNDRED ONE FIFTY ONE THOUSAND.
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN TO BE A TO
SCALE THE BUDGET. AND THEN WHAT
WITH APPROACH WOULD BE IN
REGARDS IS SEGMENTING THE
HOMELESS POPULATION WHETHER
IT'S- WOMEN AND KIDS- VETERANS
THOSE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE X. ADDRESS IF YOU COULD
DEAL WITH THOSE THREE
SPECIFICS- CENTER CORTESE THANK
YOU SO MUCH READING DEPUTY
SECTOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION- I
THINK YOU ARE GOING TO BE VERY
INTERESTED AND THE HOME DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM THAT WE ARE
LAUNCHING HERE. IN ABOUT A
MONTH AND SO I WILL MAKE SURE
TO FOLLOW UP AND MAKE SURE YOU
GET A DEMONSTRATION OF THAT I
THINK THAT IS OUR BEST CHANCE
AT THIS STAGE- NEED TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE ACCESSING HOMELESSNESS
SERVICES ACROSS THE STATE. AND
SO IT WELL IT WON'T TO GET AT A
WHOLE GAS ASSESSMENT REMAINS OF
THAT NATURE IT VERY MUCH WILL
HELP US UNDERSTAND HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ACCESSING SERVICES
HOW MANY FOLKS ARE STAR ARE
STILL. UNABLE TO MOVE THROUGH
THE SYSTEM AS ME BUT AT MEDIA
AND QUICK WAY- YOU KNOW I THINK
THAT. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS NOT STATIC AND
SAID THERE ARE WHAT WE CALL
INFLOWS. AND AS IT IS FOR THIS
IS FROM THE SYSTEM REALLY AND
SO REALLY BEING MINDFUL OF
HAVING A FULL SYSTEM FROM
CHILDREN ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO
PERMANENT HOUSING IS REALLY
CRITICAL SO WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HAVE A BETTER DAY. HIS FORM
THOSE KINDS OF QUESTIONS HERE
IN JUST A MONTH AND SO WE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO BE ABLE.
TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU ALL AND
WITH THAT I ALSO WILL GET SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MEDITATION AT
THAT AGE I ASKED SYSTEM WILL
ALLOW US TO TRACK. ON VETERANS
HOMELESSNESS. MANY USE ON
CERTAIN PRODUCTS THAT HAD- HAD
REPORTED ITEMIZING VIOLENCE.
AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO REALLY
SEGMENT OUT WHAT IS WORKING
FOR. AND BE ABLE TO BETTER
TARGET OUR POLICY THAN PHYSICAL
DECISIONS BASED ON THAT SO WE
HAVE BEEN BUILDING THE SYSTEM
FOR ALMOST EIGHTEEN MONTHS IT
LAUNCHES NEXT MONTH IN YOUR
INCREDIBLY EXCITED BY. THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT IT PRESENTS-
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF OTHER
SEGMENTATIONS I WOULDN'T KNOW
WE DO HAVE YOU SET ASIDE
FINDING WHEN HE BEHALF WE HAVE
SEEN THAT CAN BE VERY USEFUL.
IN GETTING THAT POPULATION THE
ATTENTION IT NEEDS AND THEN OUR
RESIDENTS RESPONSE SYSTEM- AND
SO I THINK WE'LL BE ABLE THAT
HIGHLIGHTS AND MORE OF THAT. IN
THE COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS.
THE QUESTION. FINDING PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THROUGH A
HOME KEY ADDITIONAL TEMPORARY
IN HIS ROOM KEY OR- OTHER.
SOURCES THIS. DATA SYSTEM IS
GONNA TELL US HOW MUCH WOULD BE
NEEDED- IN WHAT THE APPROACH
SHOULD BE IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. I THINK IT WILL HELP
INFORM ACTION I THINK THERE'S A
LOT MORE THAT WE NEED TO DO
RESEARCH ACCESS PRINTER ARE
QUITE EXTENSIVE KIANA AND
RESPONSIBLE WAY BUT I THINK
THAT YEAH I ASK WILL START IT'S
ON A PATH TO HAVE. A VERY GOOD
ANSWERS TO BE GETTING ACCESS
YES. IF IT'S IN THE INTEREST OF
EACH OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I THINK
ANY WOULD BE HELPFUL IS- IN THE
NEXT SIXTY TO NINETY DAYS THAT
WE CAN HOST. A BRIEFING ON THAT
SO THAT MEMBERS CAN HAVE. DO A
DEEP DIVE IT'S INTERESTED THE
COMMITTEES- ON THE SYSTEM-
SOONER CORTESE AND ASK THIRTY
SECONDS IF YOU DON'T MIND YOU
HAVE A FINAL WORD THIRTY
SECONDS- ONLY THAT I APPRECIATE
YOUR REQUEST. REPORT TO THE
BRIEFING AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO US WHETHER WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO REPLICATE
HOMELESSNESS IN. TWO YEARS FIVE
YEARS OR TEN YEARS TO HAVE
THOSE- NON STATIC EXTRAPOLATION
NUMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU TO
EVERY SECTOR WERE GONNA GO TO
SENATOR REID SAID IN RETURN THE
FORMER TO MAJORITY LEADER.
HERTZBERG CENTER DRAWS A GOOD
MORNING. I CAN CHAIR I WANT TO
SHOW. THAT RECENTLY WE A NEW
CITY. MEMBER KEVIN DE LEON AND
WE'VE BEEN WERE. CLOSE TO GET
AND IT IT REALLY MAKES A
DIFFERENCE- AND ONE THING HE'S
DONE IS TO PURCHASE THESE OLD
STYLE MOTELS. COM FOR
PERMANENT. SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
HE'S A IT'S WORKING BUT- IT'S
EXPENSIVE- TAKES TIME AND- BUT
WORKS WELL IF IT'S TARGETED AND
IN MY OWN AREA JUST BLOCKS AWAY
FROM FROM WHERE I LIVE- THAT.
FIRST PLACES ALREADY BEEN
BOUGHT AND IT'S AND IT'S YOU
KNOW HOW GOOD IT CAN WORK- I
HAVE A JUST A QUICK QUESTION.
WITH REGARDS TO THE TRANSITION-
PLANS- AND I APOLOGIZE IF THIS
WAS IT ADDRESSED EARLIER- DOES
DOES DO TRANSITION PLANS- FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE GOING
THROUGH THIS. PROCESS DOES IT
INCLUDE JOB TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AS
PART OF THE- THE SERVICES AND
ANY EXPERIENCES. WITH EMPLOYERS
AND OUR EXISTING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM THANK YOU.
GREAT QUESTION VEGAS DRAWS I'M
HERE TO IT OVER DIRECTOR OF.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE SERVICES
THAT THE EXPECTATIONS OF
SERVICES THAT WOULD BE OFFERED
FOR EXAMPLE AT THE HOME KEY
SITES THAT CENTER DRAWS ARE
DECIDED THAT'S IN HER DISTRICT
RIGHT NEAR HER HOME- AND WOULD
THAT OFFER JOB PLACEMENT
EMPLOYMENT SKILLS- FINANCE.
GIVE LIFE SKILL TRAINING
ECCENTRIC MISTER DIRECTOR.
THANK YOU CENTER YES WE'RE
OPERATING UNDER A HOUSING FIRST
MODEL IN A PERMANENT.
SUPPORTIVE MODEL ON THE SAME
TIME SO. THE EXPECTATION IS
VERY CLEAR FOR THE CLUNKY
PROJECTS TO HAVE TO THE- EXTENT
FEASIBLE- ON SITE THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN THESE-
FACILITIES CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF- APRIL FIRST IS WHEN WE ARE
REQUIRED BY STATUTE TO DELIVER
A REPORT. ON ALL THE TYPES OF
SERVICES REALLY POPULATION IN A
BUNCH OF BREAKING DOWN A
DETAILED INFORMATION PROJECT BY
PROJECT WILL BE NINETY FOUR
PROJECTS INCLUDING THE TYPES OF
SERVICES. THAT WILL BE
DELIVERED IN EVERY FACILITY- WE
ARE- AB WE WILL BE COMPILING
ALL THAT INFORMATION AND
REPORTING APRIL FIRST SOLD BY
THEN WE WILL HAVE. A VERY CLEAR
PICTURE OF THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THE SKILL OF THE
SERVICES BASED ON THE
POPULATION THAT EACH OF THIS
PERSON WILL BE. BUT YES THAT IS
THE EXPECTATION THANK YOU
MISTER DIRECTOR ON ANY GIVEN
THIRTY SECONDS UP TO SENATOR
ALSO SYNDROME. YOU'RE GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER DIRECTOR ALL RIGHT LET'S.
GO TO MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG.
MISTER SENATOR MORE. THANK YOU
I DON'T REALLY HAVE A CO ON
EACH IS OF COURSE I HAVE A CO.
AND I START OUT BY TE
INSPIRATION OF. SURE WOMAN
EGGMAN. WHO ACTUALLY INSPIRED
ME TO STAND AND MAKE THE
STATEMENT. I THINK SHE IN A
VERY HUMAN WAY. EXPRESSED POINT.
THIS WE HAVE THESE HEARINGS IN
THIS AUGUST CHAMBER. IT'S TIME
TO BE IN REASONABLE. IT'S TIME
TO GET IN GOOD TROUBLE. THIS IS
RIDICULOUS I LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY WHERE I HAVE IN MY
FORTY SIX YEARS IN VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF PUBLIC SERVICE NEVER
SEEN THE COMMUNITY THIS UPSET.
AT EVERY LEVEL. AT THE MOST
HUMAN LEVEL TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON OUR STREETS. FROM
BUSINESS LEADERS TO EVERY PART
OF THE SOCIETY. AND WE'RE
HAVING THIS REASONABLE
CONVERSATION WE'RE USING ALL
THESE FANCY BUREAUCRATIC WORDS
WHAT I LOOK AT THE MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIFTY
BILLION DOLLARS AND I LOOKED AT
A HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS MY
QUICK CALCULATIONS AROUND
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A
PERSON. I COME FROM LOS ANGELES
WE JUST APPROVED TAXES AND
SALES TAXES AND WE APPROVED
BONDS. I'M SORRY THE NUMBERS
AREN'T GOOD ENOUGH DOESN'T
MATTER WE HAVE TIMES IN OUR
HISTORY WE FACE EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGES. THE END OF ISSUE
THERE IS NO EXCUSE IT IS NOT
TIME TO BE REASONABLE. IT IS
TIME TO FIX NO EXCUSES THE
PEOPLE OF COPIOUSLY AT EVERY
LEVEL OF THE EXPERIENCE WITH
RICH EXPERIENCE IN HOMELESSNESS
OR SOMEBODY TO COMMUNITY THAT'S
AFFECTED BY SOMEBODY'S OUTSIDE
THEIR DOOR ARE UP IN ARMS. WE
HAVE TO IN BODY THAT LEVEL OF
URGENCY PROGRAM SCHMO GRAMS
FANCY SHE FANCY WORDS IT
MATTERS NOT FRICTION OR GET OUT
OF THE WAY. SENATOR EGGMAN WAS
RIGHT. THAT IS INFORMS OUR
ATTITUDE H. INFORM EVERY ASPECT
OF OUR SENSE OF URGENCY WE LOVE
TO TALK ABOUT GOOD TROUBLE WELL
YOU KNOW THOSE PEOPLE WHO DID
GOOD TROUBLE. ISRAEL TROUBLE
BIG RISKS ENGAGED THEY WERE
WRONG SOMETIMES THEY GOT BEAT
UP AND THROWN IN JAIL OR
WHATEVER TO FIGHT FOR THE CALLS
AND I JUST THINK IS WE- AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS TODAY AT
EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT DON'T
POINT FINGERS OF FEDERAL MONEY
YOUR STATE MONEY YOU'RE COUNTY
MONIER CITY MONEY TAXPAYERS
RIGHT TO CHECK. FIX IT FIX IT
FIX IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU CENTERS ON. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MAJORITY LEADER
AND AFTER SHARING THE
SENTIMENTS I THINK FOR SO MANY
AT. THE END OF THE CENTURY I
WANT TO SEE IF YOU WANTED TO BE
A TO RESPOND TO THAT AND THEN
WE'LL GIVE THE MAJORITY LEADER
THIRTY SECONDS BUT AT MADAME W.
SECTOR EVENING YOU WOULD LIKE
TO RESPOND TO. YEAH I NEED TO
SAY. THAT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT PASSION AND I ASSURE YOU
THAT- WE FEEL THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO BE PROFESSIONAL HERE
BUT WE FEEL IT. AND IT HAS
BEEN. AN INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING
YEAR FROM. FOLKS ON THE GROUND
SERVING PEOPLE ALL THE WAY UP
TO OUR STAFF. AND IT IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN WORKING.
A LONG HOURS TO TRYING
PARTICULARLY THIS YEAR TO KEEP
NOT JUST HOUSE POKES. BUT
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE THEY ARE CITY- AND HEALTHY
AND NOT AT RISK OF REALLY
REALLY SCARY HEALTH ISSUES AND
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PASSION WE ARE VERY EXCITED TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR. I'M AN
ARTIST JUST GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PASSION IS ISSUE. SB SIX THREE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WE ARE GOING
TO GO TO ONE LAST QUESTION AND
I HAVE A QUICK COMMENT BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO. UR NEXT PANEL
AND THAT IS A SENATOR A
CHILLAGOE. GOOD MORNING I AM SO
EXCITED AND- INSPIRED THIS
MORNING. IN QUITE MOVED
ACTUALLY. YOU'RE GOOD WE ARE IN
HOUSING POPULATIONS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I WAS SO PASSIONATE
ABOUT READING. PURPOSE IN BEING
HERE. AND TO HEAR MY
COUNTERPARTS PEAK. POINTS THAT
I HAVE MADE. HAS REALLY
MOTIVATED ME INSPIRED ME BUT
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO THIS AND WORK
TOGETHER AND THAT IS SO
ENCOURAGING. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- WITH REGARDS TO THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE AUDITOR-
RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GRANT MORE
AUTHORITY AND RESPONSIBILITY TO
THE HOMELESS COORDINATING. AND
FINANCING AND FINANCING COUNCIL
SO THAT IT COULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE IN FIGHTING
HOMELESSNESS. WHICH SPECIFIC
RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD BE TO RE
DIRECTED TO BE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE COUNCIL IN
ORDER TO MAKE IT MORE EFFECTIVE.
AND ALLOW ME JUST FOLLOW UP
REALLY QUICK WITH JUST I'M JUST
GONNA READ THE QUESTIONS REALLY
QUICKLY. IN THE OFFICE OF TIME.
WHICH STATE POLICIES ARE MORE%
RESPONSIBLE FOR EXASPERATING
THE COST OF BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THEN THE LAST
COMMENT I BUT I THINK IT WAS
ALREADY ADDRESSED- HOW CAN WE
PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS WITH A
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THEY NEED
TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES IF YOU WANT EVEN
KEEP THEM IN OUR CARE LONG
ENOUGH TO BE EFFECTIVE. THAT'S
IT FOR ME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SOONER IN AB I THINK
THE SENATOR EXPRESSES
EVERYONE'S PASSION AND- HOW
PERSONAL THIS IS FOR SO MANY IN
THIS ROOM IN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ELOQUENT WORDS ALONG WITH
MAJORITY LEADER AND ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS. SO LET'S GO TO OUR
PANEL- LET'S TALK ABOUT LET'S
pGO TO THE DEPUTY SECRETARY
FIRST. WHAT ON THE IN THE IN
THE AUDIT FINDINGS RELATED TO
BE COORDINATING COUNCIL CAN YOU
EXPLAIN EXPLAIN TO US INTO
CENTER CHEWABLE. WHAT IF
STORIES THAT COUNCIL NEED TO
MAKE IT MORE EFFECTIVE. YEAH I
AND I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION-
AND ACTUALLY THE SECOND TIME I
ALSO DISMISSED MANY OF THE
OTHER TWO QUESTIONS THAT YOU
ASK SENATOR I WILL GET OVER TO
WRECKED A RECOGNIZED BY THE
INTERACTIVE TOWNSEND BUT ON
THAT. DAY IN RELATION TO THAT
THE COUNCIL I MEAN I DO THINK
WE STAND READY VERY READY TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE I AM
FREEZING YES ALREADY ON THE OF
THE COUNCIL I'M PARTICULARLY AS
IT PERTAINS TO COLLECTING
ADDITIONAL DATA. FROM STATEWIDE
OTHER STATEWIDE PROGRAM I THINK
THAT THERE IS SOME OPPORTUNITY
THERE CAN BETTER INFORM
EVALUATE AND REVIEW STATEWIDE
LEVEL AND SO I WOULD JUST
MENTION THAT. SOME OF THE OTHER
PIECES THERE ARE- WE VERY MUCH
BELIEVE IN ARE EAGER TO SHARE
THE ACTION PLAN I'M HERE COMING
UP IN A MONTH WE DO THINK THAT
WILL HELP INFORM A LOT OF THE
CORONATION CONCERNS THAT THE
AUDIT CRIED OUT. AND AS WELL AS
THE GIS SO THE BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS IN TERMS OF BETTER
COORDINATION AND HAVING SOME OF
THE DATA WE NEED TO JUST BE
BETTER ADD MORE EFFECTIVELY
TARGETING SOME OF OUR RESOURCES
THEY WERE AROUND THE RACE TRACK
FOR ME VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
WASTE AT IT THROUGH SOME OF OUR
THIRTY TAX A DATA- BETTER OUR.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE DIRECT.
THAT ABOUT WHAT- TO DOES THE
RECORDING COUNCIL. TO MAKE IT
MORE FOR. AND PARAPHRASE
MESSAGE BOGUE- DIRECT JOHNSON.
LAST ARE GONNA FIRST THE SIX
SECOND. IS BECAUSE OF. DIRECTOR
JOHNSON. YES SIR THAT WHEN I
WOULD SAY THIS EIGHT EIGHT
MULTI DISCIPLINE BODY THAT WE
ARE TO GET IN THIS THAT THAT'S
JUST CRITICAL TO ALL. AT A THAT
WOULD BE MADE TO DATE- YOU KNOW
THAT SAME DAY. OF AT THE HOUSE
AND PRINCE TO THE QUESTION OF
THE CENTER. I ALSO TO BACK SIR
IF ARE. JOINING THE MEDIA
SHELTERING NEEDS TO THE POINT
THAT YOU MAY HOW CAN THEN. AND
SHE MAKING THE FILE UP AND-
POINTS TO. ANY OTHER. THAT THE-
HAS. A IN SUPPORT SO AND THAT
THAT'S CERTAINLY PART OF OUR
INTENTION EFFORT IN IN IN OUR
PARTNERSHIP OF BOTH COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICE AGENCIES AND
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. FOR SUPPORT. AND
ON GOING NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE BETTER BEING HOUSE.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR DAMASCUS.
YEAH I'M A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
COUNCIL AND- I HAVE TO SAY YOU
KNOW IN IN MY TIME HERE A NINE
MONTHS. OR SO. TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS BEING MADE IF YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
NOT SEEN FOR YOUR STOP AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE DRAFT.
ACTION PLAN THAT THE COUNCIL IS
GOING TO BE HAVING A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY WITH
FIVE KEY ACTION AREAS OF HOW
THE HOMELESSNESS AGENDA AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS TO MOVE
FORWARD TO. YOU SHOULD YOU
SHOULD SEE IT BECAUSE IT'S A
LOT OF WORK A LOT OF INPUT FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE STATE LEVEL
BALL ACROSS JURISDICTIONS. A
CONVENIENCE OF CARE. IS
CONVENIENT I MEAN THE PLAN IS
NOT APPROVED AND ADOPTED YET
BUT IT STARTS WITH READ.
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN AND SO THE
ABILITY FOR THE COUNCIL TO GET
ALL THE SUPPORT HE NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO GUIDE. THE
OVERARCHING PRIORITIES AND
POLICIES FOR HOMELESSNESS OF
THE STATE AND THE ABILITY TO
REALLY COORDINATE ACROSS ALL
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES AS
THEY DO. I MEAN WE WORK
TOGETHER YOU KNOW EIGHT C. D. I
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS YOU KNOW
THAT. JACK FORTY NATION I THINK
IS WHAT. THE BODY REALLY
ADDRESSED AND THAT'S IT WE'RE
MOVING REALLY AND A DIRECTION
TO. FIND THE ACCORDING NATION
TO STRENGTHEN THE COORDINATION
AND SO I'M GOING TO STICK
TREMENDOUS. WORK DEPEND ON IN
THE LAST IN THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS AND NOW THANK YOU I
REQUEST YOU UP TO THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR YOUTH EMPOWER
INDUSTRY DIRECT BEFORE WE MOVE
ON TO LAST QUESTION THAT I
CENTER CHOI BOGUE HAD WAS. WHAT
POLICIES ARE NEEDED TO BE ABLE
TO ADVANCE- HOUSING QUICKER-
SINCE YOU ARE THE POINT ON ALL
ISSUES OF HOME KEY IN THE
HOUSING COMPONENT. CAN YOU A
GOOD SIXTY SECONDS TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION THE ROOM TO GIVE
A THIRTY SECOND RESPONSE TO MR
GOLDBERG MISTER DIRECTOR. I
THINK CENTER WINNER PUT IT
REALLY WELL DURING HIS OPENING
REMARKS WHEN SHE KIND OF
EXPLAIN THE PROBLEM AS SUPPLY
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING
THE HOUSING IS TOO EXPENSIVE
AND THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO. EIGHT
MUCH GREATER PROBLEM. ACCOUNT
HOMELESSNESS REALLY THE ACCENT-
HERE IN CALI. AND I'D SAY KNOW
I. MADE REFERENCE WHEN SOME
ASKED HER ABOUT- HOW DO OF WE
KIND OF SCALE SCALE THESE. THIS
STATE AND EVEN THOUGH. SEEM IS
APPROVED. I THE LOCAL LEVEL THE
STATE HAS TO EXIST ELECTION.
ADMINISTRATOR HAS TO THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS. AT TO CREATE
MORE URGE. AT SUCH AS WHAT WE
DID WITH. I WE KEEP POLICY
PROVISION THAT ALLOW US TO MOVE
WE- THAT. THE TRADE.
DEVELOPMENT HELLO SO. JUST
REALLY. WITH IN PLENTY OF JUST.
OUT THERE ABOUT. WHAT ARE THE
TOOLS TO READ. BARRIERS TO THE-
PROCESS TO BE SLOW. AND JUST
AGAIN JUST DOES NOT SENSE OF
URGENCY INCONVENIENT TO ADVANCE
POLICIES TO MOVE. DEVELOPMENT
WEAKER HAVE- AT BROAD GEN AT AT
BOB I SCHOOL AS POSSIBLE THAT'S
GOING TO ONE. THE SUPPLY IS
GOING HAVE BEEN CHOI I. INTO
TIME. FROM HOMELESSNESS. THE
YOU SO MUCH MISTER DIRECTOR AT
I DON'T MEAN IT SHORT BUT I
WANT TO. TURN OVER TO SENATOR
CHILUBA THIRTY. AT ANY RISK IN
MAY HAVE. JUST REMEMBER. FOR
THE IN. EIGHT GIVING ME SOME.
AND DIRECTION IN THE WORD OF
WITH WITH I LOOKED TO WORK WITH
MIKE. ON THIS. IT'S FROM THE
HEART WE DO NEED TO FIX IT%
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SOME
SENATOR IN WE ARE. THAT YOU
HERE- LASKI ZERO GONNA MOVE ON
TO OUR LOCAL. I'M IF YOU CAN
JUST COMMENT MADAM DEPUTY
SECRETARY ON THE AUDITOR
REPORT. SEEING A RECOMMENDATION
OF POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT ONE
AGENCY ONE AGENCY- COMBINED
COORDINATED. ON HOMELESSNESS
LAKE WASHINGTON MARYLAND AND
VIRGINIA DO- WINE MULTIPLE
AGENCIES VERSUS LOOKING AT
BRINGING IN ONE THAT COULD BE A
SUPER AGENCY BEING ABLE TO HAVE
A COORDINATED APPROACH. THAT
THE END OF THE CENTURY I DON'T
MEAN TO PUSH YOU. BUT I JUST
BECAUSE OF TIME BUT I CAN ASK
YOU TRY TO KEEP THIS ABOUT
SIXTY SECONDS. YEAH THANK I
WOULD SAY YOU KNOW. CALIFORNIA
IS AN INCREDIBLY LARGE STATE
AND SO LOOKING AT WELL WE
REALLY APPRECIATE LOOKING AT
OTHER STATES- AND THEIR MODELS
WE ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH WITH A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF THE POPULATION
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE ARE IN
THE MONTH IN THE MIDST OF DOING
AND WITH THE ACTION PLAN AND
SOME OF THE WORK HERE IN THE
LAST YEAR PARTICULAR. IS TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT AGENCIES
THAT CATCH HOMELESSNESS BUT
THIS IS NOT ONE AGENCY AND IS
ADVERTISING FROM YOU SAYING
THAT THAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS PARTICULARLY THIS YEAR
WE'VE SEEN ON SOCIAL SERVICES I
NEED TO BRING IN SERVICES FOR
MACY'S ACTUALLY SEE THIS AS A
MULTI CONCORD IN NEEDED
APPROACH WE DON'T NECESSARILY
SEE THE NEED FOR IT CAN BE. ONE
THING EVERYWHERE BUT MORE SO
THAT ALL OF THESE APARTMENTS ON
A PIECE OF SOLVING THIS PROBLEM
IS- THAT IS VERY MUCH THAT THE
MINDSET OF THE ACTION PLAN ALL
OF OUR DEPARTMENTS CAMPAIGN
DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES THAT THEY
HAVE COMMITTED TO AND THAT IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS A COUNCIL
TO MAKE SURE THOSE ARE
COORDINATED. AND MOVING FORWARD
IT'S A THAT IS VERY MUCH FROM
YOU SEE YOURSELF GOING OUT AND
MEETING FANS I HAVING THE H. I.
S. SYSTEM WILL ALLOW ALL TO
WORK FROM THE SAME KIND OF DATA
FOR THE SAME INFORMATION THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE
RIGHT NOW SEE IT OUR MOST
IMPORTANT PIECES OF MAKING SURE
THAT YOU'RE DOING THIS AND I
AND A HOLISTIC. WAY NOT TO SAY
THAT WE DON'T HAVE MUCH MORE
WORK TO DO WE DO WE REALLY FEEL
LIKE THESE COUPLE OF ITEMS THAT
NEED WITH IT OR ON HERE ALASKA
BIT I OF OUR MAY MUCH IN THE
YOU MY WHERE WE SHOULD HAD.
THANK YOU MEDITATORS DEPUTY
SECRETARY IN AS WE MOVE TO OUR
LOCAL LAST QUESTION- THE
AUDITORS THREE. HIGHLIGHTS THAT
LOCAL SERVING THE HOMELESS ARE
TRACKING THE INVESTMENTS THAT
ARE COMING INTO THEIR
JURISDICTIONS AND NOT TRACKING
OUTCOMES AS THEY SHOULD BE CAN
YOU COMMENT ON THAT AND THE
STATE'S APPROACH TO BE ABLE TO
FIX THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND ASK FOR SIXTY SECONDS AND
AGAIN THE END OF THE CENTURY
NOT A ALL TRYING TO BE. BUT
JUST BE THE TIME. NO WORRIES.
NINE QUESTIONS AND I WOULD YOU
KNOW. OUR END. WE KEEP IT WE
HAVE HAVE ANNUAL REPORT AND-
FINDING COMING OUT. THE NIGHT
WEEK OR SO. HE IS HE IS- ARE
ARE PROVIDING US QUITE A BIT OF
DATA THE STATE LEVEL IN AND SO
THEY ARE RECORDING WITHOUT. ARE
PRETTY NO OF PEOPLE ANSWER. I
DON'T LOT ABOUT DATA WILL BE
RELEASED IN A SINGLE. I WOULD
ALSO NAY ALWAYS LIKE A RECORD.
ALL FORTY FOUR CAN. OF CARE ARE.
A AT A OUR HOME DATA AND-
SYSTEM WE WILL ABLE ASK. LEVEL
TO CALL. AND CALCULATE THOSE
PERFORMANCE METRICS LEVEL. I'M
INTO WHILE WE KNOW THEIR DATA
QUALITY WHILE WE- UNIVERSITIES.
WE WILL BE FROM. A OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON. BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY. SYSTEM IS VERY MUCH OF.
FOR TO BE A TO HELP COMMUNITY.
LOOK AT THEIR DATA AND SEE.
GOING BUT IT IS LEVEL. HOW WORK
FOR ME SO YOU BELIEVE. THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD. DATED TO
LIKE HOMELESS TO INTO. SINCE
THAT HAS BEEN- YOU THESE ARE MY
WORDS NOT YOURS A BIT OF A KEY
THESE HE'LL- FOR BOTH THE STATE
AND LOCALS ONE- FIGURING
DETERMINING. INVESTMENT
OUTCOMES- AND PROGRESS IS THAT
I DON'T HAVE WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH AND THEN DEPUTY
SECRETARY. DO YOU BELIEVE A LOT
OF THESE CHALLENGES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT- WILL BE FIXED BASED OFF
OF THE HOMELESS DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM. I DO I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT SOME OF THE
THINGS IN THE HONORS REPORT
ALSO REFERRED TO FEDERAL
REGULATIONS WHICH WE ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED. THAT TO SORT OF
MONITOR FOR. CONTINUED KERR BUT
WE HAVE PROVIDED QUITE A BIT OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THEM
THROUGH HAVE. AND OTHERS AS
WELL AND EIGHTY ON AC OFTEN GET
FROM MONDAY- BUT WE DO BELIEVE
AGE I ASK OUR YOUR POINT IS
BENEFIT OF IT. NOT HAVING. OR
NEEDED STATEWIDE DATA HAD BEEN
ADDED. HEEL PRINTS WERE ON.
POINT ACCOUNT. THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR HOMELESSNESS
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE DIRECTOR
CAME JOHNSON OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND
DIRECTOR. GUSTAVO VELASQUEZ THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. TO EACH OF YOU FOR
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME LOOK.
MEMBERS WE RAN LATE ON THIS
FIRST PANEL BUT BECAUSE IT WAS
SUCH A GOOD DISCUSSION- SO
MANY- INTERESTED CENTERS WE
WANT TO GIVE YOU. THE TIME TO
BE ABLE DO THIS DEEP DIVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH READING DEPUTY
SECRETARY AND DIRECTORS FOR
YOUR TIME I KNOW. THAT YOU NEED
TO ROLL OUT NOW AND- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING THAT BRIEFING
WITH YOU. ON THE HOMELESS DATA
INTEGRATION SYSTEM FOR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE IN THE
NEXT SIXTY TO NINETY DAYS. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE NOW MOVING ON. TO
OUR NEXT PANEL- IT'S CALLED THE
LOCAL BIãU SUCCESSES AND
CHALLENGES WITH PROJECT CONKY
IN ROOM KEEP. THAT WE HEARD
FROM THE STATE NUMBER IN HER
HERE FROM THE LOCALS. ON THOSE
PROGRAMS BEFORE WE GET INTO IT
THOUGH WITH ACTIVATED TURN THE
FLOOR OVE. TO THE CHAIRWOMAN
OF THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THAT SENATOR HER
TITLE. I TO BE ABLE TO GIVE
SOME OPENING REMARKS SHE HAD
ANOTHER MEETING AT THE START
WHICH WE KNEW ABOUT CENTER HER
TITLE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. YOUR
LAST YEAR I LEARNED I CAN
EASILY BLAME OTHERS FOR THE
PROBLEMS WE ARE FACING HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR I
CAN BE PART OF THE SOLUTION. WE
KNOW THAT MODELS HERE. AND
REALLY ACROSS THE NATION HAVE
NOT BEEN WORKING AND I REALLY
DON'T WANT TO PUT BLAME ON
ANYONE- BUT I GUESS I WILL ASK
EVERYONE HOW CAN WE BETTER HOW
CAN WE BE BETTER LISTENERS AND
HOW CAN WE BETTER COORDINATE TO
FIND SOLUTIONS. AND THE REALITY
IS THAT THROWING MONEY AT A
PROBLEM WITHOUT REALLY FULLY
UNDERSTANDING. THE ISSUE AT
THAT WE HAVE AT HAND IS. IS
JUST THROWING MONEY AT
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT GOING TO
SOLVE ANYTHING AND- EVERYTHING
IS REALLY INTERCONNECTED RIGHT
FOR TALKING ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
AND HOW TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND THE HOUSING ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE HERE. BUT I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS HEARING IS A
GREAT START ON HOW DO WE GET TO
SOLVE ANY PROBLEMS FOR
CALIFORNIANS BUT- HILL I WAS
READING AN ARTICLE NOT TOO LONG
AGO AND- IT MADE ME THINK ABOUT
HOW TO APPROACH. ALL THE POPUP
ALL THE DIFFERENT PROBLEMS UP
WITH THE WERE HAVING HERE
TODAY. IN CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND
AND THAT'S- CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION- WE NEED TO. BE
ADAPTING RATHER THAN TRYING TO
PREVENT WHAT IS ALREADY HERE.
AND I WAS READING THROUGH THE
ARTICLE THE GREAT CLIMATE
MIGRATION- THAT WAS- POSTED ON
THE NEW YORK TIMES. AND IT
MENTIONS THE STORY OF A- OF A
SMALL FARMER OUT OF GUATEMALA.
AND HOW THE DROUGHT BASICALLY
FORCED HIM AND HIS FAMILY OUT
OF OUT OF THIS COUNTRY- THEY
WERE FACING STARVATION THEY
WERE- DIDN'T HAVE ANYWHERE TO.
AT YOU KNOW TO SLEEP- AND IT
MADE ME THINK A LOT ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE FACING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THE FIRES AND PEOPLE BEING
DISPLACED IT MADE ME THINK
ABOUT JUST EVEN RECENTLY MY
SISTER WHO I HAVE ACTUALLY
ENTIRE FAMILY THAT LIVES IN
TEXAS AND HOW THEY'VE BEEN
DISPLACED BECAUSE OF THE-
EXTREME. WEATHER THAT THE FEAST
THERE WITHOUT ELECTRICITY
WITHOUT WATER. AND THE REALITY
IS THAT IT'S ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION IN THE CAR
ACROSS THE WORLD BUT HOW DO WE
ADAPT TO BEASTIES. TO THIS NEW
THIS IS NEW CIRCUMSTANCES. AND
I KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S-
WHAT'S WHAT AMALA- IT'S FAR
AWAY THEY'RE MIGRATING NORTH.
THE REALITY IS THAT IT'S
HAPPENING HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
WHERE I THINK PEOPLE ARE
MIGRATING BECAUSE OF THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT. CLIMATE CHANGE
IS ALREADY CREATING AND I
THINK- ABOUT HOW DO WE HOW DO
WE PRINT HOW DO WE PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM STARVATION HOW DO
WE- IT'S A TOPIC WE HAVE TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT IT AS A
WHOLE AND NOT JUST IN IN AND
SILOS. AND I REALLY APPRECIATE-
EVERYONE IN THE WORK THAT THEY
DO BUT I REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
ARE THE RIGHT ONE OF THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS COMING OUT OF
THE ALLEY- IN THE STATE AUDITOR.
WAS TO BE I AM A BIT MORE CLEAR
LESS FRAGMENTED AND TO A LONG
TERM STRATEGY FOR ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AND I THINK THAT-
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON
WITH THAT AND I THINK THAT
TODAY I HOPE THAT WE ALL THINK
ABOUT IT- AND YOU KNOW THAT WE
THINK ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN THAT SENSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING CHAIR
VERY GRATEFUL AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP IN THIS
CRITICAL. BUT HEARING TODAY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
OUR NEXT PANEL WHICH IS GOING
TO BE FOCUSING ON THE LOCAL
VIEW SUCCESSES AND CHALLENGES
WITH PARTS OF ROOM KEY AND HOME
KEY THAT WE'RE GOING TO START
THE PANEL OFF WITH JIM
PREVENTIVA BUT SHE IS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR IN THE GREAT COUNTY
OF YOLO BUT WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
SUPERVISOR PREVENTIVA IS WITH
US TONIGHT SUPER THE PRESENT
PREVENT THAT YOU HAVE THREE TO
FIVE MINUTES I'LL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. IS A
SUPERVISOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR. MISTER PRESIDENT OF THE-
EGO. GOT YOU OFF ME BUT HE
DIDN'T SURPRISE US VERY GOOD
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME THANK YOU. IT'S
VERY GOOD TO BE HERE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THE
PROJECT- A ROOM KEY AND PROJECT
HOME HE HAD BEEN A GODSEND FOR
YOLO COUNTY. WE DON'T HAVE.
OBVIOUSLY IS A SMALL COUNTY AT.
LITTLE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE. THE RESOURCES
SET TO HOUSE THAT MANY PEOPLE.
IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AND
IT WAS. AN. EMERGENCY CONTINUES
TO BE AN EMERGENCY. WE WERE A
TO. US HUNDRED AND SEVEN
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN HOTELS
MOTELS THAT WERE RENTED. IN THE
CITY OF DAVIS THE CITY OF
WOODLAND AND THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO. BUT WE WERE ABLE TO
DO THIS QUICKLY AND- IN DOING
THIS WE WERE ABLE TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE IT WAS
OUR PRIMARY OBJECTIVE DURING
THE PANDEMIC TO PREVENT
OUTBREAKS INVITE. USE THEM FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO BE ISOLATED
WE ALSO. WERE PROTECTING THE
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE SO PEOPLE
OVER AGE SIXTY FIVE WHETHER
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS.
WHO WERE UN HOUSED WELL WE'RE
PLACED IN THE HOTELS WE BELIEVE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO PLACE
EVERYBODY IN THAT CATEGORY
THAT- THAT WANTED TO BE PLACED.
BUT THAT ALSO RELIEVED PRESSURE
AT THE SHELTERS BECAUSE THERE
WAS LESS LESS DEMAND ON THE
SHELTERS. FOR DISTANCING AND WE
WAS AND ALSO IN THOSE WHO
REMAIN HOMELESS AND HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS WE WERE ALSO ABLE
TO INTRODUCE HEALTH MEASURE
THERE AND KEEP THEM SAFE AND WE
DID. AVOID AN OUTBREAK. SO IT
WAS SIX HUNDRED HOMELESS PEOPLE.
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND. NIGHTS
SHOW. AND WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER
VERY SIX PROGRAM I WAS NOT SURE
WHEN WE WENT INTO THIS- HOW
THINGS WOULD GO DOWN BOTH THE
MOTELS WE USED IN DAVIS I
REPRESENT DAVIS. WERE IN MY
DISTRICT AND I WAS PREDICTING-
A LOT OF COMPLAINTS FROM
NEIGHBORHOODS AND PEOPLE WHO
LIVED IN THE AREA. I RECEIVED
NONE. RIGHT OFTEN RECEIVE
COMPLAINTS IN OTHER AREAS WHERE
WE'RE AT HOMELESS OR NOT HOUSE
IN THIS SITUATION ONE OF THE
REASONS IS ONE OF THE
COMPLAINTS THE VERY SIMPLE
THINGS ALL DAY THEY GO TO THE
BATHROOM- IN PUBLIC WORDS THEY
GO AROUND ASKING FOR MONEY
BECAUSE THEY NEED FOOD. WELL
GUESS WHAT WE HAD IN THE MOTELS
WE HAD A PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER
CITIES WITH THE FOOD BANK WITH
ALL THE SOCIAL SERVICES AND
WRAP AROUND SERVICES SO THEY
HAD A PLACE TO USE THE RESTROOM
THEY HAD FOOD THEY HAVE HOT
MEALS NOT ALWAYS BUT MOST OF
THE TIME WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE HOT MEALS FROM LOCAL
RESTAURANTS. ARE WE READING
ABLE TO USE THE FOOD BANK TO
DELIVER FOOD WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE HEALTH SERVICES THROUGH
COMMUNITY CARE FUNDED BY
DIGNITY HEALTH AND CENTER. AND
THIS WAS ALL DONE VERY VERY
RAPIDLY I THINK BECAUSE OF OUR
PRIOR RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE
THAT WE HAD DONE THIS WORK
ALREADY IN OUR HOUSING FIRST
PROGRAM AND WE HAD THE CITIES
AND THE COUNTY WORKING TOGETHER
THEN THE COUNTY BY THE WAY. IS
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
LIVING IN THE RURAL AREAS OF
THE UNINCORPORATED. YOLO COUNTY.
ONE APART ONE IN OKAY THANK YOU
WE ARE ALSO NOW- ENTERING HOME
SHE- THE CITY OF WEST
SACRAMENTO HAS PURCHASED A
HOTEL CITY OF DAVIS HAS RENTED
ON LONG TERM LEASES SOME
APARTMENT BUILDINGS TO OFFER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND WE ARE
WORKING ON PERMANENT HOUSING
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO. PLACE
EIGHTY FIVE PEOPLE IN PERMANENT
HOUSING AND WE HOPE TO INCREASE
THOSE NUMBERS DRASTICALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER ONE
QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED DURING
THE PRIOR PANEL WHAT WOULD WE
HAVE TO ELIMINATE A TOURNAMENT
OF. THE HOW HOMELESS WORK A
PROBLEM WITH OUR IN HOUSE
PERSON SAID I WOULD SAY
PROPERTY ALREADY IS THE GOAL
AND WE ARE DOING A PILOT
PROJECTS SOON THAT WILL PROVIDE
BASIC INCOME THAT MEANS TAKING
PEOPLE OUT. OF POVERTY. WHO
HAVE CHILDREN ZERO TO FIVE- AND
GIVING THEM ENOUGH MONEY A
BASIC INCOME AND SEEING WHAT
THAT DIFFERENCE THAT MAKES.
OVER A PERIOD OF A YEAR AND I
THINK INTEREST PASTA SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SUGGESTION OF BOLD
MOVES THAT MAY OR MAY NOT WORK
I THINK THIS PHONE BILLS THAT
CATEGORY ARE COUNTY WOULD LOVE
TO WORK WITH YOU AND DEVELOPING
SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING AND FOR ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM MEANS A LOT TO US THANK
YOU. IT'S SUPERVISORS SO GOOD
TO SEE YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
YOU'RE WITH US AND WE APOLOGIZE
THAT IT'S TAKEN A LITTLE TIME
TO BE A TO GET TO THIS PANEL
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. IN NOW WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE GOOD MAYOR FROM
THE CITY OF EL CENTRO HER NAME
IS CHERYL VIEGAS WALKER IN
ADDITION TO HER DUTIES AS MAYOR
SHE IS ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CITIES. MADAM PRESIDENT AT WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE SHE'S
GOING TO BE GIVING US THE CITY
PERSPECTIVE. ON ALL ISSUES OF
SUCCESSES AND CHALLENGES WITH
PROJECT ROOM KEY AND HOME KEY
THE FLOOR IS YOURS NOT A
MATTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY- ON SUCH AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC. I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THROUGH THE
LEADER CALIFORNIA CITIES CITY
LEADERS HAVE ABSOLUTELY MADE IT
A PRIORITY TO ADDRESS A HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS AS WELL AS
HOMELESSNESS. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND CERTAINLY
PROJECT ROOM KEY AND HONKY HAVE
PROVIDED CITIES WITH ADDITIONAL
TOOLS AND RESOURCES TO DEAL
WITH THOSE TWO TO HORRIFIC
ISSUES WE'RE DEFINITELY
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE I COULD NOT BE MORE
PLEASED WITH THE TESTIMONY. AND
QUESTIONS I'VE HEARD SO FAR
THIS MORNING SENATOR WIENER IS
ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON WE HAVE A
PROFOUND HOUSING SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED SENATOR EGGMAN
ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE GOT TO
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES.
AND IF YOU ASK ME WHAT I NEED
RIGHT AWAY I NEED ACCESS TO.
HEALTH SERVICES AND SO OF CAL.
IN ORDER- CAVALEIRO I AGREE
ABSOLUTELY THERE HAVE TO BE
METRICS INVOLVED ACCOUNTABILITY
AND EQUITY COMING FROM A RURAL
COMMUNITY THAT WAS MUSIC TO MY
EARS AND SENATOR TITLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TALKING ABOUT-
BETTER COLLABORATION AND
STRATEGY. JUST TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT BECAUSE I
JUST WANT TO GIVE A BIG THANK
YOU TO ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP BECAUSE I WANT YOU
TO KNOW EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU TO KNOW THE LIFE CHANGING
IMPACTS THAT YOUR LEADERSHIP
HAS HAD. IN OUR COMMUNITY-
COUNTY WERE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE WE ARE
GEOGRAPHICALLY ISOLATED IF YOU
DON'T KNOW WHERE WE'RE LOCATED.
THINK ABOUT HOW I CAN SEE
MEXICO FROM MY BACKYARD WE ARE
IN THE SOUTH EASTERN CORNER OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE WERE
STRUGGLING WITH AN 18%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE ONE IN FOUR
OF OUR- RESIDENTS LIVES IN
POVERTY. WE ARE 84% THE LATINO
COMMUNITY- OUR AVERAGE SALARY
IS FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
WE HAVE ONE. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IN OUR COUNTY WE HAVE ONE.
SATELLITE CAMPUS OF THE CSU.
AND WE HAVE LESS THAN 20% OF
OUR RESIDENTS TO HOLD A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. SO YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND GIVEN THOSE DYNAMICS
WHY BEING ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
ARE ONLY COMMUNITY COLLEGE TO
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
STUDENTS WITH A TARGET ON
FOSTER YOU. HAS JUST BEEN A
GAME CHANGER AND AGAIN. THANKS
TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. WHAT TALK
ABOUT HOW THIS WAS FUNDED THE
CITY OF ALL CENTRO RECEIVED TWO
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANT FUNDS FROM PROJECT HUNKY
FOR CONSTRUCTION. IMPERIAL
VALLEY COLLEGE RECEIVED FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND. DOLLARS FROM IMPERIAL
COUNTY. FROM I KEEP FINDING.
AND THEN THE CITY OF ALL
CENTURY IN A- FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
GRANT FUNDING FROM ENTERPRISE
WHICH IS GOING TO FIND TWO
YEARS OF OPERATION. AND OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH IMPERIAL
VALLEY COLLEGE WE LEARNED THAT
THERE WERE APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN SELF IDENTIFIED
HOMELESS STUDENTS. MAKING US
FOR THE SITE ON A GOING FORWARD
BASIS IS GOING TO BE PROVIDED
BY THE IMPERIAL VALLEY COLLEGE
FOUNDATION ONE MINUTE NATION IS
GOING TO BE. RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING ON SITE AND OFF SITE
CASE MANAGEMENT. THE RENT IS
GOING TO BE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER STUDENT PER MONTH
AND STUDENTS WILL ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE TEN HOURS
OF COMMUNITY SERVICE. HOURS PER
MONTH PROJECT IS GONNA SERVE
STUDENTS WITH EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME AND PRIORITIZE FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. I CENTER REQUIRE
ACCESS TO WHAT WE THOUGHT
WORKED WELL I'LL TELL YOU WHAT
WHAT WORKED WELL THEY DIRECT
ALLOCATION OF MONIES TO CITIES
THE SEQUEL EXEMPTIONFOR SITE
ACQUISITION- THE ABBREVIATED
TIME FRAME BECAUSE WE COULDN'T
JUST DILLY DALLY AROUND TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS. WHAT
WAS GOING TO WORK WE HAD TO GET
THOSE STUDENTS HOUSE RIGHT
AWAY- WHAT ALSO HELPED A LOT
WAS THAT THE AVERAGE COST TO
PROVIDE THIS HOUSING IS A
FRACTION. OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
OTHER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS WHAT IS NOT WORKING AS
WELL AS WITH REGARD TO PROJECT
ROOM K<c.cyan>. FUNDING BEING- KIND</c>
OF TARGETED TO THE COUNTY AND
YET IN OUR COUNTY ONLY 21% OF
OUR RESIDENTS LIVE IN THE
COUNTY THE REST RESIDE IN
CITIES AND ALL OF THOSE HOTELS
ARE LOCATED IN THE CITIES AND
THEN THERE'S NOT. GOOD
COORDINATION WITH WRAPAROUND
SERVICES- COMING OUT OF COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SO IF THERE
IS ONE THING THAT I WOULD
CHANGE- WITH REGARD TO PROJECT
BRING KEY IS THAT THERE BE
GREATER COLLABORATION AND
INCLUDE THE CITY'S BEST PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION. AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR GREAT
WORK AND YOUR LEADERSHIP.
SENATE PRESIDENT PRESIDENT OF
THE LEAGUE CITY SAID CHERYL
VIEGAS WALKER SHE'S AWESOME
MAYOR AND CITY OF EL CENTRO.
ALWAYS SPOT ON IN HER TESTIMONY
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. A OPENING
OF QUESTIONS IN CONVERSATION IN
JUST A BIT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE COMMITTEES
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ASK
YOUR INDULGENCE THAT WE HAVE AN
AMAZING SPEAKER WHO HAS A HARD
OUT. AT ELEVEN AM IN WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS HAVE-
HUNDRED GOMEZ TESTIFIED THE
CASE TO THE COMMITTEE SHE'S
YOUTH ADVOCATE- BUT BEFORE WE
GET TO I MISS GOMEZ HAD LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER. TO SENATOR WIENER
TO BE ABLE TO GIVE SOME CONTEXT
ON OUR THIRD PANEL. WHICH WE'RE
GONNA HAVE THIS GOMEZ SPEAK
HERE IN OUR SECOND PANEL JUST
BECAUSE OF THE HARD OUT BUT A
CENTER WIENER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS TO BE A TO GIVE YOU SOME
CONTEXT AND. TURN IT OVER TO
MISS GOMES. THANK YOU- AND I SO
I GUESS WE'LL BE DOING TITLE.
HELLO BIT US AND- WALKING
SCHOOL AS- WE- WE'RE PLANNING A
HEARING DECIDE TO HAVE- PANEL
THIS. TO THE NEEDS OF
TRANSITION AS YOU. KIDS WHO ARE
IN A HIGH SCHOOL AGE COLLEGE
AGE COAST COLLEGE AGE- WHO ARE
AT SEVERE RISK OF. HOMELESSNESS
KIDS TO. PALMER EXITING THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM KIDS WERE
COMING OUT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM KIDS WHO. ARE
SIMPLY- DON'T HAVE STABLE
HOUSING AT HOME- AND OUR- OWN
AND ARE HOMELESS ACCUSES YOUNG
AS. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD. I AND IT'S- IT'S A
CREDIT- TRIED- AND WE KNOW THAT
IF WE CAN. GET TO THESE KIDS
QUICKLY CUT THEM STABILIZE GET
THEM IN THE HOUSE AND GET THEM
ON TRACK- THEY'RE GONNA YOU
KNOW BE ABLE TO HAVE GREAT
LIVES BUT IF WE- DON'T
INTERVENE AND DON'T HELP THEM
AND DON'T PROVIDING THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED- WE COULD BE. ARE
HELPING CREATE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CHRONIC LONG TERM
HOMELESSNESS THE LAST THING
THAT WE NEED- AND SO AS I
MENTIONED THE BEGINNING. MOST
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE
YOU SPECIFIC HOMELESS PROGRAMS.
HI WHEN YOU CERTAIN GROUPS
YOUTH INTO THE ADULT HOMELESS
SYSTEM- THAT JUST DOES NOT GET
ON THE SUPPORT. BY THE DATE
THAT THEY NEED- IN ADDITION THE
STATE UNTIL ABOUT FIVE YEARS
AGO WAS INVESTING ALMOST
NOTHING. AND YOU SPECIFIC
HOMELESS NEEDS ARE WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO INCREASE OUT OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS BUT IT IS NOT
NEARLY WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE- I
WILL MENTION THAT- WITH SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY FOUR THIS YEAR
WE'RE TRYING TO GET. A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
STATE. I IN THE HOUSING FOR
YOUTH EXITING HOMELESSNESS
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM- AND WE REALLY
REALLY NEED TO GET ON TOP OF
THIS AND HELP THESE KIDS. NOT
TO SURVIVE BUT THRIVE AND I
KNOW THAT WE CAN DO THAT- SO I
WILL NOT HEAR FROM- GOMEZ AND-
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
EMIGRATE FROM THE CHAIR FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP IN FOR PLANNING.
THE POOL AT THE PANEL ON ISSUES
FACING TRANSITIONAL YOUTH ALL
RIGHT MISS GOMEZ GOOD MORNING
WE WELCOME YOU- THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES TO
GET A ONE MINUTE IN A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPTED YOU GET CLOSE.
TO THAT FIVE MINUTES GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
THE MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE AND
YOU ALL THIS OPPORTUNITY BE
HERE TO WITH YOU. I AM A
LAUNDROMAT AND I'M ONE YEARS
OLD I'M- LIVING IN CINEMA
COUNTY I'VE EXPERIENCED
HOMELESSNESS AND BETTER FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. AND I NOW WANT TO
ANY. TO RECYCLE. NOT ONLY FOR
MYSELF BUT FOR MY COMMUNITY
PEERS LOCAL STATEWIDE AND
BEYOND. I GREW UP IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM SINCE AGES SIX AND
IT'S FROM MATIC EXPERIENCE I
NEVER HAD SUPPORT COMING OUT OF
THE FOSTER CARE SYTEM WHAT THE
PARENTS WOULD ADOPTED ME. WAS
TO RECEIVING MONEY FROM MY
ADOPTION AND I WAS TOLD I
WASN'T ELIGIBLE FOR ANY.
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
WE MUST DO BETTER ACCESS.
EXITING BOX. KIDS I. REALIZING
THAT THEY THAT THEY NEEDS
ESPECIALLY AT THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE THAT I NEVER GOT I AM NOW
TWENTY ONE AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING TOWARDS MY GOALS WELL I
WASN'T ELIGIBLE FOR ANY
EXTENDED FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAMS
I WAS ABLE TO GET HELP YOU CAN
DO SUPPORT NETWORK OF WHICH IS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH. ONCE CALL
BUT HEY I LOST MY JOB AND I WAS
WORRIED THAT I WASN'T ABLE TO
GET ANY SUPPORT SAYS AS A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH WE DO NOT
HAVE. THE ABILITY TO HAVE
PARENTSTO GUIDE US THROUGH
THINGS AND- THAT WAS A BIG PART
OF THE STRUGGLE THAT I FACED. I
ALSO HAVE FRIENDS AND FAMILY
WHO EXPERIENCESSAME
HOMELESSNESS A YOUNG AGE AND
STRUGGLE TREMENDOUSLY THIS IS
WHY I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT DOING
THIS WORK. MY PRIMARY GOAL IN
LIFE IS TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM TO
SUPPORT YOU WITH PREDOMINANTLY
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF-COLOR. AND THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY FOR OVER PRESENTED
AND ARE HOMELESS POPULATION
BECAUSE WE'VE MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES TO SIR AND MEET
THEIR NEEDS. AND THE PAST.
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE THE FIRST ONES TO BE
HERE. THE LAST ONES TO BE
SUPPORTED BY THE FIRST ONES TO
BE REJECTED. ONE IF THEY DO
ANYTHING. AND THAT IS WHY I WAS
SO INTERESTED AND COMMITTED
INTO JOINING WANT OTHER DAY.
AND ALLOW ME TO. THE CINEMA
SYSTEM. TO ENSURE THAT SO TAKES.
I HAD WHEN I WAS YOUNGER AND
THE LACK OF HELP I EXPERIENCED.
ONCE I WAS OUT OF THE SYSTEM
DON'T HAPPEN TO MY PEERS. AND
THE LACK. AND THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT WE- HAVE TO FACE I'M SORRY
I'M READING THIS BUT IF I'M
GONNA BE HONEST. TO SAY THAT-
THE ONE WHO DO YOU HELPS ME A
LOT TO REALIZE THAT THERE IS A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
FACE AND- SOME OF THOSE ISSUES.
ARE THE RULES REGARDING- LAKE
COUNTY SHOPPING AND REGARDING
WHEN IT COMES TO FUNDING. AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN HELP THOSE
SOCIETIES FUNDING THESE
PROGRAMS FOR THESE YOUTH
ESPECIALLY ONES THAT WERE
ADOPTED AT SIXTEEN. OR THAT
WERE ADOPTED ONCE THEY WERE IN
THE SYSTEM- THE SYSTEM WAS JUST
IN A PLACE THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO
HELP ME. AND A FEELING ME. AND
I THINK OUR GREATEST SOLUTION
TO ENDING HOMELESSNESS IS
STARTING BY PREVENTING IT. IF
YOU WANT TO HELP OLDER PEOPLE
WHEN THEY'RE HOMELESS YOU NEED
TO HELP THE YOUNG ADULTS
BECAUSE WE ARE THE FUTURE WE
ARE THE. NEXT GENERATION. AND I
AM THE FUTURE THAT'S THIS A-
THANK YOU BUT IT'S ALRIGHT.
WITH GO MAYES. WE ARE SO
APPRECIATIVE YOU TAKE THE TIME
TO BE A TO BE WITH US TO NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO TO BE TO SHARE
YOUR STORY. IN THREE TO BE ABLE
TO SHARE THAT STORY. IN HOW
YOU'RE TRYING TO CHANGE LIVES
HERE IN THE YEARS TO COME IT
MEANS A LOT TO US. BY THAT
YOU'D BE THIS ADVOCATE HI N. B.
SO ELOQUENT TODAY SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISS GOMEZ. WE SO
APPRECIATE. YOUR TESTIMONY IT
MEANS A LOT TO US. I EVEN DID A
GREAT. R. I. LAYS IN GERMAN AT
THAT'S MISCO WHO- IS CAN TO BE
HAVING TO LEAVE US SHORTLY WHAT
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO DO
IS RETURN TOWARD LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PANEL SO WHAT WE TRY
TO DO FOR THIS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PANELISTS HERE FROM RURAL
COMMUNITIES HERE FOR RURAL
COUNTIES HERE FROM URBAN
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS- URBAN.
CONTI'S AS WELL IN SPEAKING OF
THAT WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT HEIDI
MARTIN IS WITH US HE IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY. A JPA. MISS MARTIN
HAS VERY SMALL JOB- IT HERE
AND- SHE IS THE COORDINATOR OF
THE GPA BETWEEN THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY HE'S GOING TO BE
TALKING TO US ABOUT THE
SUCCESSES. THE CHALLENGES IN
WHAT SHE WOULD LIKE TO BE A SEA
CHANGE AS WE MOVE FORWARD WHEN
IT COMES TO PROJECT ROOM KEY
AND HOME KEY. ALL RIGHT MISS
MARTIN THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
LOS ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY FLOOR IS YOURS YOU
HAVE FIVE MINUTES YOU'LL GET A
ONE MINUTE AND THIRTY SECONDS
FROM THE MORNING. GOOD MORNING
FACE SO MUCH OF REALLY FOR. YOU
ALL HAVING HERE- AGAIN MY NAME
IS MARCIN I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY. WE
ARE THE LEAD AGENCY FOR THE LOS
ANGELES CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
WE'RE ALSO JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY BETWEEN THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. AS
YOU ALL KNOW WELL HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ALL MORNING OUR
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS ACROSS ALL
OF CALIFORNIA. BEFORE PROBATED
THERE WERE A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. AND
OVER SIXTY SIX THOUSAND OF
THOSE WERE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ALONE. WE ALL KNOW THAT
KOBE IS VERY LIKELY TO MAKE
THIS CRISIS WORK. I TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
THEIR LIVES TURNED UPSIDE DOWN
BY FINANCIAL. DIFFICULTY
ILLNESS OR DEATH. MEANWHILE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVING
RESOURCES TO RESPOND TO THE
CRISIS HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE IN
LA WHERE WE RELY ON MEASURE H.
SALES TAX REVENUE TO THE STATE
ARE HOMELESS WITH THEM. WE HAVE
A PROJECTED SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLAR SHORTFALL I DO TO THE
PANDEMIC AND SPENDING BEING
DOWN. DESPITE THOSE CHALLENGES
THROUGH COLLABORATION WITH OUR
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS WE LEVERAGE
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO RESPOND OKAY
NINETEEN. IN LESS THAN SIX
MONTHS WE'VE BROUGHT OVER EIGHT
THOUSAND OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
NEIGHBORS INSIDE THROUGH
PROJECT ROOM HE AND OTHER JOINT
EFFORT. BUT WE KNOW THAT OUR
WORK DOESN'T STOP THERE AND SO
NOW OUR FOCUS IS TO PERMANENTLY
HOUSE THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
SHELTERED COVE IN NINETEEN AND
THOUSANDS MORE USING OUR
RECOVERY ROADMAP THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED ITH OUR CITY AND OUR
COUNTY PARTNERS. WHAT WE ALL
AGREE ON IS THAT WE CANNOT GO
BACK TO STATUS QUO POST CODE
AND WE NEED TO TAKE THE
MOMENTUM REBUILT. AND CONTINUED
BUILD AN EXPLORATION MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE WE HAVING. OF MANY
BROKE OFF BALL. IN L. A. COUNTY
ARE CONTINUUM OF CARE HAS BILL
IN EFFECT RATE. WHICH OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS A LOT THE
HOUSE SIX ONE. NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT PEOPLE WHICH IS
NEARLY THE SAME NUMBER OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS DURING THE LAST
COUNT WAS ABOUT ABOUT SIXTY SIX
THOUSAND. WE'VE DONE THAT BY
IMPROVING COURTNEY HERE IN OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS. BUT
DESPITE ALL OF THIS LAST YEAR
ALONE TWO HUNDRED FIVE PEOPLE
EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR HOUSE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUT TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE FELL
INTO HOMELESSNESS EACH DAY. TO
TRULY ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS WE
NEED AN EQUALLY POWERFUL
HOMELESS PREVENTION MACHINE
THAT KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES
AND I'M MATH OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUPPLY MACHINE THAT
CREATES YOUR NECK ON THE BACK
AND- THAT WE HAVE THE STOCK
WILL BE IN FLOW AND- HALF OF.
THAT WOULD WORK. OKAY BUT STILL.
WE ALSO WANTED TO DO THINK THIS
FOR THE- IN HEAT. SINCE RISK HE
FUNDING AT THE BEGINNING OF
TWENTY. AND L. A. SERVED OVER
SEVEN FIVE PEOPLE ACROSS OUR
CONTINUE ON. WE USE OUR KEEP
DOLLARS TO STAND UP PROBLEM
SOLVING FUNDS THAT GIVES
FLEXIBLE INFUSIONS OF CASH TO
PEOPLE TO QUICKLY RESOLVE
PROBLEMS THAT COULD LEAD TO
OFFER A LONG MOMENT. HELLO
THAT'S LIKE. PAYING BACK RENT.
HI THAT CAR REPAIR. WE ALSO
CHEAP TO ME CORE PARTS OF OUR
SYSTEM LIKE. YOU SHELTER BAD
SOLD PLACE THE FAN AND- HOW.
ARE HOW. WITH YOUR RECEIVED IN
THE SPRING TWENTY TWO HAS ALL.
SERVED THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
SIMILAR INTERVENTIONS. BUT WE
NEED THE STATE TO PROVIDE
ONGOINGFUNDING WHAT WE CAN'T
DO IS CONTINUE TO HAVE THE SAME
BUDGET FIGHT EACH YEAR AND
EXPECT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
STAND OUT NEW PROGRAMS WITH NEW
REQUIREMENTS. THAN EXPECTED
DATEABLE LASTING REDUCTIONS IN
HOMELESSNESS. WE ALSO NEED TO
BRING CONTINUES OF CARE TO THE
TABLE TO HELP INFORM OUR
REGIONAL POLICIES STRATEGY THAT
GOES ACROSS DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS. UC'S ARE
CRITICAL IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
THROUGH A REGIONAL APPROACH
PARTICULARLY IN LANDSCAPES LIKE
LA THAT HAVE A HOST OF
OVERLAPPING JURISDICTION.
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SHOULDN'T BE
SERVER BASED ON WHAT SIDE OF
THE STREET THEY'RE ON AND THE
C. O. C. CAN HELP COORDINATE
WITH THE COUNTIES AND THE CITY
IS TO LEVERAGE CRITICAL HEALTH
CARE AND SAFETY NET RESOURCES-
ALONG WITH THE CITIES THAT
REGULATE LAND USE AND BRING ALL
THIS TOGETHER FOR A HOLISTIC
APPROACH. ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDING FUNDING TO BUILD OUT
AND ENSURE LONG TERM SUCCESS OF
PROJECT HOME HE IS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS.
PROJECT FROM KEY REPRESENTS AN
IMPORTANT LEAP FORWARD- WE
COMMEND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
FIRST YEAR HEADING THAT EFFORT.
BUT WE NEED TO CREATE ONGOING
FUNDING TO SECURE LONG TERM
SICK BACK ONE MINUTE. WE ALSO
NEED TO KNOW THAT HOME HE ISN'T
THE RIGHT SOLUTION FOR ALL OF
OUR POPULATIONS ALMOST YOU FOR
EXAMPLE ARE NOT THE MAIN TARGET
POPULATION FOR THE INTERVENTION
AND THERE'S CONTINUE NEED FOR
TAYLOR FUNDING AND SERVICES TO
ADDRESS OUR STATE YEAR. THE
STATE SHOULD ALSO PUT FORWARD
ARCHING VISION A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
FEET WIDE A REPORT FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR EARLIER THIS
MONTH SHARED THAT WHILE THE
STATE HAS MADE CONSIDERABLE.
CONSIDERABLE INVESTMENTS IN
HOMELESSNESS. THERE HAS BEEN
OVER ARCHING STE. OR VISION
GUIDE THE INVESTMENT. I BILLS
LIKE AB SEVENTY ONE IT WOULD
PROVIDE FUNDING THAT WE NEED TO
HELP SCALE UP INTERVENTIONS
THAT WE KNOW WORK IT WOULD ALSO
INCREASE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
COUNTIES AND YES. LIKE WE'VE
BEEN LIKE I'VE BEEN SAYING
NEEDS TO HAPPEN ACROSS THE
BOARD AT THE END OF THE DAY IF
WE WANT TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT CITIES
COUNTIES AND COCS ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO IMPLEMENT A
REGIONAL COMPREHENSIVE PLAN
THAT ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF THE
ENTIRE. THE ROAD GUIDING VISION
THAT WE TO STAY TO BRING WITH
WHILE. ONE IS GROUNDED IN AB
BASED. WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
COUNT ABILITY AND MEASURABLE
GOALS AND COLLABORATION FOR
THIS. ACCIDENT THIRTY THAT WE-
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TIED AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO PARTNERING
WITH ALL OF YOU AND THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE. THIS MARCIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH- FOR- HANGING WITH
THIS FOR YOUR- TODAY. KNOW THAT
IT'S BEEN A LONG HEARING AND
WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. I KNOW THAT MISS
MARCIN IS GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
MEETING HERE COMING UP AROUND
ELEVEN ELEVEN FIFTEEN SO WE'RE
GONNA. TRY TO GET THAT
QUESTIONS TO HAITI FIRST IN
JUST A BIT BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT WE'RE SPANNING THE STATE
WE'RE GOING FROM- THE- EAT THE
U. S. MEXICO BORDER. NOW UP TO
THE CALIFORNIA- OREGON BORDER
JUST SOUTH OF THAT AND WE'RE
GONNA TURN THIS OVER TO CONNIE
BACK COUNTY BACK IS THE
DIRECTOR. OF THE HUMBLE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SHE'S GOING TO GIVE US
A RURAL COUNTY PERSPECTIVE WE
JUST HEARD FROM IN IRVINE
COUNTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR
FROM DIRECTOR BACK. FROM
HUMBLE- ON HOW. PROJECT ROOM
KEY IN HOME KEYS ROLLED OUT THE
SUCCESSES AND CHALLENGES.
DIRECTOR BECKY GOOD MORNING TO
YOU IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU
ATTHE FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES. TO GET A ONE
MINUTE AND THIRTY SECOND PROMPT.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU. I AM
CALLING BACK HEALTHY. SERVICES
DIRECTOR FOR HUMBOLDT. WHEN IT
COMES TO HOMELESSNESS WE ARE NO
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OF THE BIG
CITIES. WHEN YOU DRIVE DOWN
HIGHWAY ONE A ONE. DAY YOU WILL
SEE MANY OORWAYS OF OUR
STOREFRONTS OCCUPIED BY PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TITLE
THAT. TRYING TO SLEEP AND STAY
WARM. SOME OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
WHEELCHAIRS AND MANY MORE HAVE
NO ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. CONGREGATE SHELTERS
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO REDUCE
CAPACITY AND PEOPLE ONCE AGAIN
STARTED RETREATING INTO THE
WOODS AND GRAIN BELT. WITH SO
MANY LOSING SHELTER PROJECTS
ROOM CAN HOME HE HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN KEEPING PEOPLE
SAFE DURING THE PANDEMIC. WHEN
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY ACTED FAST TO IMPLEMENT
THREE ROOM CHEMO CAL MOTELS
ACROSS OUR GEOGRAPHICALLY VAST
COUNTY. OUTRAGE WAS SWIFT AS WE
EXPERIENCED OUTRAGE
PROFESSIONALS AND NO SHORTAGE
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WITH SEVERE
PHYSICAL RISK OF CODING. OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGE WITH RICKY
HAS BEEN STOPPING. BUT HOW WILL
MANY COUNTY SAID EXPERIENCED
ACUTE STAFFING CHALLENGES
DURING THE PANDEMIC WITH
WORKERS HAVING TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN AT HOME. OTHERS BEING
HIGH RISK THEMSELVES AND STILL
OTHERS BEING DEPLOYED ELSEWHERE
TO ASSIST WITH COUNTY EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS. NONETHELESS RING
HERE TO SERVE MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND HUMBOLDT
COUNTY REPRESENTING MORE THAN
NINETEEN THOUSAND THAT NIGHT.
THE INTENT WAS TO GET PEOPLE
OFF THE STREET AND INTO NON
CONGREGATE SHELTER QUICKLY
WHICH WE DID. NOW COMES THE
HARD PART RE HOUSING. IN RURAL
HUMBOLDT COUNTY THE RENTAL
MARKET HAS TIGHTENED
SIGNIFICANTLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WITH YOUR AVAILABLE
UNITS AND RENTS INCREASING
DRAMATICALLY AS REMOTE WORKERS
FROM OTHER PLACES HAVE CHOSE TO
MOVE HERE. WITH LIMITED
STAFFING YOU HAVE RENTALS
AVAILABLE DWINDLING ROOM HE
FINDS AN ONGOING PANDEMIC. WE
ARE FEELING THE PRESSURE OF THE
SITUATION. THE MOST HELPFUL
THING FOR COUNTIES IS FLEXIBLE
FUNDING THAT COULD BE USED
ACROSS HUMAN SERVICES AND
HOUSING PROGRAMS THREE
ENTITIES APPLIED FOR HOW HOME
KEY AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY TO OUR
SUCCESSFUL AND THIS WILL RESULT
IN SIXTY NEW UNITS. FOR THE
FIRST PROJECT THE COUNTY
PARTNERED WITH A LOCAL HOSPITAL
SYSTEM THAT PURCHASED A RAM
CANNOT TELL THE RESULT WILL BE
FORTY TWO NEW PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING UNITS AND
SIX OUTPATIENT RECUPERATIVE
CARE SO THAT. FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. OKAY
FUNDS WERE COMBINED WITH
HOUSING FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA HHA HE AND CDBG
FUNDING TO MAKE THE PROJECT
CANCEL OUT. IMPORTANTLY THE
HOSPITAL AGREED TO PROVIDE ALL
THE SUPPORT AND SERVICES FOR
FUTURE TENANTS WHICH THE COUNTY
COULD NOT HAVE AGREED TO THAT
COLLABORATION WITHOUT SINCE WE
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE ON GOING
FUNDING. OR CAPACITY TO STOP
ANOTHER PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROJECT. IN FACT WE DID
NOT APPLY FOR THE LATEST ROUND
AND NO PLACE LIKE HOME HOME
FUNDING FOR THAT SAME REASON.
THE SECOND SUCCESSFUL HUNKY
APPLICATION WAS SUBMITTED BY
THE YUROK TRIBE WHICH IS
PARTNERED WITH A LOCAL
NONPROFIT SERVICE PROVIDER TO
PURCHASE A METALLIC EIGHTEEN
BASS. SIGNIFICANTLY BOTH OF
THESE HUNKY PROJECTS AND LEAD
TO ADDITIONAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE HOSPITAL AND THE TRIBE THAT
DID NOT EXIST BEFORE
STRENGTHENING THE LOCAL
CONTINUUM OF CARE. I MUST NOTE
THAT MANY SMALL COUNTIES WERE
NOT ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
ROOM HERE HUNKY OFTEN BECAUSE
OF LACK OF CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
THE SUPPORT SERVICES. WHAT ARE
THE INSURANCE AND LIABILITY
CARRIERS. HOWEVER IMPOSSIBLE IF
MORE HUNKY FUNDING IS MADE
AVAILABLE OUR CITIES IN LOCAL
NONPROFIT STAND READY TO APPLY
ONE MINUTE. LASTLY HUMBLE IS
THE SMALLEST COUNTY THAT
MAINTAINS A SIXTEEN BED
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITY IN
CRISIS STABILIZATION UNITS. AS
EMERGENCY ROOMS ACROSS THE
STATE STRUGGLE WITH CAPACITY
DURING BECAUSE OF IT THEY ARE
ALSO STRUGGLING TO ADMIT
PATIENTS TO PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITIES. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENT IN BOARDING
CARE UNITS IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HOUSING IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. SO IS THE STATE'S
EFFORT TOWARDS AN IMD WAIVER
WAIVER WE MUST EXPAND THE
PLACEMENT AND CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS ACROSS THE
STATE. ENGAGING PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS HASN'T BEEN THE
PROBLEM FINDING THE APPROPRIATE
THAT TASK. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND TO BE A PART OF THIS
VERY IMPORTANT CONVERSATION.
MAN OF DIRECTOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS BACK IN ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE WANTED TO HAVE
HUMBLED ON NOT ONLY ARE THE
RULE BUT BASED OFF OF THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNT. HUMBOLDT COUNTY HAS THE
HIGHEST POPULATION OF
HOMELESSNESS PER CAPITA. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PER CAPITA
IN ITS THE THIRD HIGHEST PER
CAPITA IN THE NATION- AND
UNDERSTANDING THE CHALLENGES
THAT RURAL CALIFORNIA FACES.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING TO
ANOTHER PART OF THE STATE IN
THAT'S IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE
THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR
TURNING POINT THAT WITH US
TODAY HER NAME IS JODY CATCH
INSIDE AND JODY IS GOING TO BE
TALKING TO US ABOUT HER
PERSPECTIVE. FROM THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA REGION ON A PROJECT
ROOM KEY AND HOME KEY THAT
MADAM EVERY JUDGE RECTOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S JERRY CATCHES
SIGHT ON THE REGIONAL DIRECTOR
FOR TURNING POINT OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA I SERVE AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE FRESNO MADERA
CONTINUUM OF CARE I ALSO SERVE
AS A CSU REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
STATE'S ALMOST COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL ADDITIONALLY
I AM THE BOARD CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE KINGS
TULARE CONTINUUM OF CARE. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY BEFORE
CO LEAD OUR REGION HAD THE
HIGHEST UNSHELTERED RATE AND
THE CAT IN THE COUNTRY WITH
OTHER LARGELY- BANK IN THE
EIGHT LARGELY URBAN COCS
CATEGORY. EMICH STARTED MY STAY
HAS BEEN ON TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF HOMELESS CALIFORNIANS
AND THAT HAS BEEN A JOB. WITH
PROJECT ROOM Q. FUNDS LARRY
COUNTY. WAS ABLE TO SHELTER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
PEOPLE AND THREE MOUNT CHARLES.
AND THE CITIES OF TULARE
PORTABLE AND BY CELAYA. DURING
THE PANDEMIC AT KINGS TULARE
CONTINUUM OF CARE PARTICIPATED
IN. SIX OF HAD SATURDAY TO
ADDRESS YOUTH ALMOST. CHALLENGE
TOOK PLACE FROM JUNE TWENTIETH
TO OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY- ROOMS
THAT WERE UNUSED IN THE ROOM
CAME ON TOP OR UTILIZED FOR
THIS EFFORT BUT DURING THIS
TIME WE WERE ABLE TO HOUSE
FORTY YOUTH AND LAY THE
GROUNDWORK FOR YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARD. THAT WILL LAUNCH IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HAVE USED
OUR YOUTH FUNDING TO SET ASIDE
BEDS AND NAVIGATION CENTERS.
BRIDGE HOUSING AND PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECT
PROJECTS YES OUR CATIONS WERE
VERY SMALL AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES TO PUT THIS IN SOME
CONTEXT OREO- THAT PORTER VILLE.
OUR FOR THE 5% YEARS YOU'RE
SATISFIED WITH HE WAS ONLY
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO WHILE THAT THOSE FUNDS WERE
NOT NECESSARILY INTENDED TO DO
SATISFIED BEDS THAT'S REALLY
ALL THAT COULD BE DONE. WITH
THE FUNDING WAS SUCH A SMALL
ALLOCATION. REFER HOME CAME.
AND KINGS COUNTY TO MOTELS WERE
PURCHASED WITH HOME HE FINDS
ONE BY THE LOCAL HOUSING
AUTHORITY AND ONE BY A
PROVIDER. IS ABOUT CHARLES- ARE
OPERATING UNDER INTERIM HOUSING
CURRENTLY. BUT THEY WILL BE
CONVERTED INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING WITHIN THE EIGHT YEAR
ALLOTTED PERIOD. THE DIFFICULTY
AND TULARE COUNTY AS THAT
THOUGH THE AWARDS FOR HOME HE
ONLY COVER THE ACQUISITION AND
SO THEY ARE CURRENTLY SEEKING
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO FINISH THE
REHAB SINCE THEN I'M HERE WORD
WON'T COVER THAT. SETTING ASIDE
CAPITAL DEVELOPMENT FUNDS FOR
YOUTH ONLY PROGRAMS WOULD BE A
SUGGESTION MIGHT MAKE SUCH AS
WHAT SENATOR WIENER'S PROPOSING
THROUGH. HIS S. B. TWO THIRTY
FOR CHALLENGING FOR YOUTH
PROGRAMS TO COMPETE FOR THE
CAPITAL DOLLARS LOCALLY-
VARIOUS APPS AND SOMETIMES
POLITICAL REASONS. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE USING KEEP CASH IN CITY
GENERAL FUNDS WE CREATED A
PROGRAM IN THE SMALL OWN OF
PORTERVILLE WHERE THERE WERE
PREVIOUSLY NO SERVICES FOR
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. ESTABLISH
A NAVIGATION CENTER WHEREAS. AB
TODAY WE HAVE SERVED EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
UNDUPLICATED INDIVIDUALS WITH
DAYTIME SERVICES SUCH AS BILLS
IN CASE MANAGEMENT OPTS
SHELTERED OVER THIRTY ONE
INDIVIDUALS. AND SEE AN AVERAGE
OF EIGHTY PEOPLE COME THROUGH
THE DOORS DALY OUR PERSPECTIVE
PORTABLES TWENTY TWENTY POINT
IN TIME COUNT NUMBERS WERE JUST
OVER TWO HUNDRED UNSHELTERED
PEOPLE. PROBABLY KNOW THE PIT
COUNTS ARE NOT A PERFECT
MEASURE OF HOMELESSNESS IMPOSE
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES ESPECIALLY
WITH COUNTING HERE THEY DO
PROVIDE A WAY FOR COCS TO
MEASURE PROGRESS BORDER
CROSSING SHELTERED AND
UNSHELTERED HOMELESSNESS ONE IN.
IN FRESNO COUNTY JUST ALLOW
WEEK WHERE HAVE OPENED. THREE
NEW SHELTERS UNDER PROJECT TOM
HE FUNDS THAT WILL BE
CONVERTED. AT A LATER DATE TO
PERMANENT HOUSING AND WITHIN
THE FIRST FEW DAYS OF OPENING
THERE WERE ALREADY SHELTERING
OVER FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE NINETY
OF THOSE BEING. CHILDREN SO AS
YOU CAN SEE THE ALLOCATION
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN RURAL AND
URBAN. AREAS CAN BE A-
CHALLENGE FOR GETTING THINGS UP
AND GOING AND BEING ABLE TO USE
THE FUNDS. AND SHELTER PEOPLE
QUICKLY. TECHNICALLY THEY ARE
RARE THEY ARE AYE RURAL AREAS
ARE NOT ENTITLEMENT AREAS WHICH
MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
IT GET THE FUNDS THAT THEY NEED
TO ACTUALLY CONTINUE PROGRAMS
AND NOT HAVE TO SHOT THEM.
YOU'RE AFTER YOU'RE AS THEY
WAIT FOR CONTRA. THANK YOU.
GREAT JOB THANK YOU MISTER
CATCH SIGHT WORDS SO WE SO
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US AT
LEAST IN JENIN IN THE
COMMITTEES WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE A TO OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR OUR LOCAL
PANELISTS WE'RE GOING TO ASK
ALL OF THE PANELISTS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO PLEASE TURN ON
YOUR SCREENS AND WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH THE QUESTIONS WITH
SENATOR DORADO THEY WERE GONNA
GO TO CENTER NIELSEN SENATOR
PAN THANK YOU SO MUCH I CENTER
DRAWS ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I JUST
ONE ASPECT OF THE SIMILAR
QUESTION I ASKED EARLIER WITH
THE OTHER PANEL WITH REGARDS.
TO YOUR EXPERIENCE ON. WELL THE
SERVER. BE PROVIDED. THROUGH
PROJECT ROOM KEY AND OR HOME
KEY. AND THAT IS- YOUR
EXPERIENCE WITH JOB TRAINING
AND EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES-
IS THAT OF. IS THAT AVAILABLE
DOES IT WORK ON WHAT MORE WOULD
YOU NEED TO MAKE THAT WORK
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE TRYING TO MOVE-
OUR SISTERS AND BROTHERS-
TOWARDS THAT A MORE STABLE LIFE
AND THAT SEEMS TO ME A VERY.
CRUCIAL PART OF THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER DRIVE
SO LET'S START WITH MISS MARTIN
FROM REPRESENTING AT THE CITY
COUNTY OF LA THE GPA THERE THIS
MARKS IN A IF YOU CAN PLEASE
DISCUSS EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THOSE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ON THOSE
UNITS FOR PROJECT COME KEY ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR RAZA. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SO EMPLOYMENT IS
CERTAINLY A FOCUS ON THAT- OF
THE WORK THEIR PROVIDERS DO AT
THOSE SITES MAKING SURE THAT
FOLKS ARE SUSCEPTIBLE INCOME WE
KNOW. GETTING PEOPLE HOUSES
JUST STEP ONE AND THAT IS
KEEPING THEM HOW'S THAT REALLY
COMES IMPORTANT I DO WANT TO
SAY ONE THING THAT WE HAVE DONE
IN LOS ANGELES IN PROJECT. HE
THAT HATH AN INCREDIBLE EFFORT
THAT WE PLAN TO CONTINUE ITS
WORKPLACE SAYING WHAT WE CALL
DOCUMENT SPECIALIST EVERY
SINGLE SITE. WE QUICKLY LEARNED
IS THAT- HOW MANY PEOPLE IN
THIS SITE IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WHEN
THEY'RE ALL KIND OF INSIGHTFUL
ISOLATING AFTER HAVING
DOCUMENTS SPECIALISTS THERE WHO
CAN HELP NAVIGATE EATING FOLKS
AIDID'S GETTING OURSELVES
SECURITY PART EVERYTHING THAT
GETS IN THE WAY OF PEOPLE
BECOMING RE HOUSE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ALL THE PAPERWORK
NEEDED. OUR DOCUMENTS
SPECIALISTS ARE WORKING ON SITE
AND TO WORK WITH EACH PERSON TO
GET THEIR FULL PACKET READY AND
WE SEEM HAVE TREMENDOUS IMPACT
ON HOW QUICKLY WE CAN MOVE
PEOPLE INTO HOUSING. AND THEN
YOU DON'T WRAP AROUND THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES LIKE
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT TO MAKING
SURE THAT THAT. IN THERE. THE
YOU SO MUCH MISS MARCH IN- WE
LIKE TO BE ABLE QUICKLY WE'RE
GOING TO- IT NOW- MISS BACK
RESPECT WE'RE TO ASK FOR A-
SICK. SIX ANSWER. TO SENATOR
ALSO- I KNOW YOU'RE GETTING ON
YOUR PROJECTS BUT- J. TRAINING
AND SERVICE THAT WILL OFFERED
FOR EACH UNIT IN. RESPECT YEAH
SO I LIKE TO SAY THAT A LOT OF
THE FOLKS THAT WERE. I'M
WORKING WITH CURRENTLY HAVE.
MANY MORE BARRIERS AND I THINK
EMPLOYMENT WILL BE ONE OF
THOSE. LAST THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO WORK AROUND AND A LOT OF OUR
FOLKS HAVE SAID SINCE USE.
DISORDER AND MENTAL ILLNESS I'M
GETTING THEM STABILIZED INTO
HOUSING I THINK HOUSING FIRST
IS REALLY AND- WE HAVE TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT THAT AT THIS
POINT WE DO HAVE SOME
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING. AND WHEN
FOLKS ARE READY FOR THAT AND-
WHAT WE BEEN DISCUSSING
CURRENTLY IS JUST ENGAGING IN
MORE OF OUR BUSINESSES BECAUSE
SOME OF THESE FOLKS WON'T BE
ABLE TO JUST GO TO WORK FULL
TIME AND BE. SUSTAINABLE SOME
OF THEM WILL NEED YOU KNOW
MAYBE A FEW HOURS A DAY AND
THEN AND IT'S NOT ENOUGH AND
SUFFICIENT ON TO GET THEM I'M
STABILIZED ON THE RIGHT TRACK A
LOT OF THESE FOLKS. HAVE AND
MEDICAL CONDITIONS LONGTIME
MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN DEALT WITH. FOR YEARS AND
THEY'LL BE DEALING WITH THOSE
TO YOURSELF AND THERE'S A LOT
OF ISSUES WITH THOSE BUGS. THAT
HAD BEEN ON THE STREET FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME THERE AND
PRETTY DIFFICULT TO ENGAGE. AND
I AM. AND YEAH ALL THE SERVICES
SUPPORTS THAT THEY NEED THANK
YOU SO MISS MAC I DISAGREE
QUICKLY SO YOU'RE GOING TO BE
OFFERING THOSE SERVICES ON SITE.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESPECT WE'RE NOW GOING TO ASK
FOR SIXTY SECONDS FROM ITS
COUNTRYSIDE. BY TAKING A CENTER
CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL VALLEY
APPROACH- IF YOU CAN PLEASE
GIVE US A SIXTY SECOND ANSWER
TO CENTER DRAWS ABOUT SERVICES
ON SITE. SURE THAT THEY- HOME
HEATING THAT WERE OPERATING AS
AN AGENCY WE ARE STAFFING THOSE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN WE ARE FOR
CASE MANAGEMENT SERVICES
LINKING PEOPLE UP WITH ANY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY COMING ON SITE
THROUGH OUR KINGS YOU POP
ROBERT M. THEY WILL COME ON
SITE TO ASSESSMENTS ON ANYBODY
AND PROVIDE THOSE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THERE- WE ARE ALSO YOU
KNOW USING JOB BOARDS AND
HELPING FOLKS WITH SUBMITTING
RESUMES. WITH OUR CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES BUT AS A
TRIAGE. CENTER ARE OUR SERVICES
ARE. I ONLY EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING FOR THAT WE START
WORKING IMMEDIATELY WITH FOLKS
AND WHAT THE TRANSITION PLAN IS
AND HOW WE CAN GET THEM- MOVED
ON TO PERMANENT HOUSING
SUCCESSFULLY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY. I'M SORRY EIGHT GOING
FINISH YOUR THOUGHT WE'RE GONNA
DAY TURNED OUT I WAS JUST GONNA
ASK THROUGH WORKING WITH OUR
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APOLOGIZE ABOUT
THAT SIR DRAWS- ANY FOLLOW UP
ON THAT NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND ADDRESS A FOR THAT LAYS IN
GERMAN OF THE COMMITTEE WERE
NOW BEEN TURNED OVER TO SENATOR
NIELSEN. THEY WERE GONNA GO TO
SENATOR PAN YOU'RE GONNA GO TO
CHAIRWOMAN. HER TITLE. THANK
YOU THE PRESIDENT AND- MY-
PROTEST. AT THIS. IS MORE. IT
OF A- THAN A- BUT IF ANY OF THE
LOCAL GUY PRESENTERS WOULD WANT
TO COMMENT IT WOULD HELPFUL. I
SHOULD WAIT TO TALK IN THIS
SECTION BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST PROBLEMS. WITH
HOMELESSNESS THE FALLS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND I. WILL POINT
TO VARIOUS EXECUTIVE BRANCHES
OVER MANY YEARS. N.
LEGISLATURES OVER MANY YEARS
WHICH OF HELP CREATE THIS
PROBLEM. HOW BY DOING A KIND OF
A PUNCHES PILOTS TAKING THE
PROBLEMS OF THE FALL AND STATE
GOVERNMENT AND DUMP IT. ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. THAT'S
HAPPENED AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN THE MOST RECENTLY THE
LONG PERIOD OF TIME WHICH IS
BEEN CALLED REALIGNMENT. THE
REAL ESSENCE OF REALIGNMENT HAS
BEEN DUMPING THE STATE'S
PROBLEMS. ON THE CITY'S
MECHANICS. AND I SPEAK IN THIS
SECTION BECAUSE I'M MORE OF A
COUNTY PERSON THAN A CITY
PERSON. WHAT DO I MEAN. CANDIES
HAVE MORE MANDATES. THE FALL ON
THEM THE CITIES AND LESSER
RESOURCES TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
BILITY. TO FIND RESOURCES THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE WELL OFF
THEY ARE THEY SET FOR JUST TO
SAY. IT OVER THE YEARS THIS
STATE IN REALIGNING. AS DR SO
MANY. INTO OUR COMMUNITIES MANY
OF HOME HAD BECOME THIS GROWING
BURGEONING. AN OPPRESSIVE
POPULATION. OF HOMELESSNESS.
ENDED UP BEING THAT HAS
OCCURRED WITHOUT. COMMENSURATE
ASSIGNMENT OF RESOURCES TO OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES COUNTIES
CITIES. TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE NEEDS OF THIS POPULATION.
THIRTY THREE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS FOR EXAMPLE. AND
DANGEROUS INDIVIDUALS HAVE IN
ARE BEING PLACED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THEY HAVE
LITTLE ABILITY TO DEAL WITH
THEM. I HEAR WHAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PEOPLE SAY. AND
THEIR FRUSTRATION AT NOT BEING
ABLE TO HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
PRO FRIDAY ACCOMMODATIONS IN
THE TREATMENT. GENERAL
INCULCATED THEN AND WHATEVER WE
DO REGARDING. THE HOMELESS. WE
NEED TO COUPLE THAT. WITH
RESOURCES TO HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS NOT SIMPLY FIND
SHELTER. THAT'S KIND OF A
HOLLOW PROMISE. BUT A DRESS
SOME OF THE PERSONAL NEEDS OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS. I ENVISION
SOMETHING LIKE IN THE DUCATION
THE I. E. P. INDIVIDUAL
EDUCATION PLAN MORE BY. THAT
INDIVIDUAL HOMELESS PERSON. HIS
CHEST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHAT
ARE THEIR NEEDS BEYOND JUST
SHELTER. AND THEN HELPED DEVISE
A PLAN FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL. TO
DEVELOP CAPABILITIES TO BE ABLE
TO SUSTAIN THEMSELVES. BE ON
THE STREET. AND TO ASSIST THEM.
WITH SOME OF THEIR NEEDS. IT
WOULD BRING TO PEOPLE'S
ATTENTION A CLASSIFICATION OF
COUNTIES. OFTEN IT JUST THOUGHT.
URBAN AND RURAL. FIVE POINT A
NEW TERM NOW THERE'S ALSO BEEN
CALLED SUBURBAN COUNTIES. BUT
ONE TERM THAT I'VE INVENTED
MYSELF THE SUPERVISING COUNTIES
THOSE ARE COUNTIES LIKE CONTRA
COSTA MAYBE FORTY FIFTY YEARS
AGO. OR SOLANO COUNTY MORE
RECENTLY THAT I WANT TO
REPRESENT THAT ARE
TRANSITIONING FROM BEING
BASICALLY RURAL COUNTIES. INTO
SUBURBAN AND THEN MET WITH EVEN
SOME CASES SEVEN CASH. AND
THOSE COUNTIES HAVE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF NEEDS A PARTICULAR
HAVE A HEARTFELT CARING OF THE
RURAL. COUNTIES HAVE
REPRESENTED NINETEEN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. IN MY COLLEAGUES HERE
IN THE SENATE FROM SANGER WE
BOTH GREW UP IN THE SAME TOWN
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY WE KNOW.
THE LACK OF THOSE WHO LIVE IN
THOSE VALLEY CITIES AND
COUNTIES. SO THE FUNDAMENTAL
MESSAGE THAT I MAKE AND IF
ANYONE WANTS TO COMMENT I
WELCOME. STATE LEGISLATURES AND
GOVERNORS. ADMINISTRATIONS NEED
TO PAY HE- TWO ONE THREE
ALLEVIATE SOME OF OUR BURDENS.
AND THEN WE OPPOSE THEM ON OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES. TO
ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS OF THAT
SO CALLED REALIGNED POPULATION.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE DEAN OF THE
SENATE CENTER NIELSEN WE'RE
GOING TO QUICKLY GO TO-
SUPERVISOR PROVINS REPRESENTING
A YELLOW COUNTY SUPERVISOR IF
YOU DON'T MIND SIXTY SECOND
RESPONSE TO SENATOR NIELSEN
PLEASE. YES THANK YOU A CERTAIN
NIELSEN I THINK WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS BEFORE AND I'M IN
AGREEMENT WITH YOU ABOUT NOT
SHIFTING PROGRAMS TO THE
COUNTIES THAT WILL RESULT IN A
IN A MANDATE AND ADDITIONAL
EXPENSES. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE LIKE ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
LIKE PROJECT ROOM KEY- DURING
THE PANDEMIC IS THAT THEY WORK
ENTIRELY FINANCED- SO WE DIDN'T
HAVE A LOCAL MANAGE BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE WERE ABLE TO ADD%
TO THOSE PROGRAMS THAT FOR
EXAMPLE RECRUITING LOCAL
RESTAURANTS. READ RECRUITING
LOCAL SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SERVICES
AND- HELP TO THE HOMELESS THAT
THAT WASN'T OTHERWISE. COVERED
AND I THINK THAT'S AN APPROACH
THAT'S PROVING SUCCESSFUL.
PROVIDING A PRO TO LOW
GOVERNMENT AND ACTUALLY PAYING
FOR NINE I WOULD AGREE THAT
THAT IS- IS SOMETHING THAT. WE
SHOULD DO GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH SUPERVISOR PREVENT
THAT FROM YELLOW COUNTY WERE
NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
MAYOR VIEGAS WALKER FROM THE
CITY OF EL CENTRO. I SIXTY
SECONDS PLEASE ON THE CENTER.
YEAH HE PROBABLY COULDN'T SEE
ME WHILE I WAS DOING IT BUT I
WAS GIVING US SENATOR NELSON IS
A STANDING OVATION I THINK THAT
HE HEARKEN BACK TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY. SENATOR
EGGMAN EARLIER ON WHICH IS WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. OF THE
FOLKS AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT
ALREADY. GET TO THE PERSONAL
ROOT CAUSES S TO SOME OF THESE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. LIKE IN
LIKENING IT TO AN I EP FOR THE
HOMELESS I THINK THAT THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY. CRITICAL WE DON'T
HAVE A CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM WITHIN IMPERIAL COUNTY
SITE UNITS ARE ALMOST
NONEXISTENT THERE'S NO BEDS
AVAILABLE FOR THE FOLKS THAT
REALLY NEED THEM. PROVIDING
HOUSING ONLY IS NOT THE
SOLUTION WE HAD A- BAD- REYES
KATIE- PERSON COME IN AND DO
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
DAMAGE TO A HOTEL ROOM. THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT IT SHOULD
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN SCREENED
OUT THEY WERE NOT PROVIDED WITH
THE WRAPAROUND SERVICES THAT
THEYNEED IT SO. IT'S NOT JUST
ENOUGH WE ALL KNOW IS NOT JUST
ENOUGH TO. GIVE SOMEONE OF
PLACE TO. TO SHOWER AND GET
READY TO FACE THE DAY WE REALLY
HAVE TO PROVIDE THEM. WITH
THAT- WRAPAROUND SERVICE
COMPONENT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MAYOR. ALL RIGHTY THANK YU
VERY MUCH SOONER. A LAYS IN
GERMAN COMMITTEE WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR PAN. HE'S VERY MUCH- OF
A SHARE AND- CENTERS AS WELL- I
GUESS EVAN DID WANT TO TOUCH
ON- ISSUE DOES RAISE BY- THIS-
VEGAS WALKER TO MAYOR MAYOR IS
WALKER AND FIRST OF ALL THE
SLICE BEGAN ASSN DO I RECOGNIZE
THE SUPERVISOR PREVENTS- WHO-
HIS SUPERVISOR AND YELLOW
COUNTY WHICH- PART OF WHICH I
DO REPRESENT- SO. ONE THREE THE
END THIS HERE WE START OFF BY
TWO ABOUT. THE FACT THAT WE
NEED A GREATER SUPPLY OF
HOUSING- IN MANY CASES NOT ALL
OF THOSE DECISIONS BUT- THOSE
ASIANS ARE LAND USE DECISIONS
MADE BY CITIES AND SOME ARE
MADE BY COUNTIES- SAME TIME WE
TALK ABOUT WRAPAROUND SERVICES-
AND I KNOW THAT IS- SOMEONE DO
WITH THE PASTURE OF- BUT JUST
SOME THREE THAT. A LOT OF THAT
IS ACTUALLY DELEGATED TO
COUNTIES AND APPRECIATE- CENTER
NIELSEN BRING UP SOME OF THAT
ISSUE AS WELL- SO. I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS THE
INTEGRATION BETWEEN CITY
DECISION MAKING WHICH INVOLVES
LAND USE AND- YOU KNOW HOUSING.
WITH COUNTY CELLS COUNTY
SOMETIMES AS HAVE COUNTY
PROPERTY IN OKAY. IT THAT THAT
THAT HAS LAND USE OF SCARCE
COUNTY LAND BUT THEN THERE'S
THE CITIES AND THEN BUT YET.
ALSO TO SOCIAL SERVICES AT
LEAST AMPLE MENTAL HEALTH OF
MEDICARE HOW. BASICALLY FOR
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH- BASICALLY
DEPENDS ON COUNTY. BEHAVIOR
HEALTH PLANS- THAT'S- THAT'S
HOW WE IN FACT WE GIVE QUITE A
BIT OF AUTONOMY TO COUNTIES IN
TERMS OF. THE COUNTY HEALTH.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PLANS- SO HOW
DO SOME TO AND SOMETIMES HAT
TO DON'T COME TOGETHER AND I
SPENT FORTY SEEN THIS IN MY OWN
DISTRICT- SO WHAT CAN WE DO TO
GET BETTER COLLABORATION
BETWEEN CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO. ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND BE SURE YOU HAVE THE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES WHICH ARE
OFTEN TIMES THE RESOURCES ARE
DIRECTED TO COUNTIES. HOW DO WE
GET BETTER LAND USE DECISIONS-
THAT HELP US INCREASE HOUSING
SOME OF WHICH ARE DONE BY
COUNTIES BUT ACTUALLY SEE- DONE
BY CITIES- AND FOR EXAMPLE MICE
AND SEE HERE SACRAMENTO
ACTUALLY FORTUNATELY DID TAKE
STEPS TO TRY TO INCREASE-
HOUSING BY ALLOWING. US TO
THEIR ZONING DECISIONS-
ALLOWING- HILLS AND. SINGLE
FAMILY HOME AREAS TO HAVE- TO
HAVE DUPLEXES AND- IN SO FORTH-
THIS WHAT WHAT CAN WE TO BRING
THESE THINGS TO- WHEN IT COMES
TRYING TO DRESS BOTH HOMELESS.
AND OF COURSE FLAT HOUSING THAT
IS DRIVING HOME LISTED ALSO IS
ONE OF THE DRIVERS OF
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER PAN- WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST GO TO. MAYOR VIEGAS
WALKER- MAYOR PLEASE. WE'RE
GONNA GIVE YOU SIXTY SECONDS
FOR EACH OF THE- QUESTIONS SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST. WHAT CAN BE
DONE TO HAVE BETTER
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CITIES
AND COUNTIES. N. E. POINTED OUT
THAT YOU'RE TAKING THE BALL
COMPARE FREEZING HERE CITIES
ARE TAKING THE BULK OF THE
ROOMS IN REGARDS TO PROJECT ON
KEY. AND THEN THE SECOND PIECE
IS WHAT CAN CITIES DO- THEY
HAVE- BETTER DECISION MAKING
WHEN IT COMES ELAINE USED TO BE
ABLE TO EXPEDITE HOUSING AS
WELL SO LET'S GO TO THAT FIRST
ONE IMMIGRANTS A COLLABORATION
SIXTY SECONDS IN SIXTY SECONDS
FOR. EXPEDITING HOUSING. AGAIN
I THINK I WANT TO COME BACK YOU
JUST GOT A WHOLE LOT OF
BRILLIANCE IN THE ROOM EARLIER
ON SENATOR CAVALEIRO TALKED
ABOUT METRICS ACCOUNTABILITY
EQUITY AND I'M GOING TO ADD A-
FOURTH ONE AND THAT IS
TRANSPARENCY AND I WOULD JUST
SIMPLY GO BACK OUT TO THE
COUNTIES AND SAY. HOW ARE YOU
COLLABORATING WITH YOUR CITIS.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES IT
WOULD BE COUNTY BUT THERE
NEEDED BY THE CITIES TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS HOW IS THAT
COLLABORATION- OCCURRING. THIS
WEEK WE CAN HAVE ARE HANDLED
BUT IN LESLIE COUNTY IS WILLING
FOR THOSE DOLLARS TO FLOW INTO
OUR COFFERS WERE TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES IT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN SO I WOULD I WOULD JUST
ASK FOR GREATER TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL. SAYING HOW ARE
YOU COLLABORATING- WITH YOUR
WITH YOUR UNCLE COOL COOL PART
SAID THAT AT THE- AT THE CITY
LEVEL. AND THEN WITH REGARD TO
LAND USE THAT'S THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON WE KNOW THAT
IN A LOT OF JURISDICTIONS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS WITHIN THE
CITY. AND IT MAKES MUCH MORE
SENSE FOR THAT THE RESIDENTS TO
BE RESIDING WITHIN THE CITIES
TO PREVENT THE URBAN. SPRAWL
AND EVERYTHING ELSE ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT SO. I REALLY. THINK
THAT THE LAND USE. AND HOUSING
GOES HAND HAND IS. THERE NEEDS
TO BE THE- INTO. FOR K. TO ON
TO WORK DIRECTLY WITH CITIES ON
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PEACE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH CENTER PAN WERE
NOW GOING TO GO TO SUPERVISOR
PREVENTIVA AT BETTER
COLLABORATION BETWEEN COUNTIES
AND CITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE PROJECTS IN WHAT CAN BE
DONE TO BE A INCENTIVIZE.
HOUSING SUPERVISOR BERMAN SAID
YOLO COUNTY. BETWEEN THE CITIES
AND THE COUNTY AND THE REASON
WE WERE ABLE TO LISTEN WE WERE
ALREADY COLLABORATING ON
HOMELESS ISSUES WE MEET
REGULARLY. ON HOMELESS ISSUES
THAT CITY AND THE COUNTY- ALL
THE CITIES AND THE COUNTY MEET
REGULARLY AND- WE PROVIDE THE
SOCIAL SERVICES. AND THEN THE
CITY WILL UP PURCHASE- THE
BUILDINGS OR RENT THE
BUILDINGS- THAT THEY TOOK CARE
OF THE HOTEL ROOMS PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. FOR EXAMPLE THE CITY
OF DAVIS DID A- A DAY CENTER
FOR THE HOMELESS- COUNTY PAID
HALF THE COST. AND THEN ALSO
PROVIDED THE SOCIAL SERVICES WE
DON'T LOOK AT IT AS A CITY OR
COUNT ISSUE WE LOOK AT IT AS
SOMETHING THAT WE JOINTLY DO
TOGETHER. AND ARE R. C. A. O.
IN OUR CITY MANAGER SIT DOWN
AND DISCUSS WHO'S GOING TO DO
WHAT AND THEN WE DO IT. AND
BECAUSE OF THAT ONE WHEN WE
WENT INTO THE PROJECT ROOM KEEP
WEEK WE WERE SET UP FOR THAT WE
ALREADY HAD. THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND I THINK WHAT
CAN BE DONE TO ENCOURAGE IT IS
AT THE LEVEL LOCAL LEVEL- THERE
NEEDS TO BE A COMMITMENT TO
FOCUS ON PROBLEMS S. AS A
REGIONAL PROBLEM WITH IT RATHER
THAN AS A CITY. OR COUNTY
PROJECT IT CAN BE IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO DO BUT WHEN YOU'RE
DOING IT AND I'M GOING BASIS. I
THINK IT'S SO LESS OF A
CHALLENGE. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
A VISOR GOING TO TURN IT BACK
OVER TO- SENATOR PAN QUICKLY ON
YET SO I GUESS MY IN THE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT FOR EXAMPLE
YELLOW COUNTY I'M GLAD YOU'RE
DOING THAT ARE READY. WHAT
HAPPENED WHAT SHOULD WHAT
SHOULD THE STATE TO I'M ASKING
VOCAL BILL BECAUSE WE WANT YOUR
INPUT. AS TO TOO FAR LIKE WHAT
CAN WE DO TO FOSTER MORE THAT
COLLABORATION SO IT'S GREAT FOR
ITS HAPPENING THE PROBLEM IS
WHEN IT'S NOT HAPPENING. THE
REAL PROBLEMS AND SO WHAT WHAT
IS IT I MEAN WE DON'T HAVE THE
CAMERAS AT PEOPLE BUTWHAT
SHOULD WE BE DOING AS AT THE
STATE TO. GET MORE PEOPLE TO DO
THAT LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING ANY
OTHER COUNTY SO I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER MAYBE WHAT SOME OF THE
OTHER SPEAKER WANT OTHER
SPEAKERS MY WHITE DRESS THAT
WOULD BE MY HAVE LAMAR
CHALLENGE. WITH THIS
COLLABORATION. ABSOLUTELY SO
LET'S OPEN IT UP I'M WORKING
ASK. FOR THIRTY SO RESPONSE IS
JUST. OF AND I- WE- HAD A
MARTIN LA. HAD TO ANOTHER. BUT
WHEN OF THE ITEMS THAT. SHE IS
BEEN HAVING. IS THEY HAVE A JOB.
JOY POWER AUTHORITY. BETWEEN
THE CITY AND THE COUNTY ON
DECISION MAKING IN FINDING. OUT
WHICH- HAS HELPED STREAMLINE.
BUT THAT'S THE TURN IT OVER TO-
IS CRITICIZED. FROM TURNING
POINT. WHAT CAN THE STATE DO TO
HELP EXPEDITE SERVICES AND
HOUSING- EXCEL IN. IN MY NECK
OF THE WOODS WE HAD. A REALLY
GOOD EXPERIENCE WHEN WE HAD
FUNDS THAT WERE ALLOCATED TO.
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE AND I SAY
THAT BECAUSE- BOTH THE COUNTIES
AND THE CITY AND ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE IN THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE. YEAH OF THE CONTINUE ON
THE ABILITY TO. YOU KNOW LOOK
AT AT WHAT THE NEEDS WERE LOOK
AT THE DATA AND BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHAT. WHAT TYPES OF
INTERVENTIONS WERE NEEDED AND
THIS IS WITH KEEP AND CASH AS
THOSE WERE. ZERO C. ALLOCATIONS
WE'RE ABLE TO LOOK AT WHAT WAS
NEEDED. AND THEN THE CITIES AND
THE COUNTIES CAME TO THE C. O.
C. WITH. A PLANAND THE C. O.
C. VOTED. ON IT. SO IT WAS. IT
IT WHAT IT WAS LIKE A NATURAL
COLLABORATION BECAUSE IT WAS A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE COCS
BATTED WHAT THE FUNDING WOULD
BE USED FOR- AND THAT CAN BE
DONE IN OTHER WAYS LIKE IF THE
IF THE MONEY IS NOT ALLOCATED
TO THE CEO SEEN. CITIES AND
COUNTIES COULD BE REQUIRED WHEN
THEY PUT IN APPLICATIONS TO GET
A LETTER FROM THE CEO SEE
VERIFYING THAT THEY DIDN'T RUN
IT THROUGH. INTERNET RUN THEIR
PLAN THROUGH THIS YEAR- STANDBY
INPUT. BACK FROM THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THE SERVICES- AND
ANOTHER MODEL THAT WORKS WELL
IN JURISDICTIONS I THINK THAT
WHERE THE CITY AND THE COUNTY.
MAY NOT PLAY AS NICE TO GATHER
IS ONE NON PROFITS ARE OFTEN
ARE OPERATING THE PROGRAM THEN
THEY HAVE THE PARTNERSHIPS TO
MAKES THOSE. SERVICES
ACCESSIBLE TO THE EIGHT
RESIDENTS OUT OF ANY PROGRAM-
AN EXAMPLE IS WITH OUR HOME HE
FINDS WE- ARE HOUSING AUTHORITY
BOUGHT THE BUILDINGS TURNING
POINT AS AN AGENCY THAT'S
OPERATING THREE OF THEM AND WE
LIKE FOLKS THAT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. SO AND THAT IS ARE
YOU KNOW A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT I'VE SEEN WORK REALLY WELL
IN THE PAST. YES HE DID GIVE
HIS CONSENT AND BRINGING
TANGIBLE EXAMPLES TO THE TABLE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
RESPECT WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU-
SENATOR PAN **** BEST WAYS
WOULD EXPEDITE HOUSING- WITH
CITIES AND COUNTIES- YOUR
PERSPECTIVE PLEASE WE'RE GONNA
ASK FOR THIRTY SECONDS. EXCUSE.
ME SIXTY SECONDS APOLOGIZE.
THANK YOU I. AM HUMBOLDT COUNTY
I THINK WE- WORK PRETTY WITH TO
LARGER CITIES IN. I'M HAVE SOME
PRETTY GOOD PROGRAMS. AND I.
FEEL LIKE THEY CONTINUE OF CARE
STRUCTURE AND- I THINK THAT WE
COULD WORK ON NOT STRUCTURE SO
THAT ALL COUNTIES HAVE A GATE
CONTINUUM OF CARE I THINK THAT
THERE ARE AND SOME STRUCTURES
THAT DON'T WORK AS WELL AS
OTHER OTHERS SO I THINK THAT
THAT THAT MAY BE AN OPTION AND-
I DO LIKE AND THAT ALL. OF OUR
NON PROFITS AND FOLKS THAT WORK
AND WITH THE COUNTY AND THE
CITIES ACTUALLY ARE A PART OF
THAT CONTINUUM OF CARE AND NOT
DECISION MAKING PROCESS I THINK
THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL. AND YEAH
THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
DIRECTOR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU TO
THAT THE PANEL ON THAT WE NOW
GOING TO GO DO THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN OUT FOR THE REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS ARE BEING
ASKED TODAY VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT SIR- THAT'S TURN IT OVER
TO SENATOR PER TILE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. I GUESS I'M JUST
IT'S NOT SO MUCH OF A QUESTION
BUT JUST TRYING TO GET MORE OF
AN UNDERSTANDING I USED TO BE I
COME FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND I GET THE UNDERSTOOD THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE WHEN IT
COMES TO GROWTH WHEN IT COMES
TO. MORE HOUSING BUT I AM
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE ROLE
THAT. LAST GOAL PLEASE AND IN
TERMS OF GROWTH AND- OUT WHEN
IT COMES TO. A BUILDING MARK
EIGHT- HOMES OR OR OR JUST
BEING ABLE TO. SUSTAIN THE
GROWING POPULATION THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT ALSO THE RISING
HOMELESSNESS- SITUATION WOULD
HAPPEN IN THE STATE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS CENTER TIDO. LET'S
GO TO IF IT'S ALRIGHT AT ANY
COMMENTS- TO SEND HER TITLE
MISS CATCH INSIDE. FROM TURNING
POINT. THIRTY MARK AND I AM
SORRY. EXACTLY YEAH THE FLOOR
IS YOURS MA'AM. AND I THINK
THAT. NOT REALLY I MEAN TO BE
HONEST I'M NOT REALLY SURE HOW
TO RESPOND TO HER COMMENTS AND-
I DO THINK OF THAT. CONTINUUM'S
OF CARE ARE AN IMPORTANT PART
AS THE DECISION MAKING AND
JURISDICTIONS- AND I AM I MEAN
ULTIMATELY LIKE I THINK. I'VE
COVERED A LOT IN TERMS OF WHAT
HER COMMENTS WERE SO IS THERE A
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS NO IT'S GOOD
YOU'RE GOOD JUDY THANK YOU SO
MUCH SUPERVISOR PREVENTIVA YOLO
COUNTY- COUNTY WITH THE
CONTINUED CARE ANY COMMENTS ON
THAT. YOUR NEED SIR I'M SORRY.
GOOD OKAY THANK YOU I THINK THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE IS THAT A
GOOD CONCEPT I WHO ONE OF OUR
PROBLEMS HAS BEEN BIFURCATION
OF FUNDING- IN VARIOUS PROGRAMS
AND THEN BETWEEN THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY AND I THINK THAT'S
FUNDING A REGIONAL EFFORT THAT
MIGHT INCLUDE CONTINUUM OF CARE
IS PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA. WE
WERE STRUGGLING WHEN WE'RE
TRYING TO ESTABLISH CITY COUNTY.
OPERATION BECAUSE OF THE
BIFURCATION CARE MORE RECENTLY-
THAT THE PROJECT ROOM KEY WE
WERE WE WERE ABLE TO GET
REIMBURSEMENT FROM ALMOST
EVERYTHING WE DID INCLUDING-
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND BY
COOPERATION THAT THAT THAT
EXISTED I HAVE A STRONG PROGRAM
BUT I THINK THE BIFURCATION OF
FUNDING CURRENTLY- CAN BE A
PROBLEM AND- IF THERE WAS A- A
REGIONAL APPROACH TO FUNDING I
THINK YOU SEE MORE RAD MORE OF
A REGIONAL EFFORT. UP I'M NOT
AWARE OF LASKO HAVING A ROLE
THEY HAVEN'T HAD A ROLE IN OUR
COUNTY- BUT- I THINK THE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES AND SO
FORTH SO WE WORK WITH- AS WELL
AS RECOGNIZING THE DIFFERENT
ROLES OF GOVERNMENT AND-
WORKING TOGETHER TO TRY TO
ACHIEVE A COMMON GOAL I DO
UNDERSTAND- THE ISSUE OF- MAYBE
HOUSING NOT BEING APPROVED.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
STRUGGLE WITH THAT KIND OF THE
NBS OF THE CURRY SOMETIMES I
THINK THAT'S- CHANGING SOMEWHAT
BUT- IF WE DON'T BUILD HOUSING.
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THANK YOU SO MUCH SIS.
I DID IS BEING- IT.
CONVERSATION WITH LEADERS WHERE
THEY'RE FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEADERS FROM NONPROFIT AGENCIES
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAMS IN THE SERVICES ON THE
GROUND WITH PROJECT RONCHI ROOM
KEY AND HOME KEY WE WANT TO
SAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU TO
SUPERVISOR PREVENTS THAT THANK
YOU TO MAYOR VIEGAS WALKER
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS MARTIN
FROM. LOS ANGELES WE WANT TO
THANK YOU I DO MISS GETS
ASSIGNED REPRESENTING TURNING
POINT IN OF COURSE MISS BACK
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY OF
HUMBOLDT. WE OWE YOU A DEBT OF
GRATITUDE WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIMES
AND THIS IS BEEN A WONDERFUL
PANEL THANK YOU SO MUCH. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE COMMITTEE
WE HEARD FROM- THE STATE WE'VE
HEARD FROM LOCAL LEADERS AND
NOW WE'VE GOT TO BE TO TURN IT
OVER TO SUPERVISOR OR A
SUPERVISOR SENATOR WIENER
FORMER SUPERVISOR I MIGHT ADD-
TO BE ABLE TO RUN OUR LAST
PANEL. ON TRANSITIONAL USE. THE
FOR SURE SIR. THANK YOU ONE A
SUPER. OR IS- SO I ALREADY A
PREVIEW INTRODUCED- THE PANEL
WHEN I'M IS A GOMEZ- SPOKE
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF OUR
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH IN TERMS
OF HOMELESSNESS- AND SO WE NOW
WILL GO TO THE- OTHERS SPEAKERS
ON A PANEL ROBIN ROSE HAMMER
WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
SERVICES AT THE SACK SACRAMENTO
LGBT. COMMUNITY CENTER I DO
JUST WANT TO KNOW- THAT- ONE OF
THE MANY REASONS THAT I'VE BEEN
SO INVOLVED OVER THE YEARS
AROUND YOUTH HOMELESSNESS- IS
ON MY OWN COMMUNITY THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY IS HEAVILY OVER
REPRESENTED AMONG HOMELESS USE-
ABOUT 40% OR MORE OF HOMELESS
YOUTH IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ. SO
THIS IS A CRISIS FOR YOUTH IN
GENERAL BUT PARTICULARLY FOR
YOUNG LGBTQ PEOPLE WHO ARE SO
DEEPLY AT RISK- EITHER ARE
RUNNING AWAY FROM HOME OR BEING
KICKED OUT OF THEIR HOME- AND-
AND SO IT'S REALLY US
STRUGGLING AND LOCKING THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY- NEED SO
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY
CENTER THOSE TERRIFIC WORK AS-
DO OTHER LGBT. CENTERS AND
PROGRAMS AROUND THE STATE- SO
WITHOUT WILL TURN OVER. TO
ROBIN ROSE HAMMER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR KIND
INVITATION MY NAME IS ROBIN
ROSE HAMMER AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF HOUSING SERVICES
FOR THE SACRAMENTO LGBT
COMMUNITY CENTER. I'D LIKE TO
THINK OF ON WATSON CAN LUIS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH FOR RAISING THESE
ISSUES AND SOME RESEARCH SAY
FOR THAT KIND OF ATTENTION TO
SPEAK TODAY. YOUR BACKGROUND
PAPER PRESENTED REFLECTS SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES IN
IDENTIFICATION AND
QUANTIFICATION OF THE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL LAYER FOR
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH AS THEY
DO NOT FIT THE HOMELESS
DEFINITION DEFINITION
PRESCRIBES BY HEAD AND
FREQUENTLY COUCH SURF. OR
REMAIN INVISIBLE FOR SAFETY.
THERE ARE VERY DIFFERENT NEEDS
FOR TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH
THEIR AGES AND STAGES DICTATE.
A CERTAIN LEVEL OF. SUPPORT
THAT IS NOT TYPICALLY PROVIDED
IN PROGRAMS AND I'M SURE THAT
THOSE OF YOU WHO'VE EVER LIVED
WITH OR NOT A TEENAGER ARE
KEENLY AWARE OF THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT THEIR AGE GROUP
PRESENTS IN TERMS OF EMOTIONAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT.
THIS OCCURS IN COHABITATION IN
CONJUNCTION AND IT'S
EXACERBATED BY ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES.
GENERATIONAL TRAUMA AND POVERTY.
THERE IS A REDUCED AVAILABILITY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH HAS
BEEN WIDELY DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY BUT IT PUTS A DOWNWARD
SQUEEZE ON THE LESS ADEPT AT
NEGOTIATING THOSE COMPLEX
SYSTEMS. TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE CHOSEN AS
A CANDIDATE FOR THOSE HOUSING
PROGRAMS AS THEY HAVE LESS
ESTABLISH CREDIT SHORTER
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY AND GREATER
TRANSIENTS. IN SACRAMENTO WE
HAVE FANTASTIC CHALLENGES AND
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE
MANY DIVERSE PROGRAM PROGRAMS
WHICH IS FANTASTIC BUT THERE
ARE TOO FEW SPOTS IN THOSE
INNOVATIONS WHICH IS REALLY NOT
GOOD. THE TOTAL OF SPOTS IS NOT
IS LESS THAN 25% OF THE
IDENTIFIED YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNT. WHICH HAS POSTULATED TO
HAVE BEEN AS MUCH AS A 75%
UNDER COUNT OF THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
DUE TO THE NATURE OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS WHICH IS HIGHLY
INVISIBLE. WE HAVE HAD AN
INCREASE NEED FOR TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING AS YOUTH IN THE SHELTER
HAVE NO WHERE TO EXIT. WE
RECEIVED USED INTO OUR SHELTER
FROM OTHER SHELTERS AS MANY
OTHER LOCAL PROBLEM PROGRAMS
HAVE THE SAME EXIT CHALLENGES.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT COATED
STANDS TO EXACERBATE THIS IS
CURRENTLY HOUSED FAMILIES ARE
BECOMING UNSTABLE. TRANSITIONAL
AGE YOUTH ARE VULNERABLE
BECAUSE THEY'RE ADULTS AND SO
FAMILIES PEELED OFF IN AN
EFFORT TO STATE HOUSE
PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY'RE
COMBINING HOUSEHOLDS WITH OTHER
UNSTABLE FOLKS. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT FROM THE LAST RECESSION
YOUNG PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LGBTQ
YOUTH WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGED AND WE STAND TO
REPEAT THIS RECENT HISTORY
WITHOUT PROACTIVE ACTION. SO
WHAT DO WE NEED. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN USE
IDENTIFIED AS THE SECOND
HIGHEST PRIORITY AFTER MORE
HOUSING EMPLOYMENT. SOLID
RELIABLE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMMING THAT LEADS TO
TANGIBLE EMPLOYMENT. EASY TO
ENTER EASY TO ACCESS AND
PROGRAMS THAT FOLKS CAN BENEFIT
FROM WITH PROGRAM
CONSIDERATIONS THAT INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE TRANSPORTATION.
STIPENDS AND PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. TRANSITIONAL AGE
YOUTH HAVE MULTI FACETED NEEDS
AND THAT'S WHY PROGRAMS HAVE TO
BE CREATED AND DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO MEET THEM WHERE
THEY ARE. THE DATA SUGGESTS
THAT UPWARDS OF 50% OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE DESIGNATED CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS NOW WE'RE HOMELESS AS
YOU. THIS IS A SOLVABLE PROBLEM
IF YOU START NOW BY
PRIORITIZING YOU. WE NEED MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS OPPOSED
TO. IT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
YOUTH PROGRAMS. AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE APPRECIATE
THOSE WHO UNDERSTAND AND
DIFFERENT DIFFERENTIATE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN HOW THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. AND THE
DEEPENING NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. OUR CURRENT CONCERN IS
DEFINITELY BOTH ENDS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF FOR THOSE
ELOQUENT COMMENTS AND WE SO
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
TODAY AND HANG IN WITH US-
DURING THIS HEARING IS WELL ALL
RIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
COMMITTEES WITH ACTIVATED OPEN
IT UP FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- I KNOW I HAVE A
COUPLE BUT WE WANT TO SEE THOSE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. BY THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ALL RIGHT
AT WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SEE MISS
ROSE HAMER CAN YOU TALK TO US
ABOUT. THE SO MUCH OF THE
FUNDING IT'S COMING DOWN. IS
THAT LET'S FOCUS ON PROJECT
ESPECIALLY HAVING A
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE UNITS
NUMBER ONE- AND BEING CHRONIC
HOMELESS SIX ADDRESS TALK TO US
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES IN FUNDING
HAD TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
HOUSING IN THIS FORMULA IN
WHICH THE STATE HAS ADDRESSED.
SO IN YOU VERY ABSOLUTELY HIT
THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH DO NOT
ACCESS PROJECT TWENTY THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE TYPICALLY ACCESSED THROUGH
ADULT SHELTERS. AND ADULTS-
OUTREACH YEP AND USE ARE NOT
FOUND IN THOSE SPACES SO
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF RESOURCES BEING
ALLOCATED TOWARD THE MILLION
RATIONS OF. THE HOMELESSNESS
ISSUE BUT THAT DOES NOT TOUCH
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH AS
THEY'RE NOT IN THOSE SPACES.
YEAH AND I THINK THAT'S THE
AGAIN AND I DON'T WANT TO PUT
WORDS IN YOUR MOUTH AND
DIRECTOR BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH THE GAP
NOW JUST GOTTEN WIDER BUT I
DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH SO. TALK TO US IN CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG. SO THE REALITY
IS THAT THE- PARTNERSHIPS THAT.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SERVE. THE POPULATION OF
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH AND
PARTICULARLY LGBT YOUTH. THANK
IN PARTICULAR- THAT ROLE CAN'T
BE UNDERSTATED AND THERE ARE
LOTS OF REALLY GREAT USES FOR
GOVERNMENT AND LARGE PROGRAMS
LIKE ONE BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES. BUT THE REALITY IS
THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND FOLKS
THAT WORK WITH YOUTH. ON A DAY
TO DAY BASIS ARE THE ABSOLUTE
BEST STRATEGY FOR BEING ABLE
TO. REDUCE AND ELIMINATE YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS. AND GETTING
RESOURCES INTO THE HANDS OF
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE RUNNING
THOSE PROGRAMS SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY. AREAS HAS BEEN AN 88%
SET ASIDE THAT WAS DESIGNATED.
BY STATUTE FOR BOTH KEEP AND
HAPPY. AND THAT IS COMPLETELY
INSUFFICIENT TO BE ABLE TO-
ADDRESS AND- NEGOTIATE. THE
PROBLEM. I THINK THE OTHER
PIECES HE SAID AT SO MANY OF
THESE. YOUTHS ARE POTENTIALLY
COMING OUT OF THE FOSTER SYSTEM
HERE. IN CALIFORNIA IN THIS
JUST BE CANDID- UNDERFUNDED AS
WELL- ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO SERVICES AFTER THE AGE OUT
OF THE SYSTEM. SO IN ADDITION
TO HAVING TO TRY TO SECURE.
SHELTER SHOULD SECURE- A ROOM.
AT THE VERY MINIMUM. THEY'RE
DEALING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES DETENTION CENTERS
ABUSE. I MEAN IT'S- A LIFETIME
OF CHALLENGES IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON. THAT AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO SENATOR WIENER. I'D BE
HAPPY TO. THE RIYADH IS THAT
OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM DOES THE
VERY BEST YOU CAN WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT IT HAS AVAILABLE
BUT IT'S A POOR SUBSTITUTE FOR-
NATURAL AND- ORGANIC FAMILIES.
AND ANYONE OF US IS RAISED A
CHILD KNOWS THAT THE COST IS
NOT JUST FINANCIAL THERE'S ALSO
ALMOST ON PSYCHOLOGICAL COSTS
FOR RAISING A CHILD AND IF
THERE AREN'T FOLKS AROUND TO BE
ABLE TO POUR INTO THE YOUNG
PEOPLE. WHO ARE LIVING IN THEIR
HOMES OR THOSE HOUSES ARE
DYSFUNCTIONAL IT ONLY
EXACERBATES THE PROBLEMS. THAT
ARE EXPERIENCED BY TEENAGERS
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST GOING
THROUGH THE NORMAL
PSYCHOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENTAL
CHALLENGES OF BEING A YOUNG
PERSON- THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO TRANSITION
A YOUNG PERSON FROM BEING.
FULLY CARED FOR IN A HOME TO. I
CALL IT LAUNCHING INTO
ADULTHOOD ARE TREMENDOUS AND
ALMOST NOT QUANTIFIABLE IF
YOU'RE ADDING A DOLLAR FIGURE
TO IT SO THERE IS A DEEP NEED
FOR QUALITY PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENTS. THAT ADDRESSES
ALL OF THE ASPECTS OF LAUNCHING
AND MOST OF OUR FOSTER CARE
PROGRAMS DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND OR THE BAND WITH
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE THAT KIND
OF COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAMMING.
ALSO NGUYEN YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
MOVING INTO OTHER SYSTEMS LIKE
HIGHER EDUCATION THERE IS AN
EXPECTATION THAT THOSE SYSTEMS
ARE INTACT AND FOLKS GO INTO
HIGHER ED AND HEAD OFF TO THE
COLLEGE OF THEIR CHOICE AND
THEN THERE'S NOT HOUSING THERE.
FOR THEM TO GO TO THAT AND THEN
ADDS AN ADDITIONAL LAYER OF
STRESS AND THAT AND YOU CAN'T
FIND HOUSING WHERE YOU'VE
DECIDED O GO TO COLLEGE. SO
HIGHER ED HAS THAT CHALLENGES
WELL IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
SUPPORTING. INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING NO THANK YOU SO
MUCH I DID NOT MEAN TO I CUT
YOU OFF I JUST READ ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES LEFT- AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE CENTER.
WIENER I AND I JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER FOR A-
THIS PAIN. RIGHT TO THE HARING
IT WAS THREE YEARS. SO CENTER
WINNER THE FLOORS ARE. THANK
YOU ARE THE I WAS VERY- PUBLIC
I WANT TO ECHO- FRANKLY THE
FRUSTRATION. ON THAT
CALIFORNIA. REALLY HAS NOT EVEN
COME CLOSE TO A NEED TO DO IN
TERMS OF COMMITTING. FIVE TO
END YOUTH HOMELESSNESS WHICH WE
CAN DO. THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
HOMES IS CONSIDERED SO DAUNTING
IN SO MANY WAYS. WE HAVE IT
WITHIN OUR POWER TO AND USE
HOMELESSNESS. AND THE STATE HAS
SIMPLY CHOSEN NOT TO DO SO- I
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT FIVE
SIX YEARS AGO. CALIFORNIA WAS
SPENDING APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
DEDICATED YOUTH HOMELESS
FUNDING. ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE ENTIRE CITY CALIFORNIA.
WE WERE ABLE TO GET UP TO TEN
MILLION A YEAR WE'VE GOT IT ALL
MORE FROM THERE BUT IT IS
STILL. QUITE LOW COMPARED TO
WHAT WE NEED AND THEY MENTIONED
EARLIER MOST COUNTIES A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WITH TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES. LITERALLY
HAVE NO. USE SPECIFIC ALMOST
PROGRAMS. THE KIDS SUPPOSED TO
ONE OF HIS FIRST DO. I WAS IN
FRESNO YOU YEAR AND A HALF AGO
FOR THEIR PRIDE CELEBRATION.
AND I MET A GENTLEMAN WHO JUST.
RUNS A YOUTH NONPROFIT. HE
OPENED UP FRESNO'S FIRST USE
HOMELESS SHELTER WITH TWENTY
FIVE BEDS ON THE FIRST NIGHT
FOUR HUNDRED KIDS SHOWED UP FOR
THOSE TWENTY FIVE DEBTS. AND SO
WE ARE AND EVERY YEAR IN THE
BUDGET WE HAVE TO FIGHT FOR
THAT YOU SET ASIDE BUT YOU JUST
HEARD. WE HAVE TO FIGHT FOR IT
IN THE BUDGET EVERY YEAR FOR
THAT ADEQUATE SET ASIDE SO WE
NEED TO WE HAVE WE HAVE SOME
FUNDING FLEXIBILITY THIS YEAR
THANKFULLY- WE NEED TO. HAVE
SOME SOME MORE ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR HOUSING. BUT WE NEED TO
RETURN THAT TO YEAR AFTER YEAR
MAKING INVESTMENTS WE NEED. TO
REALLY AND YOUR HOME SO IT IS A
MORAL FAILURE THAT. WE HAVE
YOUNG PEOPLE LIVING ON OUR
STREETS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WEALTH AS CENTER WIENER WE WANT
TO DO A LAST CALL FOR ARE ALL
SENATORS A LAST CALL FOR ALL
SENATORS FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS CHANNEL. XENON
WE'RE GONNA BE A TO GIVE A
CLOSING COMMENT TO MISS ROSE
HAMER- PLEASE ADD THIRTY
SECONDS. AT PERHAPS IT'S NAIVE
BUT IF AS A COLLECTIVE. IN THE
SEAT OF OUR GOVERNMENT IN OUR
STATE IF WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THERE ARE A VAST NUMBER OF
RULES AND REGULATIONS. AND
GUIDELINES TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THEN WHY DON'T WE
CHANGE IT. YOU ALL HAVE THE
POWER AND THE ABILITY TO MAKE
IT SIMPLE ARE TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH WILL
CHANGE THE LIVES OF OUR
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH. IN
GIVING THEM SOMEWHERE TO GO
AFTER THEY HAVE TO LEAVE HOME.
PLEASE BUT STE LET'S MAKE
STANDS LET'S TAKE CARE THIS.
YES MISS ROBIN ROSE HEMER SHE'S
THE DIRECTOR OF HOUSING
SERVICES AT THE SACRAMENTO- TO
BE T. COMMUNITY CENTER THANK
YOU FOR OUR LEADERSHIP- IN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- BOLD BOLD
WORDS TODAY WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL. PLACE IN GENERAL
COMMITTEES WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO TRANSITION INTO
PUBLIC COMMENT EVERY INDIVIDUAL
WOULD LIKE TO BE A COMMENTARY
WILL BE GIVEN ONE MINUTE THERE
ARE SEVERAL WAYS YOU CAN
PARTICIPATING COM IN PAIN
PUBLIC COMMENT- NUMBER ONE IS
VIA OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE. IF
THERE IS ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BETTER PARTICIPATE TODAY
PLEASE DIAL. 844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED UP PLEASE USE THIS
ACCESS CODE TWO NINE SIX. ONE
EIGHT FOUR TWO AGAIN.
844-291-6364 AND HIT THAT
ACCESS CODE TWO NINE SIX. AT
TWO NINETY ONE EIGHT FOUR TWO
IT'S VERY EASY FOR ME TO SAY IT
IS PROBABLY BETTER TO LOOK AT
THE BING SCREEN. HI SECONDLY WE
ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM IN
PERSON- TESTIMONY AS WELL SO
LAYS IN GENERAL COMMITTEE WHY
DON'T WE START HERE ON IN THE
IN THE GALLERY. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
WHO IS HERE TO BE A SPEAK UNDER
PUBLIC COMMENT. HEARING XENON
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
ONE TWELVE IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE FOLKS CAN OFFER THE
PUBLIC COMMENT LET'S GO CHECK
ROOM ONE TWELVE. IT TYPICALLY-
QUITE LONELY. AND IT IS A
LONELY ROOM AGAIN TODAY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SO WE ARE NOW GOING
TO START OUR TELECONFERENCE
PUBLIC COMMENT EACH INDIVIDUAL
BE ABLE TO HAVE ONE MINUTE TO
BE ABLE TO EXPRESS. THEIR
OPINION OR PROVIDE COMMENT-
MODERATOR IF YOU DON'T MIND
PLEASE PROMPT ALL INDIVIDUALS
HER WAITING ON THE LINE.YES
THE CHAIR LEADING TO THINK
LATER DETERMINED IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
MY NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
ZERO. MAY A PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MODERATOR
AT HE'S GONNA BE QUEUING UP ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PREPARED TO
BE A TAKE A COMMENT MATTER
MODERATOR HOW MANY FOLKS DO WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. RIGHT NOW
I'M OF THE GERMAN WE HAVE SIX
PEOPLE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
NOT A MODERATOR LET'S TAKE OUR
FIRST CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LINE NUMBER ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SHARON REPORTER WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WE ARE PART OF THE
BRAIN CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION
AND C. S. H. AND THE OTHER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY PLUS MEMBERS OF
THIS COALITION URGED
LEGISLATORS TO TRANSFORM THE
STATE'S RESPONSE. TO PASSAGE OF
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY ONE WE
AGREED THE STATE CANNOT TO MORE
OF THE SAME. WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE BY
BUILDING AND FUNDING RENTAL
ASSISTANCE SERVICES AND
INTERMENT INTERVENTIONS AND THE
SAID THANK YOU. THAT'S THE L.
A. O. AND STATE AUDITOR SAID WE
ALSO NEED CHANGES IN OUR STATE
STRUCTURE TO FOSTER CARE AND
ABILITY TO CREATE INCENTIVES
FOR LOCAL COOPERATION TO
RESOLVE FRAGMENTATION AMONG
STATE AGENCIES AND THE PLAN FOR
DISCHARGES FROM STATE FUNDED
INSTITUTIONAL CREDIT. MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE MUST HAVE ON
GOING SPENDING ONE TIME FUNDING
IS HIGHLY INEFFECTIVE WASTE
STATE RESOURCES AND HAS NEVER
EXCEEDED ONE HALF OF 1% OF THE
STATE'S BUDGET. AB SEVENTY ONE
WILL IMPLEMENT ONGOING RANGE
SOURCE AND TRANSFORM THE
STATE'S RESPONSE THE GREATEST
MARC CHALLENGE OF OUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE GONNA
REMIND ALL CALLERS IN DUE TO
TIME CONSTRAINTS IN THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
GOING TO HAVE TO COME IN AND
CLEAN THE CHAMBERS BEFORE THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. WE'RE GONNA ASK
ALL CALLERS AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR ASSISTANCE WITH THIS TO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
ONE MINUTE MADAM MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
MEDICARE LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ANNA JOHNSON WITH JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR USE CALLING TO
REQUEST THAT A MINIMUM OF 10%
OF THE STATE'S FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SPENDING
ON HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING HOME
KEY. BE DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS AMONG YOUTH WE ARE
PART OF THE BRAIN CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION AND ARE ALSO
SPONSORING EIGHTY FOUR THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM WHICH
REQUEST ONGOING INVESTMENT TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS. FOR
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH
NOW MORE THAN EVER HOMELESS
USING CALIFORNIA REQUIRE ACCESS
TO SAFE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
YOU'D EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
ARE UNIQUELY IMPACTED BY COPING
NINETEEN EXPERIENCING HIGHER
RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT THAN
OLDER WORKERS. AND WITHOUT THE
ECONOMIC. SUPPORTIVE EXTENDED
FAMILY AS I ONE HUNDRED
MENTIONED ONSTAGE PANEL YOU'RE
SATISFIED TO WORK WITH THE 5%
FROM HEAT AND 8% AND HALF. FEET
WIDE JURISDICTIONS SPENT MORE
THAN DOUBLE THAT AMOUNT ON
ADDRESSING YOUTH HOMELESSNESS-
WITH NO SPECIFIED YOU SATISFIED
NEEDS ARE NOT SERVED AND WE SAW
THAT WITH HOME TO BE WITH JUST
TWO OF EIGHTY SEVEN PROJECTS
REACHING YOU- ALTHOUGH THEY
MADE UP 8% OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA. CAN
AS SEEN HERE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. YEAH THANK YOU WE
HAVE AN UP. TO ADMINISTER. NEW
FUNDING I IN A AY THAT REGION
YES AND THANK YOU FOR SENATE
PANELS TODAY AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP. MISTER JOHNSON WE
SO APPRECIATE YOUR PARTNERSHIP-
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP FOR THESE
PAST MANY YEARS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FOR PROVIDING TESTIMONY
TODAY NOT A MODERATOR THIS GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LINE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TYLER IN
THE WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS GRATITUDE
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR HOLDING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING I'M
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
CONSERVATIVE AT THE MAY.
CONTRIBUTE ANNUALLY OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING FOR CAROLINE AND
HOMELESSNESS SERVICES. NOT
INCLUDING FEDERAL FUNDING IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WITHIN
THE BROADER HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
2225% OF INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING ALMOST HALF OF
YOUR MENTAL ILLNESS. THIS IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL BUT A COUPON
PORTION OF THE BROADER
POPULATION WHILE PROJECT ROOM
HE ASKED HOUSE MORE INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THOSE EFFORTS WERE
NOT SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AT
OUR CLIENT. IN MENTAL ILLNESS
AND ACTIVITIES WERE NOT ON THE
PART OF THE FEDERALLY ALLOWED.
YEAH WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
RECENT RESEARCH HAS REVEALED
THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITIONS ARE
ELEVATED RISK OF INFECTION AND
MORTALITY BUT BUILT IN
NINETEEN. FOR PROJECT ROOM
KEEPING HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
IDENTIFY MORE INDIVIDUAL BENITO
COUNTY THEY HAVE ALL SERVICES
ALTHOUGH WE DD NOT BEEN
PROVIDED WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT SERVE BE
BENEFICIAL. HOUSE OUR
POPULATION WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS WE NEED
DEDICATED RESOURCES AND
FLEXIBILITY TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS. TO CONCLUDE THANK YOU SO
MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THANKS FOR CALLING. IN
TODAY NOT A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. YES THE CHAIR LINE
NUMBER. THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO OUT. MY NAME SPARKY HARLAN
AND I'M- BILL CENTER AND CLARA
COUNTY HOUSE AROUND. USE AND
FAMILIES EACH NIGHT INCLUDING
YOUTH AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
JUVENILE FACILITY AND HOMELESS
COLLEGE STUDENTS I AM. SPEAKING
ON SUPPORT SB TWO THIRTY FOUR
AND THE 10% SET ASIDE OF ALL
HOMELESS FUNDING FOR HOMELESS
USE. MISTER AHMED HIS SITUATION
REPRESENT POWERFUL JUNE DR
SYSTEM SALES ARE YOU INCLUDING
OUR CURRENT PRACTICE TARGETING
ONLY FUNDING FOR YOUTH WHO
LEGALLY AGE OUT OF FOSTER CARE
BY LEMONADE SUPPORT TO A
NARROWLY DEFINED GROUPS WE
MISSED THE MAJORITY YOU COULD
TALK TOUCH FOSTER HERE BUT DO
NOT LEGALLY AGE OUT OF THAT.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY ARCTIC CAT
NOW WHETHER HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN IN FOSTER
CARE ONLY 5% OF HOMELESS YOUTH
REPORT THAT THEY AGED OUT OF
FOSTER CARE AND THAT. WOULD BE
HOMELESS BUT 50% REPORT THEY
HAD BEEN IN FOSTER CARE BUT
BECAME HOMELESS AFTER TURNING
EIGHTEEN AT MS GOMEZ GOING TO
ASK YOU TO HOMELESSNESS WE NEED
TO PREVENT LONG TERM CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS. PLEASE SUPPORT
OUR TARGET OF FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS YOUTH AND PLEASE
FOSTER CARE AND SHE WAS NOT AT
ALL OF THESE AND YOU CURRENTLY
STRUGGLING BACK CAPS. THERE
SACRAMENTO. KEEPING SO MUCH FOR
CALLING IN TODAY WE ARE
GRATEFUL YOU HUNG WITH US FOR
THE ENTIRE TIME IN THANK YOU
FOR WORK ALL RIGHT A MODERATOR
IF YOU CAN PLEASE LET KNOW HOW
FOLKS ARE THE QUEUE. AFTER
YOU'VE DONE THAT LET'S GO TO
NEXT CALL. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HAVE FOR. IN MESSAGES.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THE LINE NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING- TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS RYAN JOY AND I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA UNIQUE
AFTER SOCCER WANTED O THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUE OF CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS. AND FOR ALL OF YOUR
EFFORTS TO GET BACK TO THE
NINETEEN- AS YOU MAY KNOW OUR
ORGANIZATION IS FOCUSED ON
SOLVING THE HOUSING CRISIS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THAT WE
THEREFORE UNDERSTAND THAT
ACQUISITION IN CONSTRUCTION OF
SUPPORTIVE IN DEEPLY AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I POOREST STATE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
MINISTRATION FOR THEIR WORK ON
PROJECT HOME KEY AND WILL KEEP.
HAD BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA HAS THE WORST RATE
OF HOMELESSNESS IN THE COUNTRY
25% OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESSNESS OROUR OWN
NEIGHBORS DESPITE CALIFORNIA
ONLY ACCOUNTING 410% OF THE
COUNTRY'S POPULATION. THIS LONG
TERM HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IS
CAUSED BY CALIFORNIANS LONG
TERM HOUSING SHORTAGE AND BE
SHORTAGE. OUR SHORTAGE WHICH IS
GREATER THAN ALL OF THE OTHER
SHORTAGES IN EACH OF THE OTHER
STATES COMBINED IS CONTRIBUTING
TO THIS PROBLEM- THE PROGRAMS
DISCUSS. COULD NOT BE MORE
IMPORTANT IN COURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE IMPROVING. IMPROVING
STEPS I DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
KNOWS M AFTER FIVE HOUSING.
FACTOR CORRECT CALIFORNIA'S
RISING HOUSING PRICES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
RYAN THANKS FOR CALLING IN ANY
GAME THANKS FOR HANGING WITH
US. NOT A MODERATOR NEXT CALL.
WHY NUMBER TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS YOUR BOND WILKES
I'M EXECUTOR DIRECTOR WOULD BE
CAL CALLED FOR YOUTH. AND
BELIEVE WITH ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE HEARD
TODAY. WE HAVE SPOKEN TO THE
NEEDS THAT WE NEED TO INVEST
MORE IN OUR YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
I AM AN INDIVIDUAL WHO NOT ONLY
CAME FROM THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM BUT HAD TO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS AS A YOUNG PERSON.
AND AGAIN TODAY WE HEAR THE
NEEDS INVEST IN THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH ONE ONE
THANK YOU SCOTT WIENER FOR SP
TWO THREE FOUR BECAUSE THAT IS
GOING TO BE PIVOTAL AND CRUCIAL
IN GETTING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
RESOURCE NEXT IS REALLY. MAKING
SURE THAT WE NOT JUST GIVE.
THAT INVEST BUT WE IT TWENTY
FIVE. OF PEOPLE OF THEM BEYOND
LIKE SOME OF OUR PROGRESSIVE
NEIGHBORS WERE SAYING. YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED TO BE PRIORITIZE SO
I REALLY THANK YOU ALL FOR THIS
TIME FOR HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION. IS DEEP
HEARTFELT WORK THAT IS GOING TO
LEAD US BUT WE MUST REMEMBER.
AS AN INSTALLMENT HAS STATED. I
AM THE FEW. SHE IS IN FUTURE
AND WE NEED TWENTY THAT'S IN
OUR FUTURE AND THAT MEANS
INVESTING IN HANDING YOUR
TONSILS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. JOHN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR WORDS ARE GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE WITH US TODAY I'M
NOT A MODERATOR NEXT CALLING.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ALEXIS A FORMER PASTILLAS I
WANT TO START OFF BY SAYING
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
TREMENDOUS EFFORTS BEING PUT
INTO ACTIONS THAT AFFECT THE
BETTERMENT OVERALL WELL BEING
OF PEOPLE. I'M HERE BOTH THE
PART OF THE 10% SATISFIED OUT.
OF THE YOUTH OVER EIGHTEEN
YEARS IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
I WAS FACED WITH MANY OBSTACLES
WHICH LED TO THE OVERWHELMING
AMOUNT OF HARDSHIP. FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE EXPERIENCED SUCH AS THE
HOMELESSNESS I HAD LITTLE TO NO
CONTROL OVER THE SITUATION BUT
LET ME THERE. THIS IS TRUE FOR
MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING THE SAME
MISFORTUNE BUT YOUR SUPPORT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REVERSE
THIS REALITY FOCUSING OUR
EFFORTS. ON PREVENTION RATHER
THAN A REACTION. AND I BEGIN
POLICY ARE. THE MY EARLY. YEARS
I HAVE THINGS HAVE WORKED AND
THINGS THAT HAPPEN WORKS ALLOW.
I CAN TELL YOU. THAT THE 10%
SATISFIED IS WHAT I HAVE SEEN
WORK. YOU NEED THE PERMANENT
ONGOING FUNDING TO ALLOW THEM
TO FOCUS ON STABILIZING.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS. THAT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THE
FUTURE. SO I STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. SELECT
A SINK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN TODAY IT'S GOOD TO HEAR FROM
YOU. NOT A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YES SHARE A LINE
NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRS AND-
THAT ENSURES A MARQUEE GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE IN DEPTH-
LOOK AT ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THAT TO THE
COUNTY. BUT THE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF HOMELESS POPULATION
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
ADDRESSING THE COMBAT THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU AB SEVENTY
ONE WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION- WITH ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OUTCOME MEASUREMENT. AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT PROJECT- HOME TO
THE GOVERNOR'S US SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
FUNDING. BLEACHER TO TAKE A
LOOK IN THE QUARTERS DOWN THE
MEASURE AND THE FUNDING TO
CONTINUE. TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. MISTER THANK SO MUCH
REPRESENTS THE BOARD TO. IN L.
A. GIVE OUR- TO- HOW MITCHELL
AS WE MISTER ALOT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISS CAREER LET'S GO
TO. OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BY
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ARE ALMOST AFTERNOON-
CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SIMONE CORRECTLY AND
I'M WITH JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES
FOR YOU I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
COALITION OF MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS. IN SUPPORT OF AN
EIGHTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR ONE THREE
BUDGETS AND INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BILL PAYING HER
RENT AND REDUCE DR NEW
HOMELESSNESS AT THE PER DAY WE
DO NEED TO. GIVE ME FUNDING SET
ASIDE TO ADDRESS YOU COME WITH
THE GENERALLY AND WE ALSO NEED
TO TARGET. AFTER BECAUSE THAT
HOW ACT THE POPULATION IS OF
THE- HOMELESSNESS. TO CO WOULD
TRAINING FOR CHILD WELFARE
WORKERS AND PROBATION OFFICERS
ARE HELPING IN THE HOMELESS
RESPONSE SYSTEM. AND WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
HOUSING INTERVENTIONS. WE KNOW
WORK WITH THE POPULATION LIKE%
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING COUPLED
WITH COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT
SERVICES. AND THAT CURRENTLY
HAVE A WAITING LIST OF OVER
FIVE HUNDRED NEW STATEWIDE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
HOPE THAT YOU CAN JOIN US THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
ONE THREE. THANKS FOR HANGING
WITH THIS AMOUNT PREFIX YOUR
PHONE. CALL TODAY THAT'S GOING
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. LINE NUMBER
EIGHT YOUR HONOR OPEN TO GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS MAX PERRY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF WEST SACRAMENTO- WOULD LIKE
TO ASK YOU TO COMMENT THAT CAME
UP FOR ME AND ALSO OFFER A
SUPPORT FOR AN ON GOING FUNDING
SOURCE FOR HOMELESSNESS HOUSING
PROGRAMS. IS LAID OUT IN AB
SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS FOR
YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY WE'RE
GRATEFUL SIX COLOR PLEASE
MATTER MODERATOR. AND AT THE
TIME SAID SURE THERE WAS NO ONE
ELSE DID YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO A LAST CALL THIS
IS GOING TO BE A LAST CALL FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO COMMENT EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR WITH THE ACCESS CODE
OF TWO NINE SIX ONE EIGHT FOUR
TWO LAST CALL IF YOU CAN MAKE A
LAST CALL MADAM MODERATOR. TO
ALL THE Q. IF YOU WISH TO MAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO. THAT'S ONE
ZERO NOW. THERE WERE MOMENTS
HERE WE DO HAVE SOMEONE SHOWING
UP. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS WE
PREPARE AT FOR OUR LAST
COMMENTS WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH TO EACH
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFFS FOR ALL
OF THEIR WORK WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO. JONATHAN AND ERIN
AND CICELY- ALL THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS- AND HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THE PARTNERSHIP-
THAT'S GO TO MADAME MODERATOR
FOR OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE ANOTHER PERSON
QUEUING UP AS WELL BUT LINE
NUMBER THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON LEARNING RATHER MY
NAME IS VERONICA LEWIS WITH. I
THINK THAT I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE BRING BACK BRING HOME
COALITION CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY ONE I STRONGLY URGE
THE LEADERS WHO AN ONGOING.
TWENTY FIRST BEHIND THE PROGRAM.
BUDGET ORGANIZATIONAL KEEPS
PEOPLE PEOPLE IS VERY
INFORMALITY IN. IMPACT OF NOT
HAVING AT THE SAME FUNDING. FOR
TOO LONG BECAUSE PRACTICAL WITH
THE PPL PROGRAM. SOME OF WHICH-
HAVE BEEN LKE PARTICLES WITH
MY WORKING TODAY OPERATES THE
LOOK AT THE NOW AND BUT NOT
APPROACH WORKED EXTENDED THE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. STATE
HOUSING. PARTICIPATING BECAUSE
OF CALL THE NINE. THAT NUMBER
IMPORTANT I THINK THE EVERYDAY
AND I KNOW THAT BECAUSE
OPERATED A CONFIRMING PROGRAM.
AS WELL IN PARTICULAR FOR
COMING AND PEOPLE OF COLOR YEAH
LAST WEEK THAT THEY HONOR THE
HOME LATER TOTALLY. THAT WE
NEED A PERMIT SOLUTION.
GOVERNOR NATHAN AND HAD COFFEE
PERMANENT TO HOMELESSNESS IT'S
NEVER BEEN MORE. WELL WE
CURRENCY CAN ASK IF THEY ACT
NOW PASS THE HEALTH HOME. ALL
THE LEGISLATION. EIGHTY SEVENTY
ONE THANK SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR AT YOUR TODAY
THANKS FOR WITH US LET'S GO OUR
NEXT CALL IN MODERATOR IF YOU
WANT TO TELL US MANY FOLKS ARE
IN THE QUEUE. IT'S IS THE LAST.
IS THE CHAIR. ALL RIGHT LAYS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEES. WILL BE OUR
LAST. COM OF THE DAY THAT
AMOUNT. AT THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
LINE NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOU WANT
OPEN PLEASE GO OUT. THANK YOU
KRISTIN HOW IT. CHILDREN'S
RIGHT TO YOUR SAID FOR SENATOR
WIENER SB TWO THIRTY FOUR WHICH
CREATES A FORGIVABLE LOAN
PROGRAM WHICH WE USE TO CREATE
A HOUSING ACQUIRE EXISTING
HOUSING PREVIOUS BETWEEN THE
AGES OF SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SIX
ARE CURRENTLY OR FORMERLY FOUR
MILLION FOSTER CARE.
EXPERIENCING ALMOST FIFTEEN
YEARS UNDER PROBATION
SUPERVISION. THIS WE'LL CREATE.
A AND TO THE PIPELINE TO
CHRONICLE OF CESAREAN PEOPLE WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KRISTIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMON THANKS FOR HANGING
WITH US LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE COMMITTEES WE WANT TO SAY A
BIG THANK YOU TO EACH AND
EVERYONE ONE OF. EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU ALL WHO HAVE
BEEN STICKING WITH US OUT FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING EIGHT THIRTY
THIS MORNING. SPECIAL THANK YOU
SAID TODAY WE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SENATOR CAFIERO THAT
FROM BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE FOR
HER PARTNERSHIP HER LEADERSHIP
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR. HURTADO THE CHAIRWOMAN
OF THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THIS WOULD NOT HAPPEN
WITHOUT- THAT SENATOR TITLE
COPYRIGHT WILL SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR EGGMAN THE CHAIRWOMAN.
OF THE SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE. FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND PARTNERSHIP ON
THIS HEARING IN OF COURSE TO-
MY GOOD FRIEND SENATOR WIENER
FROM THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
ON THIS CRITICAL HEARING AGAIN
WE HAVE FOLLOW UP TODAY THERE
WILL BE A BRIEF EMAIL THAT WILL
BE SCHEDULED WITH EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS. EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THE
HOMELESS DATA INTEGRATION
SYSTEM- AND ANY OTHER ITEMS
THAT YOU WILL NEED TO FOLLOW UP
ON PLEASE LET US KNOW WE'D LIKE
TO BE TO WORK WITH YOU. AND
THEN FINALLY THIS IS THE SECOND
YEAR IN A ROW IT STARTED WITH
SENATOR WIENER IN CENTER HER
TITLE ON MYSELF LAST YEAR. THAT
YOU CAN FULLY EXPECT THAT WE
HAVE AN ANNUAL HEARING ON
HOMELESSNESS AT A MINIMUM IN
THE YEARS TO COME AS IN GERMAN.
THIS MULTI COMMITTEE HEARING.
IS NOW ADJOURNED THANKS FOR ALL
YOUR WORK.